THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
BUDGET IN FISCAL REVIEW WILL
COME TO ORDER GOOD MORNING. IN
RESPONSE TO THE CODE NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERING THAT IN HERE TO
SOCIAL DISTANCING AND FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES. IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. WE'RE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE IN THE
CAPITAL SOME OF OUR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS PARTICIPATING REMOTELY
THIS MORNING TODAY WE HAVE FOUR
SEVENTIES BELL HER TADO LEYVA
AND REQUIRE. SENATORS IF YOU
HAVE SUPPORT STAFF WITH YOU CAN
YOU PLEASE IDENTIFY THEM NOW.
GOOD MORNING MADAM BUDGET SHARE
THIS IS SENATOR LEYVA I HAVE MY
DISTRICT DIRECTOR MANNIX ALSO
WITH ME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
CENTER LEYVA GOOD TO SEE YOU.
ANYWAY ELSE. OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE ALSO HAVE
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THE LADY
ALICE OFFICE AND OTHER STATE
DEPARTMENT REPS AND SUBJECT
MATTER PANELISTS WHO ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY. FOR OUR
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS
PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE YOUR
PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS WILL
GREATLY AID ELIMINATING ANY
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK I ASK THAT
EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO BE
RECOGNIZED THE TO USE THE RAISE
YOUR HANDS FEATURE IN THE
PROGRAM. ALL THE MONITORING
HERE ON THE LAPTOPS WILL BE
ABLE TO SEE WHEN YOU HIT THE
RAISE YOUR HAND- BUTTON. EACH
TIME YOU RECOGNIZE TO SPEAK A
POP UP WINDOW WILL APPEAR
ASKING IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO UN
MUTE. PLEASE SELECT ON MUTE
BEFORE YOU BEGIN SPEAKING R. I.
T. PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU BACK
ON MUTE WHEN YOU'RE DONE ONCE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE
SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON THE
SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME AND THEN
YOU ARE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING
ROOMS TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW
IT WILL BE USED IN A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY- FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT TO PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED. ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEB. IT WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND I
WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW HOWEVER.
FY I WE WILL NOT BE TAKING
PUBLIC COMMENT UNTIL THE END OF
THIS MORNING'S AGENDA. I
ANTICIPATE BASED ON HOW LONG WE
WILL GO WITH QUESTIONS THAT
COULD BE APPROXIMATELY ELEVEN
THIRTY FOR THE MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC UNDERSTAND WHAT POINT IN
TIME. WE'LL BE READY TO HEAR
FROM THEM. AGAIN TODAY'S
PARTICIPANTS PHONE NUMBER IS
EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE
SIX THREE SIX FOUR AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS NINE EIGHT ONE.
ZERO NINE SEVEN NINE. FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TO WORK PLEASE
REFER TO THE SENATE AND OR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. PLEASE NOTE
THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO HEAR
YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTE THE
DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER YOUR PHONE. IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND WE THANK YOU. I
WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING
THE HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY AND
ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO IS
DISRUPTIVE WILL BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE OR
HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED.
WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN
MADE TO STREAMLINE THE HEARING
PROCESS A CONDUCTOR HEARINGS
AND AS CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER
AS IS CUSTOMARY THERE MAY BE
SOME LAG TIME FOR PARTICIPANTS
WHO ARE ADJUSTING TO THE NEW
USE OF ONLINE TOOLS OR
TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL IMPATIENCE SO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE HEARD.
THIS MORNING'S HEARING WILL
FOCUS ON TWO ISSUES FIRST WILL
RECEIVE AN UPDATE. ON THE
STATE'S COLBERT NINETEEN
RELATED SPENDING. INCLUDING
EXPENDITURES TO DATE. THE LEVEL
OF FUNDING THAT'S INCLUDED IN
THE CURRENT BUDGET. AND THE
MECHANICS OF HOW FUNDING IS
ACCESS AND SPENDING DECISIONS
ARE MADE. NEXT WE WILL HEAR AN
OVERVIEW OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO CLOSE THE DIVISION
OF JUVENILE JUSTICE AS WELL AS
AN ALTERNATIVE PROPOSAL
DEVELOPED BY LEAD STAFF. BEFORE
WE BEGIN WE'RE GOING TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM THIS IS
STEPHANIE SHOP PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. SENATORS MITCHELL
PRESIDENT NELSON AIR BILL.
CABALLERO DOLLY. THE RAZA HERE.
HER DAUGHTER. LEYVA HERE. HERE
MCGUIRE. MCGUIRE HERE REMOTELY.
MELENDEZ MORNING HERE ORLOK
RESIDENT MORALE. PAN HERE. ROTH.
SKINNER STERN. WHY COUNTY HERE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE
CONSULTANT NOTICES THE PRESENCE
OF A QUORUM SO LET'S GO HEAD
BEGAN WITH OUR FIRST ISSUE A
VERY IMPORTANT ONE TO THE
RESIDENTS OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ALL OF US AS
LEGISLATORS IT'S THAT COLD AT
NINETEEN SPENDING. WITH US- WE
CAN HEAR BOTH FROM THE L. A. L.
AND DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WE'RE
GONNA START WITH MISS PETERS
WITH THE L. A. O. WOULD YOU
LIKE TO BEGIN YOUR PRESENTATION
GOOD MORNING AND THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR AND SENATORS- I HAVE A
PRESENTATION TO SHARE WITH YOU
ON THE SCREEN SO LET ME JUST
PULL THAT UP FOR YOU. RIGHT NOW.
ARE YOU ABLE TO SEE THAT THE
HAND OUT COULD BE NINETEEN
FUNDING OVER VIA. ARE YOU ABLE
TO SEE THAT PRESENTATION
MANAGER. YES I AM THANK YOU
IT'S ON A SCREEN HERE THANK. SO
AND GOOD MORNING AGAIN I'M SO
AS YOUR AGENDA NOTES IN THERE
ARE MULTIPLE SOURCES ON BOTH
STATE AND FEDERAL FUNDS
AVAILABLE FOR DI RACKED AND
INDIRECT KOBE NINETEEN RESPONSE
IN THIS PRESENTATION I'M GOING
TO SPEAK TO THE MORE INDIRECT
STATE FUNDING- ALTHOUGH WE ALSO
HAVE STAFF AVAILABLE TODAY. IF
YOU HAVE QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
FEDERAL FUNDING COMPONENTS.
ASIAN I'M I'M GONNA TALK FIRST
ABOUT WHAT THE FUNDS HAVE BEEN
MADE AVAILABLE TO THE
ADMINISTRATION TO RESPOND TO
THE KOBE NINETEEN PANDEMIC WHAT
THE EXPECTED USES OF THOSE
FUNDS ARE AND THE UNCERTAINTY
AROUND THOSE EXPECTING USED AS-
WELL AS ISSUES FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER
REGARDING OVERSIGHT AT THE
STATE'S EMERGENCY SPENDING. SO
IN THE TURN THAT YOU CAN SEE
HERE ON PAGE WIND WE SUMMARIZE.
THE STATE FUNDING THAT HAS BEEN
PROVIDED IN TWO NINETY. TWENTY
INTO TWENTY TO RESPOND TO THE
KOBE NINETEEN PANDEMIC. AS YOU
CAN SEE IN THE CHART MISTY
AUTHORIZED FOUR POINT TWO
BILLION DOLLARS IN NINETEEN
TWENTY AND ANOTHER ONE POINT
FIVE BILLION IN TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. FOR A TOTAL OF FIVE
POINT SEVEN BILLION IN
AUTHORIZED SPENDING. THERE'S
ALSO OTHER FRIENDS ACCESSIBLE
FOR COULD BE NINETEEN RESPONSE
ON TOP OF THAT FIVE POINT.
SEVEN BILLION THAT'LL TALK
ABOUT IN A MOMENT. I'M THE
FIRST LET ME JUST TO GO THROUGH
THE DIFFERENT SOURCES THAT THE
FIVE POINT SEVEN BILLION COMES
FROM. THERE'S REALLY THREE
DIFFERENT MECHANISMS THAT
PROVIDE THAT SPENDING- FIRST
CONTROL SECTION THIRTY SIX. HI
THIS AYE IT WAS CREATED BY THE
LEGISLATURE IN MARCH JUST
BEFORE THE LEGISLATURE RECESSED
TO OBSERVE THE STATE STATE HOME
WHERE. I AM AND THE LEGISLATURE
SPECIFICALLY APPROPRIATED ONE
BILLION DOLLARS FOR THE STATE'S
CODE RESPONSE- AND MAYBE SPENDS
ASSESSABLE THREE NEW BUDGET
CONTROL SECTION KNOWN AS
CONTROL SECTION THIRTY SECS.
THESE TRENDS ARE AVAILABLE TO
THE MINISTRATION OF
CONDESCENDINGLY TO OUR
NOTIFICATION TO THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET COMMITTEE OR
JAIL WE SEE. THROUGH THIS
PROCESS THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
ALLOCATED. EIGHT HUNDRED AND
TWENTY SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS.
THIS SOURCE FINDING AND THAT
HAS BEEN PROVIDED IS THROUGH
THE DISASTER RESPONSE EMERGENCY
OPERATIONS ACCOUNT OR THREE OUT.
THIS ACCOUNT PROVIDES
ADMINISTRATION ACCESS TO FANS
IN THE STATE RESERVE IS KNOWN
AS A SPECIAL PLAN FOR ECONOMIC
UNCERTAINTIES OUR HOUSE I FEED
YOU- ANY SPENCER AVAILABLE TO
RESPOND TO DECLARE EMERGENCIES
ONCE TRANSFERRED INTO THREE- I
FUNDS ARE CONTINUOUSLY
APPROPRIATED FOR EMERGENCY.
RESPONSE ACTIVITIES
MINISTRATION IS REQUIRED TO
NOTIFY THE GLVC OF TRANSFERS
INTO THREE ELLA BUT THERE'S NO
REQUIREMENTS TO NOTIFY IN THE
LEGISLATURE AT THE ACTUAL
ALLOCATION OR EXPENDITURE OF
FUNDS OUT OF THREE A LOT I MEAN
WE JUST KNOW THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS BEEN
SOMEWHAT INCONSISTENT. IN
PROVIDING- NOT OPTIONAL.
INFORMATION THAT IS NOT
REQUIRED. SPAWNING TO COVER
NINETEEN DEMONSTRATION HAS MADE
TRANSFERS INTO THREE- I
TOTALING THREE POINT TWO
BILLION DOLLARS. I WOULD JUST
KNOW ALSO AND THIS CHART WHAT
WE'RE WE SHOW SOME OF THAT
FUNDS ARE BEING APPROPRIATE-
PROVIDED AUTHORIZED IN TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY I'M BECAUSE
THOSE RIO I DOLLARS IN
PARTICULAR CONTINUOUSLY
APPROPRIATED. THEY CONTINUE TO
BE AVAILABLE TO THE
MINISTRATION EVEN THOUGH WE'RE
IN THE NEW FISCAL YEAR. SOURCE
OF FUNDING- COMES FROM THE
NINETY NINE OH ONE BUDGET ITEM
AS PART OF THE TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET PACKAGE.
SPECIFICALLY THIS ITEM SET
ASIDE ONE POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS TO FIND EXPECTED KOBE
NINETEEN RESPONSE ACTIVITIES.
STRATEGIES THAT DEPARTMENTS ARE
MAYBE WORK PLANNING FOR OR HAD
ALREADY STARTED IN THE PREVIOUS
FISCAL YEAR- AND SO THERE IS AN
ESTIMATE OF THE AMOUNT OF
FUNDING NEEDED IT'S SEVEN
NINETY NINE OF ONE ITEM. AND IS
AVAILABLE I'M TO THE
MINISTRATION TO BE ALLOCATED
OUT TO. AS NEEDED. NOW YOU NEED
TO THAT FIVE SEVEN THAT'S OR
EVEN AUTHORIZED TWENTY TWENTY
ONE BUDGET SET ASIDE EIGHT
SEVEN HUNDRED AND SIXTEEN
MILLION FROM THE ASSET THE YOU
RESERVE BALANCE. FOR COVERT
RESPONSE THIS AMOUNT REPRESENTS
THE SEEDS 25% SHARE OF COST OF
A TOTAL OF TWO POINT NINE
BILLION DOLLARS IN ESTIMATED
CONTINGENCY FUNDING. THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION AT THE TIME THE
BUDGET WAS ENACTED ESTIMATED IT
WOULD NEED. LIMITATION CAN
ACCESS THESE CONTINGENCY. PLANS
THROUGH THE TRAIL ACROSS. NOW
IT OF THE SONS HAVE BEEN ON THE
THROUGH THE VARIOUS CONTROLS.
AND FUNDING PROCESS SEASON IN
THE BUDGET- BUT WE JUST KNOW
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION HAS I'M
PRETTY PROUD SPENDING
AUTHORITIES UNDER THE
CALIFORNIA EMERGENCY SERVICES
ACT WHICH ESSENTIALLY WOULD
ALLOW THE ADMINISTRATION TO
SPEND FUNDS BEYOND THOSE THAT
HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED IN THE
BUDGET SPECIFICALLY I'M
EMERGENCY SERVICES ACT ALSO
PROVIDES VARIOUS OTHER
POSSIBILITIES TO THE
MINISTRATION. TO RESPOND TO AN
ONGOING DECLARED EMERGENCY. SO
FINDING SOURCES THAT ARE
AVAILABLE NEXT DAY WHEN YOU
SPEAK TO HOW THE FUNDS ARE
EXPECTED TO BE SPENT. ON HIM
THE SIGNIFICANCE AND CERTAINTY
AROUND OF THE USE OF THE
STATE'S COVERT RESPONSE
SPENDING. I'M IN THIS CHART WE
SHALL BE AT FIVE POINT SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS THAT WAS
AUTHORIZED- AND AT THE TIME OF
THE BUDGET ENACTMENT. I'M AND
THE ADMINISTRATION'S EXPECTED
USE ABOUT FIVE POINT SEVEN
APPETITE IN THE BUDGET WAS AN
ACCIDENT. I'M OF THE PAGER
REFLECTS THAT IS. WHILE THIS
INFORMATION FROM THE
MINISTRATION AS HELPFUL TO GET
A SENSE TO THE LEGISLATURE. OF
THE TYPES OF ACTIVITIES THAT
MIGHT BE FUNDED FROM THEM THE
FUNDS THAT HAVE BEEN MADE
AVAILABLE. AND IT'S ACTUALLY
SUBJECT TO SOME UNCERTAINTY FOR
A COUPLE OF REASONS. FIRST WE
KNOW THA THE ADMINISTRATION
IDENTIFIED IN SOME CASES FAIRLY
BROAD CATEGORIES OF SPENDING.
AS YOU CAN SEE A HIGHCHARGE ON
THE ADMINISTRATION AT THE TIME
THE BUDGET WAS ENACTED HAD
IDENTIFIED. THREE POINT FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS IN ESTIMATED
FUNDING NEEDED FOR
PROCUREMENTS. I'M HOWEVER DID
NOT COMPREHENSIVELY IDENTIFY
THE MIX OF THINGS THAT WOULD
ACTUALLY. BE PURCHASED WITH
THESE DOLLARS. I'M IN A-
DIMINISHES HAS FLEXIBLE TO RE
ALLOCATE TIMES AMONG SEIZE
CATEGORIES OR EVEN INTO NEW
CATEGORIES THAT IT IDENTIFIES
AS PRIORITIES CHANGE AN ONGOING
RESPONSE TO THE COMING. BACK SO
THE EXPECTED MIX AND THE USE OF
MIND CAN CHANGE- AND ACTUALLY
HAS CHANGED ALREADY ABOUT TALK
ABOUT INA MOMENT AND AS YOU
HEAR ABOUT YOUR NEXT
PRESENTATION FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. SO WHILE
THE- WHY I'M IT SHOWS ME
EXPECTED USED AT THE TIME THE
BUDGET WAS ENACTED AT THE FIVE
POINT SEVEN BILLION HAD BEEN
AUTHORIZED THERE IS STILL THIS
TIME TWO POINT NINE BILLION AN
ESTIMATED ADDITIONAL
EXPENDITURE SUPPORTED BY THAT
SEVEN HUNDRED SIXTY MILLION
ASSETS BE USED ANNEX. NOT THAT
THE BUDGET WAS ENACTED
ADMINISTRATION HAVE NOT
IDENTIFIED I'M EXPECTING USES
FOR ANY AT THIS ADDITIONAL
FUNDING- SUPPORTED BY THE SEVEN
HUNDRED AND SIXTEEN MILLION I'M
AND I INFORMATION HAS NOT BEEN
PROVIDED TO THE LEGISLATURE UP
UNTIL YESTERDAY AFTERNOON WHEN
THE ADMINISTRATION HOSTED- AND
AUGUST FOURTEENTHUPDATE ON TO
THAT- THAT PROVIDED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I'M
DETAILING IT'S EXPECTED HOUSTON
UPDATED EXPECTED USE OF THE
COPING NINETEEN TIMES.
INCLUDING I'M PROVIDING SOME
INFORMATION ON IT IT'S EXPECTED
USE OF. THESE ADDITIONAL
CONTINGENCY FUNDS. I'M THE
ARTIST DATE PROVIDED BY THE OF
FINE. AND PROVIDES. DIFFERENTLY
FOR HOW IT MIGHT SOME OF THESE
CONTINGENCY FUNDS DAY INDICATES
THAT DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HAD
INITIALLY DEVELOPED PLANS FOR
SPENDING THAT YOU PULL THAT THE
FULL TWO POINT NINE BILLION
DOLLARS- I'M HOWEVER ADDED THAT
CURRENT PLAN AND THAT. TIME HAS
BEEN POSTING INDICATES THAT
THEY'VE DEVELOPED NOW ONLY ONE
POINT SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS OUT
OF EXPECTED TO USE UP THE SIGNS
LEAVING AN ADDITIONAL ONE POINT
TWO BILLION DOLLARS BACK. HI
THERE MIGHT NOT BE USED FOR THE
EXPECTED USE HAS NOT YET. BEEN
IDENTIFIED FOR ACT. NOW WITH
THE EVERY PROVIDED IN THAT
UPDATE FROM YESTERDAY THE
INFORMATION ON THE PLAN YOU
SAID THESE FINDINGS I'M HAS
CHANGED CONSIDERABLY. SO THE
LEGISLATURE HAVE RECEIVED BACK
IN MAY ON MAY TWENTY FIRST AN
UPDATE FROM THE ADMINISTRATION
ON IT'S EXPECTED USE OF FINES
AND THAT'S WHAT WAS KNOWN AT
THE TIME OF THE BUDGET AND
REFLECTED IN THE PICTURE ON THE
PREVIOUS SLIDE. UPDATE FROM
YESTERDAY PROVIDES- PRETTY
SIGNIFICANTLY DIFFERENT
EXPECTED USES OF THE FANS I'M
IN. REALLY LASSEN THREE MONTHS
TIME. FOR EXAMPLE THE
MINISTRATION AND ANTICIPATES
NOW SPENDING ONE POINT ONE
BILLION DOLLARS I'M STATE
RESPONSE OPERATIONS. THIS IS
ABOUT NINE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS MORE THAN THE LEVEL FOR
THIS ACTIVITY THAT WAS
IDENTIFIED BACK IN BANG.
SIMILARLY THE AUGUST ACTING
ANTICIPATES SPENDING FIVE
HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS ON HOTEL HOTELS FOR
HEALTH CARE WORKERS. THIS IS A
FIVE HUNDRED AND FORTY FIVE
MILLION MORE THAN THE ONLY
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS THAT
HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED FOR THIS
ACTIVITY BACK IN MAY SO REALLY
JUST OVER THE COURSE OF THE
LAST COUPLE OF MONTHS AND THE
PLANNED EXPENDITURE OF THE
SENATE. HAS CHANGED PRETTY
CONSIDERABLY. SO SIGNIFICANT
LEVEL OF. THAT THE MINISTRATION
HAS TO ALLOCATE TIMES INDIAN
CERTAINTY AROUND THE ACTUAL
USE- OF THE LEGISLATURE MAY
WANT TO CONSIDER THE NEED FOR
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION TO
FACILITATE OVERSIGHT AND THE
RECENTLY PROVIDED. KOBE
NINETEEN FUNDING. NOW THE
MINISTRATION AS WE'VE INDICATED
HAS QUITE A BIT OF FLEXIBILITY
YOUR EXISTING STATE LAW AS WELL
AS THROUGH THE FUNDS PROVIDED
IN BY. I'M THIS IS REASONABLE
ND WAS PROVIDED RIGHT. IN
ORDER TO GET THE MINISTRATION
FLEXIBILITY TO RESPOND TO A
CHANGING AND EVOLVING
SITUATION- AND SO THAT
FLEXIBILITY AND- IS REALLY
NECESSARY. AT LEAST SOME DEGREE
OF FLEXIBILITY FOR THE
MINISTRATIONS TO BE NIMBLE
ENOUGH AND FLEXIBLE ENOUGH TO
RESPOND. I ASK THAT COULD BE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC CONTINUES TO
EVOLVE AND YOU NEEDS ARE
DEVELOPED- AND. AND BECOME
KNOWN OVER TIME. HOW BECAUSE
FLEXIBILITY THAT MINISTRY HAS.
HI THE LEGISLATURE REALLY KIND
OF LACKS ADEQUATE INFORMATION
ON. HOW THE FANS- ARE CLEAN TO
BE SPENT AND ARE ACTUALLY BEING
SPENT BECAUSE WE'RE NOT GETTING
THE TYPE OF INFORMATION YOU
WOULD GET NORMALLY HAVE WHEN
FUNDS ARE AFFECTED IN THE STATE
BUDGET- WHERE YOU HAVE A SENSE
OF THE TYPES OF PROGRAMS AND
ACTIVITIES THAT ARE GOING TO BE
FUNDED AND THERE'S MORE
RESTRICTIONS PLACED ON THE USE
OF THOSE FUNDS. I'M I SAID
BEFORE THE MOST RECENT
INFORMATION ON HOW THE
ADMINISTRATION PLANS TO
ALLOCATE FUNDS WAS PROVIDED
JUST YESTERDAY. AND IDENTIFY
SIGNIFICANTLY DIFFERENT
SPENDING LEVELS OVERALL.
PRIORITIES AND THOSE IDENTIFIED
ONLY A FEW MONTHS AGO IN THE
LEGISLATURE WAS MAKING BUDGET
DECISIONS. COPING NINETEEN
FRIENDS HAVE ACTUALLY BEEN
SPANKED THE INFORMATION HAS ALL
FOCUSED ON B. I'M PLANNED
ALLOCATION BUT NOT WHAT
ACTUALLY HAS HAPPENED WITH. I.
WE FIND THAT ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION IS NEEDED TO
FACILITATE LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT HAVING REGULARLY
UPDATED INFORMATION ON THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PLAN
ALLOCATION OF FUNDS WILL BE
IMPORTANT FOR THE LEGISLATURE
TO CONDUCT OVERSIGHT
ADMINISTRATION'S PRIORITY AND
ITS OVERALL APPROACH IN
RESPONDING TO THE CODE NINETY
EVER. WHICH CAN SHIFT QUICKLY.
SIMILARLY UNDERSTANDING THE
ACTUAL EXPENDITURES THE FANS
WILL BE IMPORTANT FOR COPING
NINETEEN OVERSIGHT FOR A COUPLE
OF REASONS. FIRST THE PIECE OF
WHICH THE ADMINISTRATION IS
SPENDING IT'S CALLED THE
RESPONSE FANS WILL BE IMPORTANT
TO TRACK FOR EXAMPLE I SPENDING
IS OCCURRING VERY RAPIDLY THIS
COULD POINT TO THE NEED FOR
POTENTIAL ADDITIONAL FUNDING
BEYOND THE LEVEL BUDGET IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. ON THE OTHER
HAND IF SPENDING IS OCCURRING
RELATIVELY SLOWLY- THIS COULD
ACTUALLY INDICATE SOME
POTENTIAL ADMINISTRATIVE
BARRIERS WERE CONCERNS ABOUT
THE STATE'S RESPONSE TO THE
PANDEMIC THAT WOULD MERIT
LEGISLATIVE ATTENTION. SECOND
THE LEGISLATURE WANNA
UNDERSTAND HOW ACTUAL
EXPENDITURES ALIGNED WITH THE
PLANNED USES THE FINEST AND
MINISTRATION HAS INDICATED. AND
WHETHER THE EXPENDITURES BEING
MADE ARE ELIGIBLE FOR FEDERAL
FEMA REIMBURSEMENTS AND THE
PIECE OF RECEIVING THOSE
REIMBURSEMENTS I WOULD NOTE
THAT AN UPDATE POSTED YESTERDAY
BY THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
AND ADMINISTRATION INDICATE
SOME OF ITS PLANNED
EXPENDITURES WILL BE FULLY
SUPPORTED BY THE GENERAL FUND
AND ARE. NOT ELIGIBLE FOR FEMA
REIMBURSEMENT. NOW EXPENDITURE
INFORMATION IS GOING TO BE
HELPFUL TO THE LEGISLATURE IN
ASSESSING THE ADMINISTRATION'S
OVERALL SPENDING DECISIONS AND
HOW THAT'S IMPACTING THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE RESPONSE
TO BE EMERGENCY. SO IN MY NEED
FOR ADDITIONAL INFORMATION WE
HAVE SEVERAL REPORTING OPTIONS
TO HIGHLIGHT TO IMPROVE THE
OVERSIGHT OF WHAT THE PLAN
ALLOCATION OF FUNDS YEAH ON THE
ACTUAL EXPENDITURE OF FUNDS. SO
FIRST FOR THE PLAN ALLOCATION
OF FUNDS THE LEGISLATURE COULD
CONSIDER SOME WHITE LAST FORMAL
TYPES OF REPORTING SECTION AS
REQUESTING THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION OFFER MEMBER
BRIEFINGS TO INTERESTED MEMBERS
OF THE LEGISLATURE- KEY POINTS%
SUCH AS BEFORE AWARDING MAJOR
CONTRACTS- WE WOULD NOTE THAT
WE'VE HEARD FROM THE STAFF THAT.
THAT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION HAS BEEN
PROVIDING SAM I'M PERIODIC
UPDATES TO CERTAIN MEMBERS AND
STAFF AND WE'VE HEARD THAT THAT
INFORMATION HAS BEEN HELPFUL.
ANOTHER OPTION THAT THE
LEGISLATURE CAN CONSIDER. TO
HAVE MORE INFORMATION THE
PLANNED OF FUNDS WOULD BE TO
REQUIRE OR REQUIRE A MORE OF A
FORMAL WRITTEN NOTIFICATION
SIMILAR TO THE TYPE OF
NOTIFICATION THAT WOULD BE
PROVIDED. FOR FUNDING THAT GOES
THROUGH THE GLVC SUCH AS TREE
OR TRANSFERS. THE LARGEST.
COULD I'M REQUIRE OR REQUEST A
DEMONSTRATION PROVIDE UPDATES
SIMILAR TO THE ONE PROVIDED ON
MAY TWENTY FIRST AND YESTERDAY.
TO UPDATE ON THE PLANNED
ALLOCATION OF FRIENDS AND HOW
THAT CHANGES AND I CAN BE
PROVIDED ON A REGULARLY
SCHEDULED BASIS OF THE
LEGISLATURE KNOWLEDGE WINDOWS
UPDATES ARE COMING AND CAN PLAN
ITS OVERSIGHT ACTIVITIES AROUND.
THE NEW INFORMATION THAT IS
PROVIDED. IN ADDITION WE WANT
TO PROVIDE SOME OPTIONS TO
IMPROVE THE OVERSIGHT OF THE
ACTUAL EXPENDITURES SO THE-
PATIENT THAT'S REALLY SORT OF
YOUR FRONTEND ACCOUNTABILITY OF
HOW HIS ADMINISTRATION EXPECT
TO USE THE SIGNS. UP REPORTING
ON THE ACTUAL EXPENDITURES IS
SORT OF MORE OF A BACK IN
ACCOUNTABILITY THAT LACKS THE
LEGISLATURE- NO HEALTH PLANS
ARE ACTUALLY BEING SPENT AND
THE PACE OF THERE BEING SACKED-
AND WHETHER THAT ALIGNS WITH
WHAT THE ADMINISTRATION. HAD
INDICATED OR ITS PLANS. I'M SO
A COUPLE DIFFERENT WAYS THAT
YOU COULD- REQUEST OR REQUIRE
THE ADMINISTRATION TO. REPORTS
ON ACTUAL EXPENDITURES THE
LEGISLATURE COULD CONSIDER AS
SOME SORT OF- ROUTINE REPORTING
SUCH AS MONTHLY OR QUARTERLY
EXPENDITURE REPORTS- EVEN KNOWS
THAT SINCE EARLY APRIL THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
REQUIRED ALL STATE AGENCIES TO
REPORT ON THEIR CLOTHING
NINETEEN RELATED COSTS. AND SO
THEY'RE COLLECTING A LOT OF
THIS INFORMATION ALREADY AND SO
IT IT DOESN'T SEEM UNREASONABLE
TO REQUEST THAT THEY SHARE A
SUMMARY OF THAT INFORMATION
THAT THEY COLLECT ALREADY WITH
THE LEGISLATURE. I'M AND WE
WOULD JUST NOTE THAT THESE-
EXPENDITURE RECORDS COULD BE
COMBINED WITH REPORTING ON THE
PLAN ALLOCATION OF FUNDS AS
WELL SO THAT THE LEGISLATURE IS
GETTING A COMPLETE PICTURE. I'M
ANOTHER APPROACH IF YOU DIDN'T
WANT TO HAVE MONTHLY OR
QUARTERLY EXPENDITURE REPORTS.
ON YOU COULD HAVE MAYBE A LESS
FREQUENT REPORTING SUCH AS
HAVING TRIGGERING A REPORT
EVERY TEN ADMINISTRATION HITS A
CERTAIN THRESHOLD AT THAT LEVEL
OF FUNDS SPENT SO FOR EXAMPLE
WHEN THEY SPENT TWENTY FIVE OR
FIFTY OR SEVENTY FIVE. PERCENT
OF THE FUNDS. REPORTING OPTIONS
THAT I WANTED TO SHARE WE THINK
COULD HELP FACILITATE IMPROVED
INFORMATION NEEDED FOR
OVERSIGHT OF THE RECENTLY
PROVIDED. CO IN NINETEEN. NOW
WELL IT'S NOT DIRECTLY RELATED
TO THE OVERSIGHT OF THESE
RECENTLY PROVIDED FRIENDS WE
WANT TO SHARE SOME INFORMATION
WITH YOU. THAT WE FEEL IS ALSO
AN IMPORTANT ISSUE THAT HAS
COME TO OUR ATTENTION DURING
OUR REVIEW OF NOT ONLY THE
COPING NINETEEN EMERGENCY
FUNDING REQUEST BUT ALSO OTHER
EMERGENCY FUNDING REQUEST OVER
THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS. WITH
MAJOR WILDFIRES AND CIVIL
DISTURBANCE ISSUES. FROM
SPECIFICALLY IT'S CONTRARY
TENSION THAT THE STATE HAS I'M
NUMEROUS AN OVERLAPPING
EMERGENCY SPENDING AUTHORITIES
THIS IS THROUGH THE- EMERGENCY
SERVICES ACTING AS WELL AS
STREAMLINED TIME AND DIFFERENT
BUDGET PROCESS SEES. THESE VERY
EMERGENCY SPENDING AUTHORITIES
APPEAR TO CREATE DIFFERENT
MECHANISMS OF SPENDING
AUTHORITY THAT COULD ALLOW. FOR
SIGNIFICANTLY DIFFERENT LEVELS
OF TRANSPARENCY AND LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT DEPENDING ON THE
DISASTER AND THE AUTHORITY THAT
DIMINISHING IN MINISTRATION SHE
JUST YEARS IN ANY. GIVEN
PARTICULAR EMERGENCY. ARMENIANS
AUTHORITIES HAVE BEEN AND STATE
LAW FOR DECADES AND SOME OF
THEM HAVE BEEN RARELY USE. SO
THE LEGISLATURE MAY WANT TO
CONSIDER JUST LOOKING TOWARDS
THE FUTURE- TO CONSIDER IN
EVALUATING THE EXISTING
EMERGENCY SPENDING AUTHORITIES
THAT ARE ON THE BOOKS AND
CONSIDER SOME MORE BROAD AND
LONGER TERM CHANGES. TO HELP
FACILITATE OVERSIGHT AND FUTURE
EMERGENCY RESPONSES FONG. AND
WENT BACK AND HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISS PETERS I HAVE A QUICK
QUESTION BEFORE ALL OPENED UP
TO- MEMBERS BRIEFLY BEFORE WE
THEN HEAR FROM DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND CHIEF FINANCIAL. TO
RESPOND TO ELIGIBLE FOR THEIR
PRESENTATION I PRE THE VERY.
OPTIONS YOU US FOR REPORTING DO
YOU HAVE A RECOMMENDATION ON
THE FREQUENCY OF REPORTING THAT
WE SHOULD ANTICIPATE OR EVEN
ASK FOR. I'M A WE DON'T HAVE A
SPECIFIC RECOMMENDATION I THINK
HE WANTED TO PROVIDE DIFFERENT
OPTIONS. THAT YOU COULD
CONSIDER IN YOUR DISCUSSIONS
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION. WE
WOULD NOTE I THINK AS I SAID
BEFORE THE ADMINISTRATION IS
COLLECTING EXPENDITURE DATA ON
A MONTHLY BASIS AND SO. I AM
REQUESTING UPDATES MORE
FREQUENTLY THAN THAT PROBABLY
WOULDN'T MAKE SENSE- BUT
MONTHLY UPDATES AND SEEM LIKE
THEY COULD BE REASONABLE. YOU
COULD ALSO CONSIDER QUARTERLY
UPDATES ALTHOUGH WE WOULDN'T
KNOW THAT IT'S BEEN BASS IN
THREE MONTHS FROM THE MAY
TWENTY FIRST UPDATE TO THE
UPDATE THAT WAS POSTED
YESTERDAY. AND QUITE A LOT HAS
CHANGED IN A HURRY AND SO
YOU'RE GONNA WANT TO CONSIDER
YOUR COMFORT LEVEL WITH. AND
HOW MUCH INFORMATION CAN CHANGE
PRETTY RAPIDLY AND BALANCE THAT
WITH THE EMAIL THE
MINISTRATIONS ABILITY TO SHARE
REPORTING INFORMATION. IT'S
GOING TO BE IMPORTANT FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO HAVE UP TO DATE
INFORMATION THAT HASN'T GONE
STALE. AND IN ORDER TO BE ABLE
TO FACILITATE YOUR OVERSIGHT
ACTIVITIES I'M ESPECIALLY AS
YOU LOOK IN THE COMING MONTHS
IN THE LEGISLATURE IS OUT OF
SESSION I'M HAVING THAT ROUTINE
INFORMATION OF THE HELPFUL.
THANK YOU SENATOR MORE LOT.
THANK MADAM CHAIR AND JUSTICE
CLEAR EITHER DO QUICK QUESTIONS
FOR L. FOR WE HEAR FROM FINANCE
OF THE EXACTIONS OF THE
PRESENTATION EXACTLY. MISS
PETERS WHO SIGNS THE CHECKS. I
THE FINES AND YOU WE CAN ASK
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCES FOR A
MORE TECHNICAL ASPECTS RENDERED
ARE DISTRIBUTED BY THE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE- BY IN
TERMS AS- I THINK WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO HIGHLIGHT IN OUR
PRESENTATION IS THE FLEXIBILITY
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION AND
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HAS. IN
DETERMINING HOW TO ALLOCATE
FUNDS TO DEPARTMENTS- AND
REALLY AUTHORIZED DEPARTMENTS
TO GO FORWARD WITH SPENDING ON
IT VARIOUS ACTIVITIES INTERNAL
ACTIVITIES OR CONTRACTS. THAT
THEY NEED MAYBE PURSUING OKAY
THE REASON I ASK IS I COME FROM
A COUNTY MODEL WHERE AN AUDITOR
CONTROLLER WOULD PROBABLY GIVE
SOME PUSH BACK TO US. THE BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS FOR CERTAIN
TYPES OF SPENDING. I DIDN'T SEE
THE CONTROLLER MENTIONED ONCE
IN YOUR REPORT AND I'M JUST
WONDERING. IF ISSUE. JUST
SIGNING CHECKS WITHOUT. ANY
PUSH BACK OR QUESTIONING AND NO
REPORTING IT WHY WHY ISN'T THAT
THE CONTROLLER PROVIDING US. A
WEEKLY REPORTS OF EXPENDITURES
HI. OR OR OR IS THE DEPARTMENT
FINANCIAL SIGNING THEIR OWN
pKNOW RISK YOU HAVE TO FIGURE
OUT IF AN AUDIT FIRM COMES IN
AND- TELLS US WHAT HAPPENED A
YEAR OR TWO LATER. I'M WHERE
ARE YOU CAN OBVIOUSLY ASK THE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE FOR
INFORMATION ON THEIR INTERNAL
PROCESS THESE- BUT I THINK THE
POINT THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
HIGHLIGHT IS THAT EXISTING
STATE LAW AS WELL AS THAT. AND
FLEXIBILITY PROVIDED IN THE
BUDGET ALLOWS THE
ADMINISTRATION TO MAKE A LOT OF
THESE DECISIONS AROUND HOW TO
ALLOCATE THE FUNDS. AND YOU
KNOW AS THE COMPTROLLER'S
OFFICE IS GOING TO CHECK AND
MAKE SURE THAT THERE'S
AUTHORIZATION AND THIS IS AN
ALLOWABLE EXPENDITURE THERE'S
AN APPROPRIATION ATTACHED TO
IT- AND SO I GUESS THE POINT
WE'RE TRYING TO MAKE IS THAT
THERE THERE IS A LOT OF
FLEXIBILITY TO THE
ADMINISTRATION. TO MAKE THOSE
DETERMINATIONS- WHERE THAT THE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE WOULD SAY
YES THERE'S JUST YOU KNOW.
THANKS TO DELIVER IN THE LOT
OTHERS AN APPROPRIATE THERE'S
MONEY SET ASIDE IN THESE
VARIOUS ITEMS- AND SO. YOU KNOW
YOU COULDN'T YOU CAN CERTAINLY
FOLLOW UP THE COMPTROLLER'S
OFFICE TO ASK MORE ABOUT THEIR
SPECIFIC PROCESS BUT AND- YOU
KNOW IN TERMS OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S. DECISION
MAKING AUTHORITY OVER HOW TO
SPEND THE FUNDS THEY HAVE A
GREAT DEAL FLEXIBILITY UNDER
THE LAW. BOETTICHER A LOT OF US
VIEW THE CONTROLLER AS A
PROTECTOR OF TAXPAYERS THAT'S
WHY WE ELECT. A STATE
CONTROLLER AND MAYBE IN THE
FUTURE WE CAN HAVE THE STATE
COMPTROLLER PROVIDE. A REPORT
BECAUSE OF THEIR INVOLVEMENT
WITH THIS WHOLE PROCESS AND-
YOU KNOW JUST SIGNING CHECKS
BLINDLY WITHOUT. ASKING
QUESTIONS IS A LITTLE
DISCONCERTING TO ME SO MAYBE IN
THE FUTURE WE COULD INCLUDE HER
ON AN AGENDA THANK YOU MADAM I
APPRECIATE YOUR QUESTION
PERSPECTIVE AND I THINK WE ALSO
NEED TO BE CLEAR ABOUT YOU KNOW
THE AUTHORITY UNDER THE LAW
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
BEEN GIVEN THREE TRAIL AND
OTHERS TO EVEN FIGURE OUT IF
THE- IF THE CONTROLLER IS ROLE-
IT. IS THE SAME IN THESE
INSTANCES SO WE PROBABLY NEED
TO HAVE SOME CLARIFICATION MAKE-SURE ALL MEMBERS UNDERSTAND AT
WHAT POINT THE CONTROLLER
SHOULD WEIGH IT OR NOT SO I
APPRECIATE THE QUESTION SENATOR
NELSON. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. AND I'M- GONNA FIND
A PREFACE. WHAT WOULD BE
QUESTION TO HELP FINANCE WILL
ANSWER ON THEIR OWN COULD YOU
PUT A REMARKABLE CULTURE PLEASE
SIR. THERE WE GO THAT BETTER
YES SIR YES I'M GOING TO
PREFACE. QUESTIONS THAT COULD
BE POSED TO FINANCE. WITH THEIR
PORTION BUT I'D RATHER THAT
THEY ADDRESS IT ON THEIR OWN. I
AM EXTREMELY ALARMED AT THE
AMOUNT OF AUTHORITY THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS CEDED TO THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OF TAXPAYER MONEY IS
BEING SPENT. AND WHAT WE'VE NOW
DISCERNED FROM THE ANALYST
REPORT. IS THE ADMINISTRATION
UNILATERALLY HAS CHANGED THE
PRIORITIES. AND THERE'S BEEN NO
REGULAR REPORTING. TO THE
LEGISLATURE. I ARGUE THAT MUST
BE REQUIRED SO I'M GOING TO ASK
THEN FINANCE TO ADDRESS ONE
THEIR TURN AT BAT COMES. WHAT
ARE THEY DOING TO GIVE US MORE
INFORMATION. AND THE ABILITY OF
THE LEGISLATURE TO BATCH IF WE
ARE NOT IN ACCORD WITH THE
PRIORITIES ESTABLISHED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION THIS IS ALMOST
AWESOME AND FRIGHTENING THE
AMOUNT OF POWER. AND THE AMOUNT
OF CHANGES THAT THIS
ADMINISTRATION CAN EFFECT OF
THROUGH THE AUTHORITIES THAT WE
HAVE CEDED TO THEM SO I WOULD
LIKE TO THEM AS THEY TALK ABOUT
IT WHAT ARE THEY GONNA DO
PROSPECTIVELY. AND MY-
ADMONISHMENT WOULD WE SHOULD
BOMB MONTHLY REPORT THEY
APPARENTLY ACCORDING TO
ANALYSTS ARE GETTING A MONTHLY
REPORTS FROM THE AGENCIES THOSE
ARE TO BE IMMEDIATELY TENDERED
TO THE LEGISLATURE THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU SIR
CENTER DORADO. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. MICHAEL IS WE HAVE- THE
L. A. O. HAS IDENTIFIED A
NUMBER OF WAYS IN WHICH THE
LEGISLATURE HAS NOT RECEIVED.
ADEQUATE INFORMATION OR
COMPLETE INFORMATION. HAVE YOU
FOUND ANY. GAP IN THE
AUTHORITY. OF THAT THE-
ADMINISTRATION HAS. A AS FAR AS
OF AN OBLIGATION TO PROVIDE
THIS INFORMATION. IS IT TOTALLY
WITHIN THEIR AUTHORITY TO NOT
PROVIDE THIS IN IT YOU KNOW
BECAUSE I KNOW YOU MADE
SUGGESTIONS AS TO THE CHANGES
NEEDED FOR BETTER OVERSIGHT-
AND SPECIFIC IDEAS ON HOW TO DO
THAT WITH THESE REPORTS. BUT IS
I GUESS MY QUESTION NOW IS. ARE
THEY NOT REQUIRED TO DO THAT IS
THERE A GAP IN THEIR AUTHORITY.
TO DO THAT OR IS IT A 100%
WITHIN THEIR AUTHORITY THE
ADMINISTRATION'S OF FORTY TO
NOT HAVE TO PROVIDE THIS KIND
OF INFORMATION. THAT'S A GOOD
QUESTION SO V. THERE THERE'S
DIFFERENT REQUIREMENTS
DEPENDING ON THE SOURCE OF THE
FUNDING AND I TOUCHED ON A
LITTLE BIT IN THE BEGINNING OF
OUR PRESENT TO BUT GENERAL
SPEAKING MOST OF THESE FUNDS
ARE PROVIDED IN A VERY FLEXIBLE
MANNER THAT DOES NOT REQUIRE ON
ANY SORT OF REPORTING BACK TO
THE LEGISLATURE. I HAVE A LOT
OF THE FUNDS WERE PROVIDED
THROUGH THREE ELAT AND AS I
NOTED- THE INITIATION IS
REQUIRED TO NOTIFY THEIR GLVC
WHEN MONEY IS TRANSFERRED INTO
THE THREE- AND THEY WOULD
IDENTIFY YOUR BROADLY AND THE
TYPES OF THE REASON FOR THAT
DAY TRANSFER IN THE TYPES OF
THINGS FUNDED. BUT THERE'S NO
REQUIREMENT TO NOTIFY THE
LEGISLATURE ASSETS FUNDS
ACTUALLY GO OUT THE DOOR OR
ALLOCATED DEPARTMENT
DEPARTMENTS- AND SO A LOT OF
THE MONEY HAS BEEN PROVIDED
THROUGH JURY OUT WHILE ON THE
FUNDS THAT WERE PROVIDED
THROUGH SECTION THIRTY SIX DID
HAVE A SEVENTY TWO HOUR
NOTIFICATION- THAT WAS IN LAST
WAS TO FISCAL YEAR THE-
ADMINISTRATION DID PROVIDE
THOSE NOTIFICATIONS- SO WE'RE
NOT SEEING ANY CASE WHERE
THERE'S- REQUIRED NOTIFICATIONS
OR REPORTING THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S FAILING TO
DEAL. I THINK IT'S MORE IN THE
WAY THE STATE'S EMERGENCY
SPENDING AUTHORITIES ARE SAT
AT- IT GIVES A LOT OF
FLEXIBILITY TO ADMINISTRATION.
AND YOU'RE ONE OF THE REASONS
IN A TYPICAL EMERGENCY YOU KNOW
THE VERSION YOU HAVE A FIRE AND
THEN THE FIRE WOULD BE CUT OUT
AND THEN THE EMERGENCY WOULD BE
OVER AND THEN THERE IT JUST BE
SORT OF AFTER THE FACT.
RECOVERY OPERATIONS- OF THE
COVER NINETEEN EMERGENCY IS
SOMEWHAT DIFFERENT IN THAT WERE
STILL UNDER AN EMERGENCY
DECLARATION THAT COULD CONTINUE
FOR MONTHS OR EVEN YEARS AND
SALAS EVEN IF THE LEGISLATURE
HADN'T PROVIDED FLEXIBILITY
THROUGH THE BUDGET
ADMINISTRATION WOULD HAVE
FLEXIBILITY TO THE EMERGENCY
SERVICES ACT- THAT STATUTE WAS
PUT INTO EFFECT IN I THINK IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY. AND DOESN'T
HAVE ANY REPORTING REQUIREMENTS
ON THAT GOAL WITH IT AND I
THINK. IT'S PROBABLY FAIR TO
SAY THAT WE HIS WAS IN PLACE.
OKAY BEEN IN THAT WE HAVE
EMERGED. THAT WOULD GO ON FOR
MANY MONTHS EVEN. SUCH AS THE
PANDEMIC THAT WE'RE IN RIGHT
NOW. THANK YOU. A DOCTOR PAN
FOLLOWED BY CENTER WORKOUTS SKI.
THANK YOU AND I WANT TO THANK
THE L. A. O. FOR THEIR
PRESENTATION SO I GUESS I MIGHT
MY QUESTION IS REGARDING TRAIL-
IS THAT- AND I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU LOOK HISTORICALLY- PRIOR TO
CODE WHAT'S THE LONGEST PERIOD
OF TIME IN WHICH IN THE
MINISTRATIONS BEEN GIVEN
PERMISSION YOU MENTIONED THAT
LAWS PASSED IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY. WHICH IN A
MINISTRATION WAS ALLOWED TO USE
FUNDS UNDER JAIL AT USE FUNDS
UNDER TRAIL US IT WAS THE
LONGEST EMERGENCY PERIOD THAT'S
EVER HAPPENED AND SECOND OF
ALL- HE DID YEAH I CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND FLEXIBILITY BUT
THERE'S ACCOUNTABILITY SO
HISTORICALLY AS WELL HAS THERE
BEEN AN ACCOUNTING NGUYEN IN A
MINISTRATION USES FUNDS FOR
JAIL AND EVENTUAL ACCOUNTING OF
HOW THAT MONEY WAS EVENTUALLY
SPENT I UNDERSTAND AT THE
MOMENT THEY HAVE TO MAKE QUICK
DECISIONS WE WANNA GIVE
FLEXIBILITY. HAS THAT BEEN
SOMETHING THAT'S HAPPENED
HISTORICALLY OR NOT IN TERMS OF
FUNDS THAT WERE SPENT UNDER
DRILLED UNDER OTHER EMERGENCIES
OR IS IT A AN EVENTUAL FINAL
ACCOUNTING FOR HOW THOSE FUNDS
ARE SPENT OR DID THAT SIMPLY
HAPPEN AND- NOTHING EVER
HAPPENED THERE WAS NEVER EVER A
REPORT THE LEGISLATURE ANY
OTHER SORT OF PORT ACCOUNTING
FOR HOW THE MONIES WERE
EVENTUALLY SPENT. FOR THAT
EMERGENCY SO CAN YOU SPEAK TO
THE HISTORIC OF THE HISTORY OF
ISRAEL. AND IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. R. AND LET ME.
CLEAR IT SENATORS. AND SO.
THREE WHAT ADMINISTRATION CAN
CONTINUE TO SPEND ON THE SORT
OF AFTERMATH AND- RECOVERY OF
AN EMERGENCY. EVEN AFTER THE
EMERGENCY DECLARATION HAS
ENDED. ONCE EMERGENCY
DECLARATION HAS ENDED SOME OF
THE AUTHORITIES JUST BEHIND I'M
SUCH AS THOSE PROVIDED UNDER
THE EMERGENCY SERVICES ACT-
WHICH IS SEPARATE FROM THAT
RELY STATUTE. THOSE GO AWAY AND
SO IT REALLY DOES PROVIDE AN
INITIATIVE CONTEMPLATED TO
PROVIDE FOR THIS I'M GOING
FUNDING HE- AFTER EMERGING.
DECLARATION HAS ENDED WE I
DON'T HAVE OFF HAND BUT WE CAN
CERTAINLY LOOK INTO. AND THE
LONGEST DURATION OF A OF A
DECLARED EMERGENCY- AS WELL AS-
THE USE OF THREE- I FRIENDS
AND- THE THREE OTHER STATUTE
MAKES THAT THIS. FUNDING
AVAILABLE FOR A HUNDRED TWENTY
DAYS. KIND OF. TRYING TO SAY
WELL ABOUT HALF THE YEAR SO
THAT ADDITIONAL BEYOND THAT
COULD BE CONSIDERED TO THE
STATE'S REGULAR BUDGET PROCESS-
BUT THAT THE STATUTE DOES ALLOW
FOR THE HUNDRED TWENTY DAYS TO
BE EXTENDED. I'M IN ADDITIONAL
HUNDRED TWENTY DAY INCREMENTS
OF THE SPENDING CAN GO ON FOR
QUITE AWHILE. I'M PRIOR TO THAT
THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS WITH A
MAJOR FIRES IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN%
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE STATE HAD
NOT USED THE TRIO IT STATUTE
VERY MUCH- FOR PRETTY SMALL
AMOUNTS. AND SO I THINK IN
RECENT TIMES THE LONGEST
STANDING YOU SURGERY A LOT
WOULD BE LOOKING AT THE DEBRIS
REMOVAL AND ONGOING RECOVERY
OPERATIONS FROM THE MAJOR FIRES
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. I'M AWARE THAT
HUNDRED AND TWENTY DAY
AUTHORIZATION WAS EXTENDED. I'M
IN TERMS OF THE INFORMATION
THAT THE LEGISLATURE IS
RECEIVING ON THE BACK END OF
WHAT ALTERNATELY HAPPENED. AS I
NOTED BEFORE IT'S INCONSISTENT-
SO IN SOME CASES ADMINISTRATION
HAS PROVIDED I'M SOME GOOD
INFORMATION ON A PARTICULAR
RESPONDING TO THE MAJOR FIRES
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN TO TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. ADMINISTRATION ADDED
SOME DOCUMENTS TO ITS BUDGET
DISPLAYS- I'M DETAILING OUT HOW
THE FUNDS WERE ALLOCATED- TO
VARIOUS DEPARTMENTS FOR A
DIFFERENT RESPONSE AND RECOVERY
ACTIVITIES- FOR THOSE FIRES. IN
OTHER CASES THE ACTUAL
ALLOCATION EXPENDITURE OF DRILL
OF FRIENDS HAVEN'T HAD ANY- YOU
KNOW ADDITIONAL BACK AND
ACCOUNTING- THAT'S REPORTED TO
THE LEGISLATURE CELL IT YOU
KNOW SOME KEY. ARE HAS PROVIDED
IN SOME CASES NOT- BUT THE LOCK
ITSELF DOESN'T REQUIRE THAT
BACK AND REPORTING. SORRY THE
JUST ONE OTHER VIEW QUESTION
GIVEN THE FACT THAT TRAIL NOT
YOU FOR THE- OF THIS. IS A TIME
TO UPDATE THE TRAIL A LOT. TO
ENSURE THIS IN THE CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND THE FLEXIBILITY THIS
EMERGENCY FUND BUT THAT. DESERT
SOMETHING DAILY I WOULD
RECOMMEND. YEAH SO I THINK CAN
IS TO OUR LAST ISSUE FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION TODAY IS STEPPING
BACK EVEN FROM THE TIME THAT
THE SPECIFIC FUNDS AND SET
ASIDE TO RESPOND TO THE CALL
THE NINETEEN EMERGENCY. IN OUR
REVIEW I HAVE HAD TO COPE WITH
FINDING RECENT WILDFIRE FUNDING
I'M- FUNDING FOR THE CIVIL
DISTURBANCE AND THAT WAS IN A
DECLARED EMERGENCY. AND IT'S
REALLY COME TO OUR ATTENTION
THAT THERE IS NOT ONLY TO RIO
AT HAS. SOME SHORTCOMINGS
PERHAPS IN TERMS OF. THE
LEGISLATURE'S ABILITY TO HAVE A
PROGRAM FOR MISSION AND
FACILITATE THAT TRANSPARENCY
AND LEGISLATIVE INVOLVEMENT BUT
THE THESE OTHER STATURE. AND
OTHER PROVISIONS ALLOW FOR
EMERGENCY SPENDING AUTHORITIES.
AND. AND SO REALLY WE THINK IT
SHOULD BE I. LOOK AT THEM TO
GET. AND I WOULD YOU KNOW. THAT
IF THEY MINISTRY HAVING. REAL
AT TAX. THE FUNDS FOR THE CODE
NINETEEN EMERGENCY THEY COULD
HAVE USED. A DIFFERENT SPENDING
AUTHORITY UNDER THE EMERGENCY
SERVICES ACT THAT HAS NO
RECORDING AND SO AND YOU KNOW
IT'S AND THE LEVEL OF
TRANSPARENCY IN REPORTING UNDER
EACH OF THESE DIFFERENT
SPENDING AUTHORITIES. IT
NECESSARILY YOU KNOW TIED TO
THINGS THAT YOU MIGHT THINK IT
WOULD BE OR SHOULD BE SUCH AS
THE URGENCY OF FINDING AND
THINGS LIKE THAT SO THOSE ARE
SOME OF THE QUESTIONS THAT
WE'RE ASKING. I HAVE EVER
CERTAINLY CONTINUING TO LOOK
INTO THIS AND WE THINK YOU KNOW
CERTAINLY LOOKING AT TRIO AND
THE AUTHORITY PROVIDED THERE-
BUT ALSO TAKING OUT RYDER LUCK
AND TO THE EXTENT THAT. THE
CODE NINETEEN EMERGENCY OR
OTHER FUTURE EMERGENCIES COULD
STAY UNDER THAT DISASTER
DECLARATION FOR A LONG PERIOD
OF TIME AND YOU REALLY WANT TO
HAVE A COMPREHENSIVE LOCK AND-
BUT YOU KNOW IT WELL IT DOESN'T
DIRECTLY RELATE TO THAT AND SO
YOU PROVIDED. IN THIS YEAR TO
THE MINISTRATION. BUT WHAT. AS
ATTENTION THAT THE REAL ARE
OVER IN INCOME EMERGE SPEND
AUTHORITY THAT PROVIDE FOR
DEGREES OF TRANSFER IN OVER
PROBABLY ALL OF YOU AT THE ARE
IN GIVEN THE SCALE AND
MAGNITUDE OF THE FUNDING ON TO
IN RECENT YEARS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MUST BE MEMBERS I'M
GONNA ASK YOU TO ASK YOUR ONE
MOST PRESSING QUESTION OF THE
L. L. THIS ISN'T OUR ONLY
OPPORTUNITY TO ENGAGE THE L. A.
L. ON THIS CRITICAL ISSUE. BUT
I AM- MANAGING OUR TIME TODAY
I'VE GOT SENATOR WHITE CAL SKI
FOLLOWED BY SKINNER CENTER
LEYVA WITH YOUR HAND RATES FOR
THE TESTER DO YOU STILL HAVE A
QUESTION. HE THOUGHT HE SAW THE
QUESTION AND FOLLOWED BY SEVEN
TO REQUIRE Y. CASKEY I THINK
CENTER NIELSEN MAKES A GOOD
POINT N. CENTER PAN TALKING
ABOUT. OKAY I GET IT IN MAY
TWENTY FIRST WE DIDN'T ACTUALLY
REQUIRE TECHNICALLY FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION TO GIVE US
UPDATES I UNDERSTAND THAT FOR
YOU LET TECHNICALLY DOESN'T
UNDER REQUIRE THEM TO GIVE US
UPDATES AT AGE AND I UNDERSTAND
THAT THE EMERGENCY SERVICES.
TECHNICALLY DOESN'T UNDERSTAND
THAT WE PAY THEY HAVE TO GIVE
US UPDATES OKAY THAT'S ALL
CLEAR IS THERE ANYTHING THAT
PROHIBITED THEM WITH- ANYTHING
INTERNAL LAW OR IN THE
AUTHORIZATION THAT DEEP
PROHIBITED FROM GIVING US BASIC
INFORMATION WHEN THE- WHOLE.
HOTEL AND HEALTH CARE WORKERS
CHANGE FROM THIRTY MILLION TO
FIVE HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE
BILLION ASSERT ANYTHING IN THIS
BODY OF LAW THAT PROHIBIT THEM
FROM GIVING US A NOTE. AND A
HEADS UP OF THESE THINGS HAD
SUBSTANTIALLY CHANGED THIS ONE
LITTLE BIT OF LAW. THAT THEY
COULD HAVE PAINTED ON. I ARE
ASKING THEIR THERE'S NOT THAT
FOR THEM IN. FROM PROVIDE THIS
OF. AND WE WOULD KNOW THE ARE.
AS WELL AS OTHER LEGISLATIVE
STAFF HAVE BEEN ASKING FOR. I'M
WEEKS AND EVEN MONTHS FOR
UPDATED INFORMATION FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION ON ITS PLANNED
SPENDING ON AN ACTUAL
EXPENDITURES. AND TIME UP UNTIL
THE INFORMATION THAT WAS POSTED
LATE YESTERDAY. AND THE
RESPONSE WAS ALWAYS THAT THE
NAY TWENTY FIRST A LETTER TO
THE G. L. B. C. WAS THE MOST.
CURRENT INFORMATION AVAILABLE-
AND SO CERTAINLY AS A
LEGISLATURE IS PROVIDED. I HAVE
A GREAT DEAL OF FLEXIBILITY IN
THE MEASURE SHE HAS A GREAT
DEAL FLEXIBILITY TO RESPOND
HERE RIGHTLY SO AS THE
SITUATION CONTINUES TO UNFOLD
WITH EMERGENCY. WE THINK IT'S
ALSO VERY REASONABLE TO EXPECT
THAT THE MINISTRATION WAITED
PROVIDE EITHER OF ITS OWN
ACCORD OR HAS ANY SORT OF
INFORMAL REQUEST OR IF YOU
FORMALLY REQUIRING TEAMS. TO
PROVIDE THIS ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION TO KEEP THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE LOOP
ESPECIALLY TO THE EXTENT THAT
MANY OF THAT THE EXPENDITURES
HAPPENING HERE. ARE BEING
PLANNED OUT DAYS OR WEEKS OR
MONTHS AHEAD OF TIME WHICH IS A
LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT THAN A
SITUATION WHERE. THERE'S
HELLFIRE IN. HIS JUST GO AND
PUT IT OUT AND YOU KNOW NOT
REALLY PLANNING WHAT YOU'RE OR
HOW DOING. ON INTO THE SUMMER-DEBATE DIFFERENT SO WE DO THINK
IT'S VERY REASONABLE FOR THAT
THE LEGISLATURE TO EXPECT THAT
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION THANK
THANK YOU WAS SPEAKERS MY
SKINNER. THANK YOU CARE AND-
GIVEN THAT WE ARE THE SELL OUT
GIVEN THAT WE ARE GOING TO BE
OUT OF SESSION. AUGUST THIRTY
FIRST. HI MY UNDERSTANDING IS
WE THE ONLY WAY WE COULD COME
BACK. TO ACT BEFORE OUR REGULAR
SESSION STARTS AGAIN. IN OF. OF
DECEMBER I GUESS. WOULD BE
THROUGH A GOVERNOR ACTION.
FIRST L. A. O. JUST CORRECT ME
ON THAT. LET ME KNOW IF I'M
ACCURATE IN THAT. AND THAT WE
CAN GET BACK TO YOU IF THERE'S
ANY OTHER OPTIONS BUT I THINK
AT CERTAINLY THROUGHOUT LIKE I
HAD A SPECIAL SESSION CALLING
OF A SPECIAL SESSION AND I
WOULD HAVE TO BE THE GOVERNOR.
AND HOW THAT WOULD BE THE
TYPICAL WAY THAT THE
LEGISLATURE RIGHT SO AND SO
THEN IF WE ASSUME THAT WE WOULD
NOT BE ABLE TO ACT IN THAT
INTERIM PERIOD WE'D IF WE
WANTED TO FOLLOW UP. ENACT
SOMETHING CLOSE TO YOUR
RECOMMENDATION ON THE- LAST
PAGE ABOUT. FINANCIALLY
REVISING THE EXISTING STATUTES
WE'D HAVE TO DO THAT BY AUGUST
THIRTY FIRST. PRACTICE BY
AUGUST THIRTY FIRST RIGHT TO
THE MY LAST COMMENT IS I THINK
THAT'S WORTH OUR CONSIDERATION
OKAY AND SECONDARILY ON PAGE
SEVEN OF THE L. A. O.'S REPORT
WHERE THEY MENTION WRITTEN
NOTIFICATION WHERE THEY
MENTIONED IT'S AT SIX AND SEVEN
WERE THERE IS RECOMMENDED- TWO
DIFFERENT WAYS. THAT WE MIGHT-
GET A IMPROVED OVERSIGHT ONE OF
THEM IS MEMBER BRIEFINGS AND
THE OTHERS WRITTEN NOTIFICATION
I WOULD HIGHLY RECOMMEND THAT
WE OPT FOR OF COURSE WE CAN
ALWAYS HAVE MEMBER BRIEFINGS
BUT I THINK WE SHOULD REQUIRE
THE REGULAR WRITTEN
NOTIFICATION AND SECONDARILY WE
SHOULD ASK FOR THE MONTHLY
EXPENDITURE REPORTS. THANK YOU
SENATOR LEYVA. THANK YOU MADAM
BUDGET CHAIR I HAVE A QUESTION
ON PAGE FOUR OF YOUR REPORT ON
THE ONE POINT ONE BILLION ON
STATE RESPONSE OPERATIONS THE
INCREASE OF NINE HUNDRED
MILLION MORE. DO WE KNOW WHAT
THE RESPONSE OPERATIONS ARE IS
THAT TESTING IS A CONTACT
TRACING WHAT IS IT THAT MONEY
BEING USED FOR. AND SO I THINK
THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION FOR
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO
EXPLAIN THE DETAILS. RIGHT I
DON'T BELIEVE IT WOULD
INCLUDING TESTING AND CONTACT
TRACING BACK THE SEPARATE
CATEGORY MS I'M NOT SURE IF YOU
GUYS RECEIVED A HARD COPY OF
OUR HAND OUT BUT HI CHART BUT I
SHOWED. DURING THE PRESENTATION
HAD THESE DIFFERENT CATEGORIES
THIS PROCUREMENT CASTING AND
THE STATE OPERATIONS
RESPONSIBLE I AND MY
UNDERSTANDING OF IT IS IT'S
MORE AT THE STATE SORT OF
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS BUT I
THINK THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION
FOR A DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
ONLINE. WHAT THEY PLAN TO SPEND
THOSE FUNDS ON AND WHY IT'S
GOING TO. SHOW CENTROLEGAL COME
TO YOU FIRST AFTER FINANCE
PRESENTS FOR YOU TO POSE THAT
QUESTION TO THEM. THANK YOU SIX
WIRED. THIRTY THANK YOU SO MUCH
AT NIGHT OF CHAIR. COMMITTEE
JUST COURT COMMENT NOW CHAIR IN
LIGHT OF THIS. ONGOING PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY IT WOULD MAKE
SENSE AT LEAST TO ME IT SOUNDS
LIKE FOR MANY OF OUR
COLLEAGUES. TO REVIEW BLOGGER
TURNED THE DERAIL THAT STATUTE
AND OTHER. EMERGENCY SPENDING
MEASURES THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION CURRENTLY HAS I
THINK- PRIOR TO THIS PANDEMIC.
THE REAR WITH MAKE A WHILE AND
FIRES IS THE REAL ONE HERE IN
LARGE. EMERGENCY RESPONSE
INITIATIVES ARE NOW PART OF OUR
IT LIFE WHETHER IT'S- LARGE
WHILE FIRES FLOODS GOD FORBID A
LARGE EARTHQUAKE. AND THIS ON
GOING PANDEMIC SO I KNOW THIS
ISSUE HAS BEEN IMPORTANT ONE
FOR OUR BUDGET SHARING GRATEFUL
FOR HER WORK ON THIS AND THAT
AND BUDGET SHARE JUST A
SUGGESTION THAT. IF WE'RE GONNA
BE LOOKING AT OVERSIGHT- AS WE
MOVE FORWARD HERE INTO THE FALL
THAT THIS COULD BE A POTENTIAL
SUBJECT. IN HOW WE COULD BRING
ADDITIONAL VOICE FROM THE
LEGISLATURE INTO THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
THANK YOU WERE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO THE PRESENTATION FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- THREE
SAID CALVERT ASSISTED PROGRAM
BUDGET MANAGER. MISS CALVERT I
HOPE THAT YOU ARE HEARD CENTER
NIELSEN'S QUESTION AND ARE
PREPARED TO INCORPORATE A
RESPONSE TO HIM INTO YOUR
INITIAL PRESENTATION AND THEN
AFTER YOU PRESENT WILL HAVE
MEMBERS POSE QUESTIONS. MISS
CALVERT THANK YOU FOR JOINING
US. THAT MORNING AT. OUR
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE YES SIR
THAT FOR THE JUST AND WILL
PRESENTATIONS YOUR I'M HERE
ALSO WASTE VENTURE WHO HELP ON
SOME OF THIS AND QUESTION AS WE
MOVE FORWARD BUT I WILL TRY TO
KEEP MY OVERVIEW BRIEF TO A LOT
OF. TIME FOR QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. I'M AT WAS NOTED IT
THAT WOULD YOU OFFICE.
DEPARTMENT DURATION OUR BEST OF
DISPLACEMENT AT THE TIME THESE
ARE THINGS THAT WE CAN TAKE TO
WORK THE STATE EACH ARE SO TO
CRISIS SECOND TO RUN YES. AND
IN EFFORTS TO TRANSFER FROM AN
UPDATE YOU KNOW SO THE BUDGET I
WE AGAIN. RELEASED I KNOW IN
FOR ESTHER. THAT WE HOPE HELPS
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL DETAILS. IN
VARIOUS PROGRAM CATEGORIES.
MOVING FORWARD AND I HOPE THIS
GETS TO SOME OF THE COMMENTS
MADE EARLIER MOVING FORWARD IT
IS OUR INTENT TO PROVIDE A
MONTHLY UPDATE ON EXPENDITURE
ESTIMATES- SO THAT THAT HELPS
REPORT OUT ON A REGULAR BASIS
ON THIS PROGRAM CATEGORIES AND
THE EFFORTS BEING MADE- AS WERE
IN. IN THE MIDDLE OF THIS
PANDEMIC. AT A VERY HIGH LEVEL
THIS UP WHAT WE ISSUE
YESTERDAY- AT AND SINCE THE
BUDGET ACT FOR THAT COMBINATION
OF PAST YEAR IS WHAT YOUR
KNIGHT TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
AND THE- CURRENT FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY. TWENTY ONE WE ARE
ESTIMATING THAT OUR TEACHERS
ARE TRACKING ABOUT ONE POINT
TWO BILLION DOLLARS LOWER THAN.
PREVIOUSLY ESTIMATED- OF THAT
AMOUNT ABOUT THREE HUNDRED
SEVENTY MILLION. IT WOULD BE
GENERAL FUND DEBT DECREASES AND
YOU GET TO REITERATE OUR POINT
IN TIME ESTIMATES CONTINUE TO
APPLY YOU KNOW. PANDEMIC
CONTINUES TO EVOLVE AND THINGS
ARE DEFINITELY SUBJECT TO
CHANGE BUT THOSE REDUCTIONS.
LARGELY ATTRIBUTED TO LOWER
THAN ANTICIPATED PREVIOUSLY
JUST. THIS IS A RESULT OF SOME
OF MY COSTS THE CREATION AND
ALSO SOME CONTRACTS NOT COMING
TO FRUITION WE CANCELED IT WAS
ALSO A PRETTY BIG. AND THE
MEDICAL SURGE HOSPICE OPTIONS
FOR THE PAST YEAR. THE NINETEEN
TWENTY THERE'S CONSTANT
MATERIALIZE AS PREVIOUSLY.
ESTIMATED TIME IN ADDITION
THERE'S BEEN A COUPLE OF
ACTIVITIES THAT WORK I AM KNOWN
WHEN WE HAD OUR MAY TWENTY
FIRST CHARTS AND ESTIMATES YOU
HAVE HEARD PUBLICLY OUT OF THAT
FUNDING FOR THE HARVEST PROGRAM
WRITING CHILDREN'S SERVICES
WITHIN THEIR CULTURAL INDUSTRY
WHO HAVE BECOME EXPOSED TO
COVER NINETEEN AND- NOT SELF
RESULT. RESULT ISOLATE AND
THERE'S ALSO THE PROJECT HOPE
PROGRAM THAT PROVIDES CHILDREN
SERVICES. TO FORMERLY
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS.
EXPOSE PRIOR TO RELEASE. I
GUESS ONE THREE. THAT INTENDS
TO PROVIDE MONTHLY REPORTING I
THINK THAT GETS YOU. A FEW OF
THE QUESTIONS NOTED- ON THE
NOTION OF BREAKING SPEAKING
WITH. OUR PARTNERS AT- YES AND
YOU JUST AGENCY ALWAYS AN
OPENNESS TO PROVIDE. MEANS AND
BALANCING THAT WITH YOU KNOW
RELIEF FOR THE SAME ENTITIES
RESPONDING TO THE CRISIS AT AS
IT UNFOLDS. AND WORKED WITH
THAT WERE YOU KNOW HAPPY TO
TAKE QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE AND WE CAN ALSO
DISPLAY. THAT CHART THAT WE PUT
OUT. YESTERDAY THAT HASN'T.
HIGH LEVEL TO LOOK AT TO THE
COMMITTEE AND THEN SHE SENATOR
LAST QUESTION POSED ABOUT THAT
STATE RESPONSE COST YES STATE
RESPONSE OPERATIONS LARGELY IS
THOSE THINGS THAT ARE-
ATTRIBUTED THIS. STATE
DEPARTMENTS AND WHAT THEY'RE
DOING AND RESPONSE TO THE
CRISIS IN OUR CHURCH THAT WE
ISSUED YESTERDAY. THOSE. THAT
WE PULLED OUT FOR. DETAILS CAN
THAT KIND OF WHERE. WE SEE OUR
GUARD AND STATE HOSPITALS THAT
KIND OF GIVES A SENSE OF THE
INTERVIEWS OF COURSE- YES JUST
AGENTS OF COURSE. THAT'S THAT'S
THAT KIND AGAIN WITH THAT WE
HAVE EIGHTEEN FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION. A LITTLE. TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS AND- I WITHOUT.
IN ADDITION. THANK YOU
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS SENATOR
MONNING. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR-
AND I APPRECIATE THE
INFORMATION PROVIDED BY
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I DID
HAVE A QUESTION ON THE HOUSING
FOR THE HARVEST. IN ESTIMATE OF
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS DO YOU
KNOW CURRENTLY HOW MUCH OF THAT
HAS BEEN DISTRIBUTED IN THROUGH
THROUGH QUITE AGENCY OR
DEPARTMENTS IS THAT FUND BEING
ADMINISTERED. YES SO AND TO MY
KNOWLEDGE I DON'T KNOW THAT ANY
OF THAT HAS BEEN DISTRIBUTED
YET THE PROGRAM IS FAIRLY NEW
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE IS LEAD ON THIS
PROJECT THEY'RE WORKING CLOSELY
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL
SERVICES TO HELP. WITH THAT
PROCUREMENT OF THE HOTELS- AND
SO THOSE PERMITTED OF
AGRICULTURE IS THE LEAD AGENCY.
AND. FINDING WORK FLOW. I
BELIEVE EITHER TARGETING
AGRICULTURE DEPARTMENT SERVICES
WITH MY KNOWLEDGE NONE OF THAT
HAS BEEN ALLOCATED YET. RIGHT
NOW IT'S RECENTLY ANNOUNCED
THAT. OUR INTEREST I THINK MY
INTEREST WOULD BE THE-
EXPEDITIOUS DISTRIBUTION- WE
KNOW IN MANY RURAL COMMUNITIES
THE HIGHEST RATE OF CODE
NINETEEN IS AMONG. FARMWORKER
COMMUNITIES- AND- I WOULD HAVE
HOPED THIS WOULD HAVE BEEN
ANTICIPATED. DIRECTED EARLIER
BUT- WE WILL FOLLOW UP WITH
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE AND- MAYBE THROUGH
THE CHAIR WE CAN REQUEST SOME
FURTHER INFORMATION ON THAT
EMERGENCY FUNDING SOURCE. I'D
ALSO BE CURIOUS TO SEE. WHAT
THAT AMOUNT WAS BASED UPON
WHAT'S THE ESTIMATE OF WHAT
WILL BE ACHIEVED WITH IT AND
WILL IT MEET THE NEED
ANTICIPATED- I'D ALSO LIKE TO
HEAR FROM THE PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENT- WORKING WITH CDFA-
THE ANTICIPATED NEED IN WILL
THAT BE SUFFICIENT. AND THEN
ALSO IN THE AREA OF. VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS FIFTEEN MILLION
IDENTIFIED FOR FOOD BANKS DO
YOU KNOW IF THAT HAS BEEN DONE.
SOME AND THROUGH QUITE AGENCY
OR DEPARTMENT IS THE SUPPORT
FOR FOOD BANKS BEING MANAGED.
YES I DO- I BELIEVE THE
DEPARTMENT FOR THAT EFFORT. IS
THE TIME TO SOCIAL SERVICES I
WILL NEED TO TURN THAT OVER TO
MY COUNTERPART HERE AT FINANCE-
I'M DOOR TO SEE IF HE HAS A
SENSE OF HOW MUCH.
ADMINISTRATOR IF THAT'S ANOTHER
FOLLOW UP THAT WILL WELL.
SENATOR MONEY GREAT THANK YOU.
IN THE IS THAT AVAILABLE NOW.
HI THIS IS ADAM DIVERSITY AT
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- YES
SO- THAT IS THE DEPARTMENT
SOCIAL SERVICES THAT IS IT
MINISTERING THAT PROGRAM AND
IT'S- YOU KNOW PART OF A SERIES
OF INVESTMENTS MADE IN FOOD
BANK- AND SO- LET ME I'VE KIND
OF UP IN SEE IF THE FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS HAS BEEN
DISTRIBUTED ALREADY. THANK YOU
IN I THINK ONE THING THAT WOULD
BE HELPFUL TO US ON MANY OF
THESE. ALLOCATIONS FOR
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES. THEY
WERE BASED ON WHAT PROJECTED
TIME OF NEED AND AS THE COVERT
VIRUS CONTINUES TO SPREAD IN
CALIFORNIA IN NATIONALLY. I
THINK IT WOULD BE HELPFUL TO
KNOW ARE THESE ALLOCATIONS
ANTICIPATING SUPPORT FOR THREE
MONTHS OR SIX MONTHS AND IT AND
IF THEY NEED TO BE REPLENISHED
OR IF THEY'RE EXHAUSTED- I
THINK WE WOULD LIKE TO KNOW
THAT SOONER RATHER THAN LATER
AS PART OF OUR EFFORTS. TO PLAN
FORWARD IN TERMS OF FUTURE
ALLOCATIONS OR FURTHER APPEALS
TO THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT- WE
KNOW WE'RE IN A HUGE GAP RIGHT
NOW FOR UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
SUPPORT. THAT IS AFFECTING LOW
INCOME AND VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES WHO ARE NOW FACING
RENT. BILLS THAT HAVE BEEN
CARRIED. BUT NOW WE'RE COMING
DUE THE CRISIS IT BUILDS AND
PART OF IT IS THE IMMEDIATE
HEALTH PANDEMIC CRISIS BUT IT'S
TRIGGERING THESE OTHER SOCIAL
IMPACTS THAT- I THINK IT WOULD
BE IN OUR INTEREST TO BE KEPT.
INFORMED ABOUT ANTICIPATED
DEPLETION OF ALLOCATED MONIES
AND HOW THEY ARE BEING
IMPLEMENTED ALLOCATED AND LET'S
GET AHEAD OF THE CURVE ON THE
NEED FOR CONSIDERING- FURTHER
ALLOCATIONS- SO I APPRECIATE
ANY FURTHER INFORMATION THAT
MIGHT BE PROVIDED TO US. OVER
THE NEXT WEEK OR SO THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU SIR US
INTO MORE LAW. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR- BEING ACCOUNT NUMBERS
ARE NUMBERS BUT THERE'S A
NARRATIVE THAT TELLS. APPS A
DIFFERENT STORY AND HERE WE ARE
FOUR MONTHS INTO THIS. PANDEMIC
AND THE INITIAL FOCUS WAS ON A
MASSIVE SURGE- THAT DID NOT
OCCUR- SO WE HAD A MASSIVE
OVERSHOOT FROM THE INCEPTION WE
HAD A BOAT IN ARENA AN EMPTY
LOS ANGELES HOSPITAL. VERSUS
PROGRESSIVELY WORKING WITH ERIC
EXCESS PROPERTIES LIKE
FACILITIES LIKE FAIRVIEW'S
SONOMA PORTER VILLE- BUT WE
SHUT DOWN HOSPITALS AND MEDICAL
PRACTICES. AS A POSTER RAMPING
UP BUT I'M I'M JUST CURIOUS-
MADAM CHAIR WHEN WE RECEIVE NOT
ONLY THE NUMBERS BUT WHEN WILL
WE RECEIVE THE NARROW OF WHY
CERTAIN DECISIONS WERE MADE. AT
AND- WHY DO WE DO CERTAIN
THINGS THAT NEVER MATERIALIZED
OUT WHAT DATA WHAT SCIENCE. I
WOULD LOVE TO BUY THE BOOK AND
MAYBE THE DEPARTMENT FINANCE TO
MAYBE GIVE A LITTLE. TEASER OF
WHAT WHAT ARE WE WOULD THAT BE
READING THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
SO THAT RHETORICAL ARE YOU
LOOKING FOR A RESPONSE FROM
FINANCE. IF THERESA COVERED HAS
ANY CAN'T COMMENT I'D LOVE TO
HEAR IT THREE MISS CALVERT. YES
THANK AND YEAH ON THE SURGE
AGAIN THOSE ESTIMATES FOR
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY WERE
HIGHER THAN WHAT ACTUALLY
MATERIALIZES- I HAVE A
COLLEAGUE MARCO BEACH FROM HHS
AGENCY. ON AS WELL HE MIGHT BE
ABLE TO SPEAK A LITTLE BIT MORE
ABOUT. WHAT THAT WHAT THAT
MEANT AND HOW THAT. CAME ABOUT
AS BEING LOWER LOWER COST OF
THE DIDN'T MATERIALIZE AS AS
FEARS. AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
THANKS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BE HERE WITH YOU AND SENATOR I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR QUESTION IN
PARTICULAR BUT WITH REGARDS TO
THAT THE MEDICAL SEARCH
FACILITIES. WE ACTUALLY DID
TAKE ADVANTAGE AND WE CONTINUE
TO HAVE OUR MD DEVELOPMENTAL
CENTERS AS ALTERNATE CARE SITES
WE IN FACT TOWN FAIR VIEW AND
PORTABLE DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS
BOTH- ACTIVATED AND ARE USING
THEM. WE ARE VERY FORTUNATE IN
CALIFORNIA WE PLAN FOR THE
WORST CASE SCENARIO AND-
FORTUNATELY ENOUGH WE WERE ABLE
TO MANAGE THE- THIS INCREASED
AND- HOSPITALIZATIONS AND THE
NEED FOR INDIVIDUALS TO
HOSPITALIZED WITHIN THEIR
EXISTING HEALTHCARE DELIVERY
SYSTEM. AND THAT IS ULTIMATELY
THE BEST PLACE FOR US TO BE
TREATING INDIVIDUALS. AND AS A
RESULT WE DID NOT FORTUNATELY
NOT HAD TO USE AT THE
ADDITIONAL MED SURGE WITH
BODIES THAT WE HAD. MADE
AVAILABLE OR BUILD OUT IN THE
EARLY STAGES. OF THIS AND
DEMOCRATS ARE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU THANK PAN. I THANK YOU A
MAN CHAIR AND MAYBE FIRST MY
REMARKS BY SAYING THAT- I DO
APPRECIATE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION- PREPARED US FOR
A POTENTIAL- SEARCH AND- THE
CHALLENGE PUBLIC HEALTH IS THAT
WHEN IT DOESN'T HAPPEN
SOMETIMES YOU DON'T GIVE CREDIT
TO THE FACT THAT WE WORK TO
MAKE NOT MAKE THAT HAPPENED
LET'S THIS WAY I PREFERRED THAT
WE PUT THE MONEY UP AND WE END
UP NOT HAVING TO USE IT AND
EVEN WHEN I CONSIDER THAT WASTE
OR NOT. THEN ACTUALLY NOT
HAVING DONE IT AND HAVE INSTEAD
PAID WITH LIVES SO I JUST HAVE
TO START WITH THAT- WHEN IT
COMES TO THIS SPENDING AGAIN
YOU KNOW HERE WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT ACCOUNTABILITY AND SO
FORTH AND SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES FOR EXAMPLE I'M
LOOKING AT THE CHART FROM
FINANCE- COVE IN NINETEEN TO
DIRECT RESPONSE COST ESTIMATES
Q. MILLER TOTAL EXPENDITURES.
AND THE CHALLENGE WE DON'T HAVE
DETAILS IS THAT. YOU KNOW FOR
EXAMPLE WE ARE ONLY SPENDING 6%
ARE ACTUALLY WELL IF YOU LOOK
AT THE AUGUST TOTAL WE LOOK AT
THE- AUGUST TOTAL WHICH WOULD
ACTUALLY REPRESENT THE ACTUAL
SPENDING VERSUS THE ESTIMATE
WELL HE SPENT SEVEN POINT 2% ON
STATEWIDE TESTING AND ONLY TWO
POINT 4% ON CONTACT TRACING THE
TWO THINGS THAT WE SHOULD MAKE
THE TOP PRIORITY. IN ORDER
CONTROL THIS PANDEMIC THAT'S
KEEPING OUR BUSINESS IS CLOSE
OUR SCHOOLS CLOSED NOW I DON'T
KNOW WHETHER THAT'S THE RIGHT
AMOUNT BECAUSE I DON'T JUST
DUMP MONEY INTO SOMETHING THAT
CAN ABSORB IT- BUT I GUESS THIS
IS WHY IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT WE
HAVE THIS KIND OF TRANSPARENCY
COULD BE THE RIGHT AMOUNT OF
MONEY RIGHT I MEAN I'M NOT
DISPUTING THE FACT THAT WE'RE
SPENDING MONEY. ON OTHER THINGS
IN FOR EXAMPLE THE PROCUREMENT
WAS NO TO P. THE WOULD ACTUALLY
FOR TESTING COURSE THAT DOESN'T
FALL UNDER TESTING CATEGORY SO
I THINK IT IS IMPORTANT THAT
THERE'S A MORE DETAILED
EXPLANATION FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION OTHERWISE WHAT
HAPPENS IS I'M LEFT OF THE
CHART LIKE THIS AND I COULD
CERTAINLY CRITICIZED
ADMINISTRATION FOR UNDER
SPENDING IN PUBLIC HEALTH. THE
AT PERCENTAGES. SO THAT'S WHY
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
ACCIDENTAL HOW MUCH MONEY IS
GOING TO OUR LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS. HOW MUCH MONEY ARE
WE REALLY SPENDING. ON TESTING
OUT IN THE COMMUNITY I KNOW
THAT- SOME OF MY COLLEAGUES
HAVE TALKED ABOUT THE LACK OF
TESTING AVAILABILITY RIGHT IS
THIS SUFFICIENT AMOUNTS- THESE
ARE TYPES OF QUESTIONS THAT. WE
DO NEED THE ADMINISTRATION TO
HELP EXPLAIN. BECAUSE OTHERWISE
WHAT HAPPENS IS THAT PEOPLE
DROP PERHAPS INAPPROPRIATE
CONCLUSIONS ABOUT THE
PRIORITIES AND THE STRATEGY OF
THE ADMINISTRATION. SO I JUST.
YOU KNOW SO I I'D REALLY DO
WANT EARNERS ADMINISTRATION TO
THINK CAREFULLY. ABOUT THE NEED
FOR EXPLANATIONS AND FULL
DISCLOSURES OF. HOW MONEY IS
BEING SPENT. NOT JUST BECAUSE
WE'RE ASKING IS BECAUSE ON
FORTY PEOPLE CAN DRAW.
POTENTIALLY INAPPROPRIATE
CONCLUSIONS. AND SO I WOULD
JUST MAKE NOTE AND IS I'M DOING
JUST A QUICK YOU KNOW
CALCULATION OF. THESE
EXPENDITURES. AND CERTAINLY I
AM YOU KNOW. THAT YOU KNOW
THESE TO ME THESE TWO ARE THE
TOP PRIORITIES FOR TRYING TO
CONTROL THIS PANDEMIC THAT
UNDERLIES OUR UNEMPLOYMENT.
THAT UNDERLIES OUR SCHOOL
CLOSURES THAT UNDERLIES OUR
BUSINESS IS BEING CLOSED. AND
YET THERE ARE ONLY A FRACTION
OF THE TOTAL AMOUNT. AND WHY IT
AND SO BE ABLE TO HAVE A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING AS TO WHY WE'RE
SPENDING EXACTLY HOW MUCH. FOR
DIFFERENT THINGS IS GOING TO BE
IMPORTANT FOR US TO BE ABLE TO
BETTER COMMUNICATE TO THE- THAT
WE HAVE OUR PRIORITIES
STRAIGHT. AND I DON'T NOBODY
WANNA RESPOND TO THAT FINANCE
OR A PERHAPS WE CANNOT FOLLOW
UP LATER ON THIS THANK YOU.
THIS CALVERT. YES I DON'T HAVE
YOU KNOW I DON'T HAVE A DIRECT
RESPONSE TO THAT BUT THIS IS
PART OF THE DISCUSSION THAT
COMES AS WE KIND OF REPORT OUT
MORE. REGULARLY AND AS I NOTED
PLANNED ON A MONTHLY BASIS TO
KIND OF HAVE THAT ALONG WITH.
THAT MEMBER BRIEFINGS THAT WERE
MENTIONED EARLIER- I MIGHT ALSO
TURN IT OVER TO MARCO BEACH
AGAIN. AT THE HHS AGENCY JUST
TO TALK ABOUT THE TESTING OUT
AND- TO GIVE A LITTLE MORE IN.
ON HE- AS WELL HEARING. THANK
YOU TO RESEND DR PAN THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR QUESTION I
THINK YOU ALLUDED TO. AS
SOMETHING THAT WE OFTEN THINK
ABOUT IN THE PUBLIC HEALTH
SPACE WHICH IS AYE WE BOX IN
THE VIRUS AND WE BOX IN THE
VIRUS REALLY BY. LOOKING AT A
FEW THINGS THAT INCLUDES BOTH
TESTING CONTACT TRACING AND
WEBER THE INFORMATION THAT WAS
PUT OUT BY. THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE INCLUDES THE GENERAL
FUND CONTRIBUTIONS THE STATE IS
MAKING. NOT NECESSARILY THE
TOTAL FUNDS INCLUDING THAT
FEDERAL DOLLARS THAT WE
RECEIVED FROM. THE CENTERS FOR
DISEASE CONTROL AND PREVENTION
AND AS YOU KNOW WE PUSHED OUT
RECENTLY TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY SIX
MILLION DOLLARS. FOR A LOCAL
PARTNERS RECENTLY AND THAT
FEDERAL EAT WHAT WE CALL E. L.
C. DOLLARS THAT IS TRUE ALL
COUNTIES X. FROM THE COUNTY OF
LOS ANGELES. COUNTY OF LOS
ANGELES OUT OF SEPARATE
ALLOCATION OF BURNER AND EIGHTY
NINE MILLION DOLLARS. FOR THE
PURPOSES OF CONTACT TRACING
TESTING ETCETERA AND SO. IN
ADDITION TO THE FUNDING THAT
YOU SEE AND THE LETTER THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. I WISH
YESTERDAY THERE ARE ADDITIONAL
FEDERAL RESOURCES THAT WE'RE
PRO ACTIVELY PUSHING OU AT
YOUR LOCAL PARTNERS FOR BOTH
CONTACT TRACING AND TESTING
EFFORTS ON TESTING IN
PARTICULAR- WE ARE LOOKING AT
IDENTIFYING ADDITIONAL
MODALITIES. THE LOOKING AT HOW
DO WE LEVERAGE ALL TESTING HOW
DO WE ENSURE THAT WE HAVE
MOBILE TESTING CAPACITY SO
WE'RE WORKING ON. BUILDING OUT
THOSE PIECES ON THE CONTACT
RACING SIDE BY WE ARE REALLY
LOOKING AT HOW DO WE LEVERAGE
THE RESOURCES THAT WE HAVE AT
THE LEVEL OF TRANSIT. WE HAVE
CURRENTLY. WHILE THE SAME TIME
CAN. TO BE ON BECAUSE- YEAH
GALLY AUSTIN SAYS WE HAVE TO
FIND EQUAL. BUT WE REDUCE THE
TRANSMISSION. I DON'T THAT
ALLOWS THEM TO CONTACT REYES
ALL THE POSITIVE. WHILE AT THE
SAME TIME BUILDING UP OUR
CONTACT RECENT ACTIVITY. FROM A
TECHNOLOGY PERSPECTIVE BUT ON.
HUMAN RESPECT. ANSWER ARE ALL
POLL AFTER THAT WERE WERE. VERY
CLOSELY. I APPRECIATE. THAT
NOTE THAT OFTEN MY CONVERSATION
WITH ADMINISTRATION PARTICULAR
COMES MONEY DOES DON'T INCLUDE
NUMBER. AND QUITE. AND
QUALITATIVE I TO GET WE'RE
DOING THIS WOULD BE THAT THAT'S
GOOD BUT- I YOU KNOW FOR A-
WOULD BE. TO HAVE- THE REPORTS
FROM THE ADMINISTRATION ABOUT
THE TOTAL AMOUNT OF MONEY AND
THEN BROKEN DOWN BY WHAT THE
SOURCES ARE. BECAUSE SOMETIMES
I HEAR WEALTH AND FEDERAL
GOVERNMENTS GIVING MONEY FOR
THIS SO THAT'S BEEN COVERED BY
THAT I DON'T KNOW EXACTLY HOW
MUCH IT IS. SO WE NEED TO BREAK
THESE WE NEED TO HAVE THAT
TOTAL PICTURE. OF EXACTLY WHAT
IS OUR CAPACITY THAT WERE
FUNDING. FROM ALL THE DIFFERENT
SOURCES AND SO THAT'S THAT'S
I'M HOPING WE CAN HAVE THAT
KIND OF- REPORTING AND
TRANSPARENCY FROM THE FINANCE
ADMINISTRATION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MOVING ONTO CENTER DRAWS UP
THERE ALSO WILL BE FOLLOWED BY
CENTER CABALLERO. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. I HAVE TWO BASIC
QUESTIONS. ONE IS WHY. DID YOU
NOT FEEL IT WAS IMPORTANT. TO
PROVIDE THE LEGISLATURE WITH
MORE INFORMATION AND MORE
OFTEN. AND JUST TO GIVE AN
EXAMPLE AS VICE CHAIR OF THE
LATINO CAUCUS I KNOW WE SENT IN.
SOMEWHERE BETWEEN FIVE AND TEN
LETTERS IDENTIFYING ISSUES AND
QUESTIONS AND- THE YOU KNOW
REQUEST OF MINE I'D UNDERSTAND
THERE WERE A LOT MORE
LEGISLATORS WHO ARE DOING THAT
SO WHY DDN'T YOU FEEL. IT WAS
IMPORTANT OR NECESSARY ODD TO
PROVIDE THIS INFORMATION. JUST
TO RESET COLOR WHITE PANTS
AGAIN WE REALLY ARE TRYING TO
PROVIDE THIS INFORMATION THAT
WE ARE YOU KNOW PROVIDING IN
AUGUST UPDATE. WE ARE DOING
THAT AS WE ALSO AND ENDEAVORING
TO DO IT ON A MONTHLY BASIS
THIS WILL HAPPEN AT THE SAME
TIME AS WE'RE PUTTING TOGETHER
THIS FALL THAT THE JANUARY
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET SO THIS IS-
TRYING TO REPORT OUT ON A
REGULAR BASIS IN PROGRAM
CATEGORIES WERE TRYING TO- ALSO
TAKE FEEDBACK AS WE'RE HEARING
THAT AND REFINE THESE- THIS
LOOKS A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT
THAN WHAT WE PUT OUT IN MAINE
WE HAVE A BIT MORE DETAIL.
CATEGORY SO AS YOU'RE GATHERING
THAT DETAIL WE ARE PUTTING IT
OUT THERE- WE ARE TRYING TO.
BALANCE WITH PROVIDE IT I
TRYING. CLEAR WAY WITH PUTTING
IN A LOT OF INFORMATION YOU'LL
NOTICE IN OUR MEMO. WE ARE ALSO
TRYING TO HIGHLIGHT WHAT'S
HAPPENING ON THE CORONAVIRUS
REALLY FUND ALLOCATION SO
THAT'S KIND OF AND- SENATOR
PAM'S POINT AS- SEE MORE OF THE
PICTURE SO WE REALLY ARE TRYING
TO PUT THAT INFORMATION OUT
THERE IN A WAY THAT'S HELPFUL.
TO FOLKS AND CATEGORIES THAT-
THAT MAKES SENSE AND- SHOW THE
PROGRESS AS AS WE MOVE THROUGH
THIS DYNAMIC AND YOU KNOW THESE
THESE. MEMBERS WILL CHANGE AND
WE WILL CONTINUE TO REFINE AND
THE FUNDING SOURCES OF WHAT'S
AVAILABLE FROM THE FEDERAL
FUNDS- MAKE ME CHANGE AND SO WE
ARE ATTEMPTING TO DO. EXACTLY
AS I DO SENSE. I HAVE ANOTHER
BOMB ONE MORE QUESTION-
RECENTLY- THE GOVERNOR
ANNOUNCED ADDITION ON THIS IS
ABOUT PROCUREMENT. ANNOUNCED
ADDITIONAL PROCUREMENT
SPENDING- HE EMPHASIZED THAT
HE'S WORKING WITH COMPANIES
LIKE THREE M. AND HONEYWELL. AS
AN EXAMPLE THE FUTURE MASS
PROCUREMENTS WILL HAVE A JOB
CREATION FOCUS. I HAVE A TWO
PART QUESTION WHICH IS HOW ARE
YOU ADDRESSING THE STANDARDS
THE WORKING STANDARDS OF ANY
COMPANY THAT WE ENGAGE IN
CONTRACTS WHETHER BY SUPPLIES
FROM. WHAT ARE THE STANDARDS
THEY'RE FOR THE WORKERS- THAT'S
VERY IMPORTANT- THERE'S BEEN
NUMEROUS ARTICLES IN LA TIMES
AND OTHER OTHER PARTS OF THE
STATE. ABOUT. A HOUSE WHICH
JOBS ARE STILL OPEN OUT YOU AS
THEY CALLED UPON TO. MAKE
PROTECTIVE GEAR- SO I'M VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT ONE IS A REPORT
ON THE ACTUAL THAT THESE
PROCUREMENT THESE CONTRACTS
LEAD TO JOB CREATION- AND THE
STANDARDS FOR THE WORKERS IN
THOSE LOCATIONS WHERE WE SPEND
OUR TAX DOLLARS. HOW ARE WE
WATCHING OUT FOR THE STANDARDS
FOR THOSE- WORKERS- I THINK
THOSE ARE REALLY IMPORTANT I
KNOW GARMENT WORKERS AND OTHER
WORKERS WHO AREN'T GETTING-
WHAT THEY DO IS WHAT THEY NEED
TO CARRY OUT THEIR WORK AND IT
COULD BE THIS ADMINISTRATION IS
CONTRACTING OUT WITH THOSE
COMPANIES. CALDERON FINANCE-
AGAIN I DON'T HAVE THOSE
DETAILS AT THE READY SO THAT
MIGHT BE ANOTHER- IT WILL HAVE
TO TAKE BACK TO GET YOU. MORE
INFORMATION SENATOR. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THIRTY CABALLERO.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR- FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY ASK A COUPLE
QUESTIONS- MY ME START OFF BY
SAYING THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THE INFORMATION YOU'RE GIVING
US HERE TODAY- YOU KNOW EVERY
TIME WE HVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
WE LEARN SOMETHING NEW AND I
THINK THAT'S THAT'S GREAT BUT-
IT MAY BE THAT. WE CAN BE
HELPFUL IN SOME OF OUR EFFORTS
TO TRY TO STEM THIS- TERRIBLE
DISEASE YEAH AND- THAT'S REALLY
KIND OF THE POINT THAT I WANT
TO THAT I WANT TO LEAVE WITH-
DETERMINE WHERE THE MONEY IS
BEING SPENT AND THEN. TO
WHETHER IT'S ACTUALLY BEING
EFFECTIVE AND GETTING US TO A
PLACE WHERE WE'RE GOING TO BE
ABLE TO- OPEN OUR OUR OUR
BUSINESSES IN OUR SCHOOLS- SO
MY FIRST QUESTION I THOUGHT SO
MY DISTRICT HAS TWENTY SEVEN
CITIES FOUR OF WHICH ARE LARGER
THAN FORTY THOUSAND BUT MOST
ARE SMALL. FARMWORKERS RURAL-
COMMUNITIES AND IF YOU HAD
ASKED ME THREE MONTHS AGO
WHETHER I THOUGHT THAT WE WERE
GOING TO SEE AN UPSWING OF
INFECTION AMONG. LATINO
FARMWORKERS I WOULD'VE SAID
ABSOLUTELY NUMBER ONE BECAUSE
THEY WERE GOING TO WORK AND THE
WORK HASN'T CHANGED IN MANY OF
THE FEELS. FROM THE WAY THEY
DID THE WORK. A YEAR AGO AND
I'VE SEEN IT WITH MY OWN EYES
AND PEOPLE ARE WORKING SHOULDER
TO SHOULDER AND THEN THE GOING
HOME TO OVERCROWDED SITUATIONS
DURING OUR TO DO DUE TO OUR
HOUSING CRISIS- AND SO. WHEN WE
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT TESTING THE
TESTING FOR THE MOST PART HAS
BEEN PLACED IN BIG CITIES- IN
TERMS OF THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
AND SO THAT THE SMALL
COMMUNITIES. WHO DESPERATELY
NEED TESTING ARE NOT GETTING
THE TESTING SITES THAT THEY
NEEDED AND SO THERE'S THIS
DISCONNECT BETWEEN- WHERE THE-TESTING SITES ARE LOCATED AND
WHO GETS FIRST PRIORITY AND
WHETHER IT'S EASY ENOUGH. FOR
THE FAMILY MEMBERS TO BE ABLE
TO GO AND GET A TEST DONE SO
TESTING CONTINUES TO BE TO BE A
REAL PROBLEM AND BECAUSE OF THE
LACK OF TESTING. THE INFECTION
RATE HAS BEEN ALLOWED TO
EXPLODE TO A POINT WHERE NOW-
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THE
COUNTIES THAT I REPRESENT THEY
DID NOT USED TO BE ON THE RED
LEICESTER NOW ON THE RED LAST
AND SO- NUMBER ONE IS I'M I'M-
CONCERNED ABOUT. WHETHER WORK
TOWARD MEETING WITH THE
COUNTIES WHO HAVE RECEIVED
COUNTIES AND CITIES WHO HAVE
RECEIVED KERR'S MONEY SO THAT
WERE ADEQUATELY. ALLOCATING THE
RESOURCES. TO COVERED IN.
pIT'S MOST POP WITH ARE WELL.
AND WHERE THEY CAN ACT TOSE
TESTINGS REALLY. ON AND THEN
THEN NUMBER TWO IS. THAT THE
HOUSE FOR. PROGRAM IS REALLY
IMPORTANT- BUT WHY IT'S HOUSED
IN CDFA. IT IS A QUESTION THAT
I ASK AND I LEARNED TODAY THAT
THAT'S WHERE IT'S GOING TO BE
HOUSE ARM I LOVE CVS CDFA THEY
DO TERRIFIC WORK- BUT THEY'RE
NOT THE ONES THAT ARE IN CHARGE
THAT THAT HAVE CONTACT WITH
FARMWORKERS. IF WE REALLY WANT
TO GET FARMWORKERS HOUSE AND
WHAT WHAT IT SAYS HERE JUST.
YOU KNOW AGAIN WHY IT GETS ME
GOING IS. IT'S TO PROVIDE
SHELTER AND SERVICES TO THOSE
IN THE AGRICULTURAL INDUSTRY
WILL WE KNOW WHO IT IS THAT
DOESN'T HAVE THE RESOURCES. TO
SET SAFELY SELF ISOLATE IT'S
FARMWORKERS AND SO HOW DO WE
GET. INFORMATION AT THE END THE
AVAILABILITY OF THIS KIND OF
INFRASTRUCTURE TO HELP
FARMWORKERS BECAUSE QUITE
FRANKLY THEY ARE TERRIFIED.
THEY'RE BEING ASKED TO WORK
EVEN WHEN THEY'RE SICK. IN MANY
INSTANCES AND FRANKLY SOMETIMES
THEY WORK WHEN THEY'RE SICK
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T AFFORD NOT
TO WORK THIS IS THIS THIS IS
THE PART OF THE SEASON WHERE
THERE'S- NOT WORK AVAILABLE. UP
SO I AM MY NUMBER ONE ARE WE
COORDINATING WITH THE COUNTY IS
AND NUMBER TWO WE NEED TO
REALLY LOOK AT HOW DO WE GET.
FUNDS AT THE GRASSROOTS LEVEL
TO START HELPING THE MOST
VULNERABLE VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS THAT RIGHT. NOW WE
KNOW HAVE BECOME. TREMENDOUSLY
INFO AND STARTED AFFECT THE FOR
SAYS. THANK YOU SENATOR I'LL
I'LL START PAN AM TRYING TO
RESPOND AT THAT SECOND QUESTION
FIRST AND THEN I'LL TURN THE
FIRST QUESTION ON TESTING OVER
TO MARK ON EACH YEAR BUT ON
HOUSING HARVEST IS LED BY THE
DEPARTMENT COULD AND I. BUT IT
IS A- COMPREHENSIVE EVER THAT
DAY IN. THEIR CALL FROM DEPART
SOCIAL SERVICES OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES ALSO. THAT
BUSINESS CONSUMER SERVICES
HOUSING AGENTS SO THERE'S A-
COLLABORATIVE. TO IT IS NOT.
JUST SEE IF A WORKING ON IT OWN
THEY ARE IN AND HOW YES OF MANY
ORGANS AND LOT OF FREE OUTREACH
AND DISCUSS WITH COUNTIES AND
IS GOING I WILL TURN FIRST
QUESTION ON TEST OVER TO. AT
JESSE. SENATOR THANK YOU FOR
CALL READ CASH IN. AND IN
PARTICULAR THE ISSUE AROUND
FARMWORKERS AND ABLE TO ENSURE
A WE- ARE PROVIDE ASKING. AS
THE WHAT WE'VE DONE WITH. TO
THE STATE RUN TESTING SO WE
WHAT WE HAVE CONTACT WITH OPTIM
SERVE AND WE'VE GOT. OUR
CLOTHES. AT WE HAVE. PLUS
OPTIONS THEIR LEASE I. ACROSS
THE STATE WHAT WE LOW AT A
WORKING OUR COUNTY PARTNERS
FIRST AND FOREMOST DETERMINE.
WHERE WE SHOULD LOOK THOSE ON
THAT HELLO NAY WE AND- IS
OBVIOUS. ARE NOT BEST OUR
BETTER FIGURING OUT WHERE THEY
NEED IS AT THE LOW LEVEL AND IT
WAS. FOR US TO UP. CITIES AND
COUNTIES ALLY IT'S I THINK OF.
WHERE WE GET AYE AYE I LOOK
THOSE THREE. BASED ON THE LOCAL
AT WE ALSO LOOKED AT. OUT WAYS
WHICH WE COULD ADD. MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE PASS OF. THERE
WERE. CASTING LOOKING WITH
THIRTY AND ROW AIR AND SIXTEEN
EVER RURAL. AND SO WE'VE GOT
THAT DISTRICT OF THE STATE THE
OTHER THING I NOTE WITH THREE.
OKAY FARM IMPRINT. YEAH WE HAVE
ACTIVE THROUGH OUR OVER.
SERVICE AS S. VALLEY CATS FORCE
WHICH IS REALLY. ON I. B. THIS
VALLEY COUNTIES. BUT WE'VE ALSO
ALLOCATED A HUNDRED DOLLARS AS
PART OF THE- DOLLARS THAT I
ALLUDED TO IN. TO SENATOR PANTS.
REALLY LOOKING B. B. UP OUR
MOBILE TO CAPACITY IN THIS IS
WHAT WE KERN. FROM OUR PARTNERS
PER. FARM AND ORGANIZATIONS
THAT. FARM THAT MOBILE TESTING
WHAT BE A MUCH. THAT WAY. BE A
VALUE AND SO WE HAVE CLOSED AND
S. P. AND WHEN WE VERY QUICKLY
TECH. ADDITIONAL THAT WE CAN
DEPLOY IN PART WITH ACCOUNT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HAVE YOU. TO
REALLY OUR Y. ARRAY OF END OF.
HELP. FOR TESTING. FOR A REALLY
LONG TIME BUT LET ME JUST SAY
THAT. OUT OF THE SIX COUNTIES
THAT I REPRESENT THREE OF THEM
HAD SHERIFF'S IT SAID THEY WERE
NOT GOING TO ENFORCE THE MASK
ORDER- WAY BACK IN IN MAY. AND
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AT
THAT POINT WERE VERY RESISTANT
TO BELIEVE THAT THIS WAS
ACTUALLY A CRISIS SO I
UNDERSTAND WE HAVE TO WORK WITH
OUR COUNTY PARTNERS BUT IT'S
BEEN REALLY FRUSTRATING.
BECAUSE UNTIL RIGHT NOW WHEN
EVERYBODY STILL ON THE REDLIST
IT'S BEEN VERY DIFFICULT TO GET
COOPERATION SO THAT THEY
ACTUALLY ALLOCATE RESOURCES TO
THE COMMUNITIES THAT NEED IT
THE MOST AND SO. THEY ARE
PARTNER PARTNERS I WANT TO SEE
IS WORK WITH THEM BUT WE'VE GOT
TO BE ABLE TO GO ABOVE AND
BEYOND AT SOME POINT IF WE
DON'T GET THE COOPERATION THAT
WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO SAY HOW
CAN WE DEAL WITH THIS. IN A WAY
THAT. THAT REALLY SHOWS THAT
WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT ABOUT
PEOPLE THAT ARE SUFFERING.
THANK YOU SENATOR AKOWSKI YES
MANAGER I'M LOOKING AT THE
ESTIMATED EXPENDITURES FROM
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY
AND IN TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND YOU KNOW BECAUSE
TWENTY BY TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY TWENTY HELPS TO SELL
THEM IN THE BIGGEST. ADJUSTED I
GUESS WAS IN THE PROCUREMENT OF
MASKIN OTHER MATERIALS IT WAS
ONE POINT EIGHT. BILLION LESS
AND YOU KNOW IF WE USE MARCH
APRIL MAY AND JUNE IT'S SORT OF
A FOUR MONTH PERIOD THAT WE
KNOW WE ONLY SPENT YOU KNOW. A
BILLION DOLLARS IN THAT FOUR
MONTH PERIOD. AND I'M FOLLOWING
UP ON MY COLLEAGUES ON THE FOOD
BANK WE ONLY REALLY SPEND YOU
KNOW TWENTY FIVE. MILLION OR
BILLION AND THAT THAT THAT ARE
MILLION IN THAT TIME PERIOD
THEN WHEN I GET TO TWENTY.
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE
WE'RE GOING TO BE SO WEIRD. WE
DON'T KNOW HOW LONG THIS
PANDEMIC IS GOOD TO GO BUT IT'S
GOOD TO GO FOR THE FULL TWELVE
MONTHS NOT FOR. FOUR MONTHS IN
THE PROCUREMENT NUMBER IS. AS
MUCH AS WE'D SPENT ON MASK FOR
A FOUR MONTH PERIOD. AND THEN.
AT THE END THEY'VE WITH THEY DO
HAVE FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR
FOOD BANKS BUT AT THE END THEY
HAVE THAT THE OTHER RESPONSE
COSTS THE GREAT PLATES
DELIVERY. WE WERE THREE HUNDRED
MILLION WE THOUGHT THAT WE'RE
GOING TO SPEND TWENTY FIVE.
MILLION EACH MONTH AND NOW THE
NEW ESTIMATE. A MONTH AND A
HALF INTO THE BUDGET YEAR IS
NOW ONLY TWENTY FIVE BILLION IS
SUCH A BIG DISCREPANCY SO CAN
THEY TELL. NO WE WILL LEARNING
THE BEST LESSONS I GET THE MASS
BECAUSE YOU SAY YOU DIDN'T NEED
SO MANY OR THEY GOT A BETTER
PRICE FOR. OUR PEOPLE LESS
HUNGRY- THIRTY BECAUSE I SEE BY
JUST CASUALLY WATCH THE TV IT'S
JUST SEEMS. EVERY WEEK THERE'S
ANOTHER LINE OF A FOOD BANK
OPENING UP IN IN THIS THIS.
CHARGE OF HUNGER SO WHETHER
IT'S IN THE FOOD BANK. OR THE-
THE GREAT PLATES DELIVERY IT
SEEMS LIKE WE'RE CUTTING THAT
BACK. AND ASSERT THAT'S- WHAT
IF WHAT WE LEARN THE FIRST THE
LAST FOUR MONTHS OF THE- LAST
BUT YEAR IN AND NOW WE'RE A
MONTH AND A HALF INTO THE NEW
BUDGET YEAR AND- IT SEEMS AS
THOUGH THAT. THERE'S AN
INADEQUATE TESTAMENT IS MY
POINT. THIS IS. VERY ADVANCED
AND ON THE PROCUREMENT OF
CERTAIN THE PROCUREMENTS WE ARE.
NINETEEN TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
PAST FISCAL YEAR DID COME IN
LOWER THAN ANTICIPATED OVER ALL
WE'RE TRACKING- ALMOST SEVEN
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS LESS-
OVER THE TWO YEARS- STEVEN
MENTIONED IS JUST DOING A
SCREEN SURE FOR US AND THAT
PROCUREMENT SIGNED. WITH BOTH
YEARS. TO GATHER IS ABOUT SEVEN
HUNDRED MILLION LAST YEAR
THAT'S ALSO RESULT AND SOME OF
OUR ESTIMATES OF. PURCHASES
THAT DIDN'T HAPPEN IN NINETEEN
TWENTY SHIFTING INTO TWENTY
TWENTY ONE- SO THAT DYNAMIC WE
DO THAT WHAT HAVE WE- LEARNED
OVER THE PAST FEW MONTHS AS AS
JUST BEING SENT MATERIALIZE BY
JUNE THIRTIETH BUT- THERE IS
STILL AN ANTICIPATED. NEED I
THINK THE OTHER QUESTIONS IN
OUR WAREHOUSE WE HAD WAS ON THE
OTHER RESPONSE COSTLY WHICH IS
NEAR THE BOTTOM OF OUR CHURCH.
WHAT'S NOT JUST GREAT PLACE SO
THAT WHEN Y. AS- AND WHEN WE
HAD PROPOSED IN MAY OUR OUR
CONTINGENCY WE HAD A THREE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR LINE IN
THERE ANOTHER RESPONSE COST
WHICH WAS. THAT A BIT OF A
CATCH ALSO GREAT PLATES IS PART
OF THAT LINE BUT THAT WASN'T
THE ENTIRETY OF THE GREAT PLACE
ESTIMATES OR IT DIDN'T REFLECT
THE TRAINING MILLION WASN'T
REPLACED. YOU'LL NOTICE TWO ONE
OF THE DIFFERENCES THAT'S-
PRETTY CLOSE TO THAT AMOUNT OF
WHAT WE STAYED IN THE OTHER
RESPONSE COST IS NOW IN THE
STATE RESPONSE OPERATIONS LINE.
LAND WHICH IS NEAR THE TOP OF
THE CHART AND THAT ONE WENT UP
BY- SEVERAL- SEVERAL HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS AND AGAIN WITH
MORE DETAIL SO. ABSOLUTELY
CONTINUE TO GET REFINED- THESE
WELL THESE WILL CHANGE AGAIN
YOU KNOW THAT THAT GOES TO THAT
THE NOTION OF HERD REQUESTING
MORE. FREQUENT UPDATES AND
AGAIN I PLAN TO. UPDATE ON
MONTHLY BASIS LIKE I HOPE THAT
HELPS. I GUESS IN THE INCREASE-
OF ONE POINT ONE. BILLION
DOLLARS AND PROCUREMENT IS THAT
BECAUSE WE NEED MORE MASTERS
IT'S A PRICE PER MASK CAME UP
JUST GENERALLY. YEAH I KNOW
GENERALLY THAT SOUNDS LIKE A
REFERENCE TO THAT TWENTY TWENTY
ONE- ESTIMATEA LOT OF THAT IS
SHIFTING SO THINGS THAT DIDN'T-
PERHAPS MATERIALIZE IN NINETEEN
TWENTY OR SHIFTING SO THAT
GROSSED OUT ONE POINT ONE FIVE
FIVE NUMBER. NEAR THE MIDDLE OF
YOUR SCREEN AND THAT IS MOVED
MORE AT SHIFT FROM NINETEEN
TWENTY TO TWENTY TWENTY ONE
BECAUSE SOME SOME COSTS FOR
MASKS DID DECLINE SINCE- CENTER
EARLIER ESTIMATE AND ME SO IT'S
A MIX OF. BEING. BRIGITTE THAT
THOMAS CALVERT ON MONITORING
OUR TIME AND LET ME JUST SAY
THAT I'M GOING TO HAVE STAFF-
FOLLOW UP ON SOME OPERATIONAL
QUESTIONS- FOR YOU THAT I HAVE
PLEASE IT INCLUDES THINGS LIKE
THE FREQUENCY WITH WHICH WE
EXPECT TO HAVE THE REPORT YOU
HEARD LOTS OF COMMENTS FROM
MEMBERS AS WELL AS THE L. A. O.
AW I'M GOING TO HAVE THEM
FOLLOW UP CALL WITH REGARD TO-
WHAT YOUR PLAN IS WITH REGARD
TO SECTION THIRTY SIX
NOTIFICATION IF. IF THEY'LL BE
MADE TO LEGISLATURE AS THEY ARE
MADE AFTER THEIR MATES ALL
WE'RE GOING TO FOLLOW UP ON
SOME OF THOSE REPORTING-
QUESTION THAT EXPECTATIONS- BUT
I DO WANT TO KNOW- BEFORE WE
TRANSITION- IF THE STATE
EXPENDITURES EXCEED THE CURRENT
BUDGET. BUDGET ESTIMATES WHAT
SOURCE OF FUNDING WILL THE
ADMINISTRATION USE. YES SO AND-
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE AS A MENTION
ESPECIALLY THE TRIO OF
PRESENTATION WE HAVE. THE
AMOUNT ESTIMATED ONLY ALSO AS A
RESULT OF THAT BUDGET ACT THERE
IS ESTIMATED SEVEN HUNDRED
SIXTEEN MILLION DOLLARS IN A
SPECIAL PLAN FOR ECONOMIC
UNCERTAINTIES ATTRIBUTED TO
THAT KIND OF IN THAT GENERAL
FUND COSTS FOR THESE. COSTS
PRETTY INCREASED COST WE NO
COST WILL CHANGE COST COULD
INCREASE WE WOULD THEN. NEED TO
USE MORE TO REALIZE AND THAT
WAS IT AND- IMPACT THE GENERAL
FUND AND IT COULD IMPACT IT.
MORE IF THESE ARE FOR
ACTIVITIES THAT AREN'T FOUND TO
BE THEME ARE REIMBURSABLE FROM
THAT FUNDING SOURCE- BUT AGAIN
WE TRYING TO LOOK AND USE THAT
FEDERAL FUNDING AVAILABLE AND
TO. MAXIMIZE THAT THAT USED TO
FEDERAL FUNDING WHERE
APPROPRIATE BUT IT COSTS GO UP
IT WOULD BE. AND ALSO. IMPACT
OUR GENERAL FUND ESTIMATES
MOVING FORWARD OKAY AGAIN WILL
HAVE STAFF FOLLOW UP AND I HOPE
THAT YOU REALLY- HEARD THE
TENOR OF THE- COMMITTEE MEMBERS
EXPECTATION THAT THAT EVEN
THOUGH JAIL HAS UNDERSTAFFED
YOU- SO YOU HAVE CERTAIN
FLEXIBILITY THROUGH JAIL
ACCOUNT THAT THERE REALLY IS A
CLEAR AND ARTICULATED DESIRE
THAT THE LEGISLATURE BE ENGAGED
IN A VERY FORTHRIGHT UPFRONT
MANNER IN TERMS OF PARTNERING
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION AND
LOOK LIVE IT UP TO THE
EXPECTATION OF OUR ROLE. OF THE
LEGISLATURE IN TERMS OF HAVING
DISCUSSIONS HAVING CLEAR
UNDERSTANDING ABOUT HOW DOLLARS
HAVE BEEN ALLOCATED WHAT'S BEEN
SPENT- AS WELL AS OUR ROLE IN
TERMS OF PROVIDING GUIDANCE AND
DIRECTION TO THOSE- ACTIONS
WILL CONTINUE TO FOLLOW UP-
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION. THANK YOU WHAT
THAT COLLEAGUES WE'RE GOING TO
TRANSITION TO THE SECOND HALF
OF THIS MORNING'S AGENDA YOU
pTHIRTY MINUTES LATE AND SO I'M
GOING TO BE MANAGING OUR TIME
SO IF I. ASK YOU FOR YOUR-
FINAL QUESTION I HOPE THAT YOU
WILL BE ASSISTING THIS POSSIBLE
BECAUSE WE ALSO HAVE A PANEL
THAT WILL BE PARTICIPATING
TODAY. OUR FIRST STEP UNDER
WHICH TRANSITION TO THE
DISCUSSION OF THE GOVERNOR'S
AND LEGISLATURE'S DJJ
REALIGNMENT PROPOSAL. FIRST
WE'RE GOING TO HEAR FROM- THE
L. A. O. LUCRECIA MARTEL FISCAL
POLICY ANALYSTS. FOLLOWED BY
CLINT CALLUM ASSISTED PROP
PROGRAM UP. BUDGET MANAGER
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WILL THEN
GO ON TO OUR PANEL AND MEMBER
QUESTIONS WILL BE AT THE END SO
PLEASE MAKE NOTE OF YOUR
QUESTIONS AND WHO YOU WANT
OPPOSE THEM TO. BE A PANELIST
BELIAU OR FINANCE LUKE. GOOD
MORNING- MAKERS MORROW WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
EVEN RUNNING A COMPARISON OF
BOTH THE GOVERNOR'S JUNIPER
VERSION OF THE PROPOSAL TO
REALIGN THE DIVISION OF
JUVENILE JUSTICE FROM THE STATE
TO GET COUNTY. AS WELL AS A
LEGISLATIVE ALTERNATIVE- IF YOU
HAVE AN AGENDA IN FRONT OF YOU
I WILL BE USING THE TABLE AND
THAT ATTENDED IT STRUCTURE MY
COMMENTS. SO YOU CAN CALL THAT.
STARTING OFF WITH A GUN STREET.
IT TAKES DAY THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL WOULD CLOSE IN TAKE ON
JULY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
THE LEGISLATIVE ALTERNATIVE
WOULD CLOSE INTAKE BEGINNING ON
JULY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY THREE.
AND THE- ADMINISTRATION
PROPOSAL DOES NOT INCLUDE A
FINAL CLOSURE DATE FOR DJJ
CURRENTLY BUT THE MINISTRATION
HAS STATED IN AND ARRIVE
FIFTEEN DAY. SOMEONE GOING. TO
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN BUDGET PROCESS. AND
FOR THE CULTURE HAS OCCURRED.
THE LEGISLATIVE. WOULD BE
PROVIDED OF DECEMBER THIRTY FOR
TWENTY TWENTY THREE AND ANY
YEARS REMAINING IN DETAIL I
THOUGHT THAT DATE WOULD BE
TRANSFERRED BACK TO THE COUNTY
OF JOB STATION. BUT PROPOSAL'S
WOULDN'T. SOME LEVEL OF STATE
PLANNING AND OVERSIGHT. UNDER
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL
UNTIL DJ IS CLOSED. THE
EXISTING CHILD WELFARE COUNCIL
C. W. C. WHICH IS AN ADVISORY
BODY FOR AGENCIES AND COUNTIES
THAT SERVE CHILDREN YOUR FOR
THE CHILD WELCOME CULTURE CARE
SYTEMS WHAT ADVICE DID CHANGE
ITS WAYS SUCH AS DEVELOPING
STRATEGIES TO AVOID ADULT COURT
TRANSFORMERS AND GUIDELINES FOR
FUNDING. AS WELL AS OVERSEE.
UNDER THE LEGISLATURE TO
BEGINNING SEPTEMBER ONE TWENTY
TWENTY. THAT CDW SEE WHAT
PROVIDE RECOMMENDATIONS
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGISTS
ISSUES THROUGH THE LEGISLATURE
AND BEGINNING ON MAY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE OFFICE OF
YOUTH JUSTICE WOULD BE CREATED
UNDER THE HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES ENGINE AGENCY. AND
WILL BE RESPONSIBLE FOR ALL THE
NON JUSTICE DUTIES ARE
CURRENTLY ASSIGNED TO THE
POOREST STATE COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONS AS WELL AS OTHER
TASKS SUCH AS REGULATORY
OVERSIGHT. DATA COLLECTION. AND
INVESTIGATING COMPLAINTS. BUT
THE ROSEWOOD. FUND FOR DELIVERY.
FOR THE TAKE DIFFERENT
APPROACHES TO DO SO INCLUDING
BOTH BASELINE FUNDING AND
ADDITIONAL GRANT PROGRAMS.
BEGINNING WITH THE BASELINE
FUNDING ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL WOULD PROVIDE FUNDING
BEGINNING JULY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY ONE STARTING WITH FORTY
MILLION GENERAL FUND AND
INCREASING TO TWO HUNDRED NINE
MILLION ANNUALLY BY JULY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR. THIS
FUNDING WILL BE ADJUSTED
ANNUALLY BASED ON GROWTH AND
THE JUVENILE JUSTICE GROWTH
SPECIAL. ACCOUNT IN FUTURE
YEARS. THE MONEY WILL BE OUR
BASED ON THE COUNTY RECENTLY OF
DJJ. AND COUNTY COULD BE
GUARANTEED A MINIMUM ORDER OF
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS. YOU SHOULD BE FUNDS
WOULD HAVE SOME RESTRICTIONS
SUCH AS BEING LIMITED FOR
REHABILITATION HOUSING AND
SUPERVISION FOR YOU OTHERWISE
ELIGIBLE FOR DJJ. BEGINNING ON
THE LEFT SEVERAL TARGETED
FUNDING WOULD ALSO BEGIN ON
JULY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY ONE
BUT BASS LINE FUNDING WOULD
START AT TWENTY SEVEN MILLION
GENERAL FUND AND INCREASED TO
ONE HUNDRED THIRTY NINE MILLION
ANNUALLY BY JULY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR. THE FUNDING WILL
BE ALLOCATED BASED ON A FORMULA
THAT INCLUDES FACTORS SUCH AS
THE COUNTY'S YOUTH POPULATION
THE NUMBER OF YEARS WITH
OFFENSES. WOULD HAVE BEEN DJJ
ELIGIBLE AND ON A TEMPORARY
BASIS THE RECENT USE OF DJJ.
SIMILAR TO MICHAEL PROPOSAL
COUNTIES WOULD BE GUARANTEED A
MINIMUM. ORDER OF TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS.
THERE WOULD ALSO BE
RESTRICTIONS BY ON THIS WHICH
WOULD INCLUDE LIMITS ON CERTAIN
TYPES OF PRIVATE CONTRACTING.
AND WITH ALL THE BILL WOULD
ALSO REQUIRE THAT COUNTIES
ANNUALLY SUBMIT A PLAN SUBJECT
TO STATE APPROVAL DETAILING HOW
THE FUNDING WOULD BE USED AS
WELL AS AN OUTCOME REPORT FOR
THE RESULTS OF PROGRAMS.
OPERATED WITH THIS FUNKY. IT IS
TO THE BASELINE FROM BOTH ROSE
ALL ALSO PROVIDED ADDITIONAL
FROM THE THAT COULD BE USED FOR
THIS POPULATION ANOTHER
MINISTRATION PROPOSAL. THAT
WOULD SET ASIDE NINE POINT SIX
MILLION DOLLARS FOR ONE TIME
STARTUP GRANTS DEVELOP LOCAL
CONTINUUM OF CARE INCLUDING
REGIONAL TREATING FACILITIES.
AND SEX OFFENDER TREATMENT
PROGRAM. IT WOULD ALSO INCLUDE
LANGUAGE CLARIFYING THAT
COUNTIES CAN USE THEIR EXISTING
YOUTHFUL OFFENDER BACHRACH.
RIGHT ENHANCE SERVICES TO YOU
IF YOU WOULD HAVE BEEN D. J. J.
L. DOUBLE IN RECENT YEARS IS
FUNDING HAS BEEN ABOUT ONE
HUNDRED AND FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS. THE REGIONAL MOSEL
WOULD ALSO INCLUDE ADDITIONAL
GRANT FUNDING THROUGH TWO
DIFFERENT GRANT I WOULD GET THE
FIRST WOULD BE A ONE TIME
COMPETITIVE GRANT TO SUPPORT
JUVENILE JUSTICE INFRASTRUCTURE
IN ORDER TO PROVIDE
GEOGRAPHICALLY DIVERSE SECURE
PLACEMENTS AND PROGRAM E. THIS.
WOULD BE- ONGOING COMPETITIVE
GRANT FOR EVIDENCE BASED AND
PROMISING PROGRAMS WHICH WILL
BE DELIVERED BY NON LAW
ENFORCEMENT ENTITIES. FOR
PROGRAMS TARGETED TOWARDS USING
WOULD HAVE BEEN DETECTED
ELIGIBLE. IN ADDITION TO
PRIVATE MONEY THE PROTOCOLS
WILL ALSO PROVIDE GUIDANCE ON
WHERE YOU CAN BE HOUSE EVERY
OTHER THAN MINISTRATION
PROPOSAL REALIGNED YOU FIFTY
HOUSE AND ONE OF VARIOUS TYPES
OF EXISTING COUNTY JUVENILE
FACILITIES CURRENTLY SPECIFIED
IN STATUTE WHICH INCLUDE DO NOT
HOMES RANCHES CAMPS FOR HOLES
IN ADDITION COUNTIES CAN USE
THE START OF BROWN'S TO PROVIDE.
FOR REGIONAL TREATMENT
FACILITIES. ANALOGICAL TERM IN
ADDITION THAT EXIST TAX AND
JUVENILE. TO A NEW TYPE OF
SECURE FIRST SO HE COULD BE
CREATED WHICH WOULD BE INTENDED
TO PROVIDE PROGRAMMING IN
TREATMENT TO INDIVIDUALS
EDUCATED FOR CERTAIN. OR
VIOLENT OFFENSES. IT FOR YOU
THIS CAN COMMITTED TO ONE OF
THESE NEW FACILITIES THE COURT
WOULD BE REQUIRED TO SET THE
TRUMP CONFINEMENT FOR ANY USE
COMMITTED TO BE SOLELY. BASED
ON COMPLIANCE TERMS WHICH WOULD
BE SET BY THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL.
THEY WERE ALSO BE CHANGES TO
EXISTING HE AND FUNDING
STRUCTURE FOR DJJ HE- UNDER THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL. USE
WHAT. CAN DO- CONTINUE TO
ENDURE COMMITTEE DJ UNDER THE
AGE OF TWENTY THREE ANY. WOULD
STILL REQUIRE COUNTIES TO PAY
TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS
PER YEAR. OPEN L. JULY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. THIS IS AN EXISTING
FEEDBACK COUNTS K. JULY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE THIS FEELING THAT
INCREASE TO ONE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
FOR EACH YEAR UNDER THE AGE OF.
TWENTY THREE COMMITTEE TODAY.
I'M LEGISLATIVE ALL. BASICALLY
WHAT AT FOUR DOLLARS PER YEAR.
AND THE LEGISLATURE THEY NOTED
IT INCLUDE. ADDITIONAL FUNDING
FOR COUNTIES TO INCENTIVIZE
THEM TO. CALL USED BEFORE THE
FINAL CLOSURE DATE SPECIFICALLY
BETWEEN JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AT DECEMBER THIRTY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWO COUNCIL
RECEIVED ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR EACH USER.
THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN. AUSTIN
DJJ FOR THE TIME HER THEY WOULD
HELP SECURE. THE FUNDING WOULD
BE OFFSET BY THAT REDUCE COSTS
FROM HOUSES IF INDEED IT. THE
PROPOSAL WOULD ALSO HAVE AN
IMPACT ON YOUTH SENTENCE TO
PRISON. CURRENTLY CERTAINLY
USED TO BE TRANSFERRED FROM
JUVENILE COURT TO ADULT COURT
AND SENTENCED JEFFERSON.
EXPECTATIONS WHEN THE UNITS
UNDER THE AGE OF EIGHTEEN J. J.
HOUSES THAT YEARS UNTIL THEY
ARE EIGHTEEN CONTRACTS FOR THE
PERSON. WHEN DJ CLOSES UNDER
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
COUNTIES WITH HAVE YOUTH
SENTENCED TO PRISON UNTIL THEY
ARE EIGHTEEN YEARS OLD AND THE
STATE PAID ACCOUNT HE'S A RATE
OF SIX HUNDRED AND SIXTY
DOLLARS PER DAY DURING THIS
PERIOD. WHEN YOU USE OUR.
EIGHTEEN THEY WOULD THEN BE
TRANSFERRED TO PRISON. I WOULD
LIKE ABLE TO. COUNTIES WOULD.
YOU TO PRISON UNTIL THEY ARE
EIGHTEEN YEARS OLD SOME OF THE
GOVERNMENT'S PROPOSAL. THE
LEGISLATIVE ALTERNATIVE WOULD
CONSIDER THIS POPULATION TO BE
PART OF THE REALIGNED
RESPONSIBILITIES. AS SUCH NO
FUNDING WOULD BE PROVIDED
DURING THAT PERIOD WHEN
COUNTIES OUR HOUSING EASY IF. I
WANT. TO USE OUR EIGHTEEN AND
TRANSFERRED TO PRISON THEY
WOULD BE REQUIRED TO PAY THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTION REHABILITATION IS
MARGINAL COST. FOR THE DURATION
OF THE YOUTH SENTENCE. ANOTHER
HELPING IMPACT THE REALIGNMENT
IS AGES JURISDICTION FOR
JUVENILE COURSE. COOLEY COURTS
CAN ONLY RETAIN JURISDICTION
UNTIL AN INDIVIDUAL IS TWENTY
ONE A LOT LESS THE YOUTH IS
COMMITTED TO DJJ. COROZAL
SQUATTING PLAYED THE SAME
LANGUAGE TO ACTUAL FUNERAL
COURT JURISDICTION SPECIFICALLY
TO INCREASE THE AGE OF
JURISDICTION IN TWENTY THREE
FOR YOUTH EDUCATED FOR CERTAIN
OFFENSES. OR UP TO TWENTY FIVE
IF THE YOUTH WOULD HAVE
RECEIVED A SENTENCE OF SEVEN OR
MORE YEARS IN CRIMINAL COURT.
THIS IS INTENDED TO BE ARE
THEIR AGES JURISDICTION. FOR
YOUTH COMMITTEE DJ. BOTH
ARRIVALS ARE ALSO IN IN
LANGUAGE TO THE PINE GROVE
YOUTH COME. CAMP OPENED WHICH
IS A FIRE YEAH. LOCAL STATE.
STATE LOCAL PARTNERSHIP OR SOME
OTHER ARRANGEMENT. THE
LEGISLATIVE ALTERNATIVE IT DOES
INCLUDE SOME PROVISIONS ARE NOT
ADDRESSED IN THE GOVERNMENT'S
PROPOSAL. FIRST PLACE
ADDITIONAL RESTRICTIONS ON THE
TRANSPORT USED TO ADULT
FACILITIES. CURRENTLY I DO NOT
USE IT WAS HEALTH LOCALLY AND
HE WAS NINETEEN ALL OR CAN BE
MOVED TO AN ADULT FACILITIES AT
THE JAIL UPON RECOMMENDATION OF
PROBATION. I WOULD LIKE TO SAY
THAT WOULD ALTERNATE. AN
ADDITIONAL STEP BE REQUIRED IN
WHICH A COURT WHEN YOU APPROVAL
SUCH A MOVE BEFORE COULD TAKE
PLACE. IN ADDITION THE ALLEGED
ALTERNATIVE WOULD. VERIFICATION
PLAN FOR IMPROVING JUVENILE
JUSTICE DATA COLLECTION BY
REQUIRING THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE TO SUBMIT A PLAN BY
JANUARY FIRST. TWENTY TWENTY
TWO FOR THE REPLACEMENT OF THE
CURRENT JUVENILE COURT-
INFORMATION STATISTICAL SYSTEM
WHICH PROBABLY IS THAT WAY
INCLINED IN DATA ON LOCAL
JUVENILE JUSTICE STATE. FINALLY
THE LESS IT WILL TURN IT WOULD
INCLUDE INTENT LANGUAGE TO END
THE PRACTICE OF PLACING YOU IN
THE CUSTODY OF SOME PRIVATE
ENTITIES OR IN OTHER STATE
ENTITIES THAT DO NOT PROPERLY
ADDRESSED THE PROGRAMMING AND
SERVICE SAFETY AND OTHER NEEDS.
HI STEVE. THANK YOU. ANSWER
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE. THANK
YOU MUCH GOING TO MOVE ON- TO-
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE CLICK
CALLUM. GOOD MORNING CALENDAR
BERMAN A FINANCE. I APPRECIATE
DALY- PRESENTING THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL I
JUST WANT TO TAKE A QUICK
OPPORTUNITY DISCUSS OUR
PROPOSAL A LITTLE FURTHER WE
SEE THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
PROPOSAL AND FURTHER REFORMING
THE JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM
THAT BUILT ON PREVIOUS
SUCCESSFUL EFFORTS BY
TRANSFERRING THE MANAGEMENT OF
ALL YOUTHFUL OFFENDERS AND DJJ
TO COUNTY. BECAUSE THOSE
CONSISTENT WITH THE EVIDENCE
THAT SHOWS JUSTICE INVOLVED
YOUTH ARE MORE SUCCESSFUL WHEN
THEY STAY CONNECTED WITH THEIR
FAMILIES AND COMMUNITIES. THE
PROPOSAL INCLUDES FUNDING FOR
COUNTIES TO PROVIDE YOUTH WITH
MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT
SPECIALIZED PROGRAMMING IN
EDUCATION. EVASION APARTMENTS
HAVE LED THE EFFORT. TO REDUCE
INCARCERATED YOUTH OF THE LOCAL
LEVEL. REDUCING THE CARBON FROM
OVER A LOT THOUSAND IN TWO
THOUSAND AND SEVEN TO THIRTY
SIX HUNDRED AND TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN A DECREASE OF ALMOST
SEVENTY PERCENT. IT IS THIS
DEMONSTRATED TRACK RECORD ALONG
WITH EVIDENCE OF YOU BEING MORE
SUCCESSFUL LOCALLY THAT IS
INFORMED THIS PROPOSAL. THE
PROPOSAL IS NOT INTENDED TO
REDUCE STATE OVERSIGHT.
APPROPRIATE SAFEGUARDS AND
PARAMETERS ARE NEEDED FOR THE
TRANSFER OF THIS RESPONSIBILITY
AS IS THE STATE'S ASSISTANCE IN
ESTABLISHING NEW COUNTY
PROGRAMS FOR THESE HIGH NEED
YOU. WE APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY PROVIDERS
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUE DISCUSSIONS
WITH THE LEGISLATURE. THANKS
VERY MUCH MR KELLAM- CALLING
YOU'RE GONNA TRANSITION NOW- TO
OUR PANEL. YOUR AGENDA LISTS OF
WHO THEY ARE IN THE
ORGANIZATION THEY REPRESENT
WE'RE GONNA- INDEED AND THE
POINT OF HAVING THE- PANELISTS
TO REALLY HEAR FROM THEIR
PERSPECTIVE. ON WHAT
CONSIDERATIONS LESSONS LEARNED
IN ASPECTS ARE CRITICAL TO
SUCCESSFUL REALIGNMENT WE'RE
GOING TO START WITH CHIEF.
TANYA HEITMAN SANTA BARBARA
VICE CHAIR OF C. P. O. C.
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE. CHIEF
HITEN WILL BE FOLLOWED BY
DOCTOR BOB ROSS PRESIDENT CEO
OF THE CALIFORNIA ENDOWMENT.
WILL BE FOLLOWED BY SHOULD MAKE
A GASKINS EVEY OF THE
CHILDREN'S DEFENSE FUND
CALIFORNIA AND FINALLY FRANKIE
GOOS MON DIRECTOR YOUTH JUSTICE
INITIATIVE AT THE NATIONAL
CENTER FOR YOUTH LAW.
DEPARTMENT THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US YOU- AND EVERY
PALACE CALLED THE BILL HAVE
FIVE MINUTES AND I'LL. BE
WATCHING THE CLOCK THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU I HOPE MY
VIDEO AND AUDIO IS OKAY THAT
TURKEY HAS GONE OUT MY
COMMUNITY IT'S PERFECTLY FINE
TO YOU CHOOSE. WHICH DEVICES
OKAY GOOD GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ON TONYA HYPE AND
CHIEF PROBATION OFFICER FOR
SANTA BARBARA COUNTY AND
LEGISLATIVE VICE CHAIR FOR THE
CHIEF PROBATION OFFICERS OF
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU FOR THE
INVITATION TO OFFER A MARKS ON
BEHALF OF THE PARK. THIS
HISTORIC DISCUSSION THAT WILL
MOVE USE PLACED AT DJJ CLOSER
TO HOME IS FILLED WITH HOPE.
AND THE CHIEF PROBATION OFFICER
SHARE THAT HOPE. HOWEVER IT'S
NOT WITHOUT POTENTIAL
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES MANY OF
WHICH LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WOULD
BE LEFT TO RESOLVE. THEREFORE
WELL WE REGISTERED OUR OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED TO THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISION. SINCE
THEN WE'VE ENGAGED IN ROBUST
DISCUSSIONS WITH POLICYMAKERS
TO RESPOND TO THIS MOMENT AND
STRIVE TO PARTNER IN
ACCOMPLISHING SOMETHING
HISTORIC. WHILE ENSURING IT CAN
SAFELY BE ACCOMPLISHED. IN A
WAY THAT IMPROVES OUTCOMES FOR
YOU. PROBATION CHIEFS WORKED
HARD TO TRANSFER OUR WORK
SHIFTING TO A POSITIVE YOUTH
DEVELOPMENT FRAMEWORK. LETTING
GO OF OUTDATED INEFFECTIVE
MODELS AND INVESTING IN
TRAINING AND EDUCATION TO
CREATE A MORE HEALTH FOCUSED
TRAUMA INFORMED AND- PASSIONATE
JEWEL JUSTICE SYSTEM. THAT
DIVERTS THE MAJORITY OF YOU AND
UTILIZES INDIVIDUALIZED
APPROACH FOR THOSE WITH HIGH
NEEDS TO HELP THEM ACHIEVE LONG
TERM SUCCESS. IT'S IMPORTANT TO
REMEMBER WHERE WE'VE COME FROM
AND HOW FAR WE HAVE COME.
CALIFORNIA TODAY HAS A JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM WERE OVER 95% OF
YOU ARE SUCCESSFULLY SERVE
LOCALLY. AND WHERE 90% OF USED
UNDER OUR CARE AND SUPERVISION
ARE SAFELY TREATED IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. MASON IS A UNIQUE
AND I AM DUPLICATED CONNECTOR
IN THE SYSTEM THAT HELPS THE
MOST VULNERABLE AND FRAGILE
YOU. WE TOUCH SO MANY ASPECTS
WITH OUR CONTINUUM AND OFTEN
SERVE AS A SAFETY NET FOR USE
WITH. OTHER SYSTEMS HAVE FAILED.
CALIFORNIA PROBATION IS UNIQUE
IN THE NATION AS WELL WE
COLLABORATE WITH MANY STATE
ENTITIES AS WE SERVE OUR COURTS
ARE LOCAL BARD OF SUPERVISORS
AND OUR COMMUNITIES. WE'VE
PARTNERED WITH MANY OF YOU WELL
WE'VE ADVOCATED FOR AND
IMPLEMENTED MANY JUVENILE
JUSTICE REFORMS FOR MORE THAN A
DECADE. INCLUDING JUVENILE
JUSTICE REALIGNMENT OR S. B.
EIGHTY ONE THE REALIGNMENT OF
THE JUVENILE CORAL SYSTEM.
CONTENT YOU KNOW CONTINUUM OF
CARE REFORM FOCUSING ON FOSTER
YOUTH. AND RETURNING THE
AUTHORITY FOR TRANSFERS TO
ADULT COURT BACK TO JUDGES AS
PART OF PROP THIRTY SEVEN. BUT
MORE CAN BE DONE AND SHOULD BE
DONE. MOST RECENTLY WE EMBARK
IN AN EFFORT TO RAISE THE AGE
OF JUVENILE COURT JURISDICTION
AND CODIFY BEST PRACTICES TO
REFLECT A MORE EQUITABLE
DELIVERY OF SERVICES TO YOUTH
ACROSS ALL JURISDICTIONS. ALSO
NOTICED ELEVATE JUSTICE ACT. WE
ACKNOWLEDGE AND THANK SENATOR
SKINNER AND OTHERS AND HELPING
US EMBARK ON THIS IMPORTANT
DISCUSSION THAT CAN CHANGE THE
LIVES OF OUR EMERGING ADULT
POPULATION. ALSO STRENGTHENING
THE ENTIRETY OF OUR WORK WITH
THE JUVENILE JUSTICE. TODAY THE
CONVERSATION FOCUSES ON THE
CLOSURE OF DJJ AND PROBATION
CHIEFS ARE PREPARED TO HELP THE
STATE SHAPE WHAT IS NEEDED TO
MAKE THAT SUCCESSFUL. WE WANT
TO ENSURE THAT IT'S DONE IN
SUCH A WAY THAT WE ENHANCE
OUTCOMES FOR YOUTH. AND
SPECIFICALLY WHAT WE MUST BE
ABLE TO TAILOR PROGRAMS
SERVICES CAPACITY AND DELIVERY
METHODS TO THE NEEDS OF THE
YEAR. WE MUST BE ABLE TO RELY
ON STABLE SECURE FISCAL SUPPORT
TO KAREN TREAT THESE COMPLEX
AND HIGH NEED YOU. WE MUST
ACCOUNT FOR COUNTIES THAT DO
NOT HAVE CAPACITY FOR THE
APPROPRIATE CAPACITY FOR
TREATMENT. WE CANNOT BUILD A
SYSTEM THAT LEAVES SOME YOUTH
BEHIND WITHOUT HOPE. WE MUST
INVEST IN THE REDESIGN OF OUR
SPACES TO TRANSFORM THEM INTO
MORE THERAPEUTIC HOME LIKE
ENVIRONMENTS. MORE REFLECTIVE
OF THE TROM INFORMED WORK THAT
OUR YOUTH REQUIRE. WE MUST
ACHIEVE A CLEAR BALANCE OF
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TREATMENT
WITHIN THE NEW MODEL THAT
INSTILLS CONFIDENCE IN OUR
SYSTEM PARTNERS SO THAT WE
AVOID MORE YOUTH ENTERING THE
ADULT SYSTEM. WE MUST
COORDINATE ADDITIONS TO THE
SYSTEM THAT WILL NOT DUPLICATE
THE MANY ENTITIES CURRENTLY
COLLABORATING. ON PLANNING AND
OVERSIGHT WHILE THIS CURRENT
CONSTRUCT CAN SEE EXHAUSTIVE BY
THE ENTITY IS VERY DIFFERENT
FROM ONE ANOTHER THEY SERVE AS
A CONTINUUM. OF CHECKS AND
BALANCES THAT WORK TOGETHER.
AND FINALLY AS THE STATE WE
CANNOT DIRECTLY OR
INADVERTENTLY CREATE A SCENARIO
WHEREBY THE REALIGNMENT OF DJJ
HARMS OVER 95% OF YOU. WE
CURRENTLY WORK WITH AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL. WE ARE TO THE
LEGISLATURE TO FOCUS ON THE
INTEGRATION OF THE DJJ
POPULATION DURING THE SCRIPT
CRITICAL WINDOW OF OPPORTUNITY.
IN CLOSING WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO EVERY YEAR
THAT'S IN OUR CARE AND AS A
MOTHER. I FEEL A PERSONAL
RESPONSIBILITY TO EVERY MOTHER
GRANDMOTHER ANSWER I'LL OTHER
LOVED ONE WAS A CHILD AT ONE OF
OUR FACILITIES. THE NEEDS NEEDS
YOU HAVE THE TRAUMA THEY'VE
BEEN DOOR CANNOT BE TAKEN
LIGHTLY AND WE MUST ENSURE
WE'RE NOT JUST ANOTHER FAILED
SYSTEM THAT THEY WILL CYCLE
THROUGH. THE DJJ POPULATION HAS
THE MOST SIGNIFICANT SKIN NEEDS
AND REQUIRE NOTHING SHORT OF
OUR BEST RESEARCH DATA
EXPERTISE AND COMMITMENT. AS I
SIT AND TALK TO THE YOUTH R.
TRUST UNIT IN THE SPACE THAT'S
BEEN RECONFIGURED LIKE A FAMILY
ROOM IN SOMEONE'S HOME RATHER
THAN INSTITUTIONAL DAY ROOM. I
REMINDED WHILE THERE IS STILL
MUCH WORK TO BE DONE WE HAVE
COME A LONG WAY. WHEN I WATCH
THE YOUTH ARE CARE SHARE THEIR
ART WORK OR ENJOY AN OLD
FASHIONED WATER BALLOON FIGHT
ON A HOT DAY. I'M REMINDED WHY
WE WORK SO HARD TO ALLOW THEM
TO BE CHILDREN. IF DONE WELL
THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO DO SO
MUCH MORE TO IMPROVE THE SYSTEM
WHAT KEEPING OUR CHILDREN IN
OUR COMMUNITY. PLEASE NOTE THAT
THE PROBATION CHIEF STAND READY
TO WORK WITH THIS COMMITTEE AND
THE ADMINISTRATION TO
ACCOMPLISH. THE REALIGNMENT OF
DJJ. IN A WAY THAT ACHIEVES OUR
SHARED GOALS. THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR HAVING ME HERE TODAY. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FIVE MILLION WE
HOPE THAT YOU WILL STAY. ON IN
CASE MEMBERS HAVE QUESTIONS- OF
YOU AFTER- ALL OF THE PANELS
THAT ARE PRESENTED- DOCTOR ROSS.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR CAN
YOU HEAR ME OK I CAN HEAR YOU
FINE THANK YOU. MORNING MANAGER
SIR GREAT TO SEE YOU- AND THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO BE
INVITED TO. SPEAKS OF THIS
HISTORIC RESTORED MOMENT BUT
THAT AS YOU KNOW WELL MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR SEVERAL SPINNERS WELCOMES
YOU HAVE IT'SA CONDUCTOR ROSS
WOULD YOU SPEAK UP JUST A
LITTLE BIT I HAVE BEEN BIRDS
ARE HAVING A HARD TIME HEARING
YOU. IT'S ONLY A HISTORIC
MOMENT IF WE GET IT RIGHT IS
THAT BETTER YES THANK YOU. IT'S
ONLY HISTORIC MOMENT THERE IF
WE GET IT RIGHT AND I JUST
WANTED TO SPEAK TO WHAT. THAT
MIGHT LOOK LIKE A DEGREE
TESTIMONY FROM- TWO CATALYSTS-
BETTER. BALL MADE. AS A
PEDIATRICIAN A PRESIDENCY OF
THE CALIFORNIA TELEPHONE WHAT
THE STYLE OF ASIAN. OF THE
CALIFORNIA ENDOWMENT WE HAVE TO
STAND UP THE MOST. SIGNIFICANT
CONTRIBUTORS TO HELP. OUR LAW
OUTSIDE THE MEDICAL. OUR CHEN
YEAR ONE POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLAR INVESTMENT IN BUILDING
HEALTHY COMMUNITIES HAS TAUGHT
US THAT OUR WELL BEING SHAPED
BY THE CONDITIONS IN WHICH WE
ARE BORN GROW LIVE. WORK AND
PLAY.THESE LAST SEVERAL MONTHS
HAVE BEEN A OBJECT LESSON THE
HARD LESSONS ABOUT OUR NATION
ON THE MATTER OF WHAT HAPPENS
IN THESE ENVIRONMENTS
INSTRUCTORS ARE LACKING. HOLDEN
NINETEEN SAVAGE HEALTH AND
ECONOMIC IMPACTS THAT
DISPROPORTION FOLLOWING NEWS OF
COLOR BURKE STRESSED OUT
REGIONAL SYSTEMIC RACISM AS
WELL DEFENDER INVESTMENT IN
FORWARD POLICING IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES. AND THIS EXTENDS
THE DJJ WERE 93% OF
INCARCERATED YOUNG PEOPLE ARE
YOU ALL. WE HAVE SPENT TOO MUCH
MONEY ON SURVEILLANCE
CRIMINALIZATION AND THE TENSION
AND FAR TOO LITTLE ON
HEALTHCARE HOUSING JOBS. AND
SCHOOLS FOR YOUNG PEOPLE. WE
KNOW WHAT IT TAKES TO HELP.
THESE YOUNG PEOPLE SO IN
GROWING FOR NEXT GENERATION OF
LEADERS. IT IS THE LAW OF CARE
IN SUPPORT OF THEIR
COMMUNITIES. AND THEIR FAMILIES
AND THEIR LOCAL INSTITUTIONS. I
ENCOURAGE THAT WE HAVE THIS
HISTORIC OPPORTUNITY TO BRING
YOU THE DJJ FACILITIES BACK TO
THEIR HOME UNITY IS THAT IT CAN
BE CLOSER TO THIS KIND OF
SUPPORT. MANY OF THESE YOUNG
PEOPLE SUPPORTERS OF CHILDHOOD
TRAUMA. VIOLENCE NEGLECT AND
OTHER FORMS OF ADVERSITY IN THE
INTERFERE. NEVER LOGICALLY OF
INTERFERE WITH THE HEALTHY
DEVELOPMENT OF THEIR BODIES AND
MINDS. YOU CAN EXPOSE THE TRIAL
OR MORE LIKELY TO HAVE A FIGHT
OR FLIGHT RESPONSIBLE MEANS OF
CRISIS. AS THE BRAIN GOES INTO
SURVIVAL MODE AND THIS CAN LEAD
TO RASH DECISIONS AND SOMETIMES
TRAGIC MISTAKES. THE FIRST
QUESTION A POSITION TRAINED TO
TROUBLE ASK IS. WHAT HAPPENS
AND- NOT WHY DID YOU DO THAT.
WE WANT TO HELP YOUNG PEOPLE
LEARN FROM MISTAKES GET BACK ON
TRACK WE NEED TO ADDRESS THE
ROOT CAUSE. THE YOUNG PERSON'S
OF USING DRUGS WHAT IS THE CAME
HERE TRYING TO KNOW. IS IT
BECAUSE YOU'VE BEEN A VICTIM OF
SEXUAL VIOLENCE. IF SOMEONE
STOLE SOMETHING FROM A GROCERY
STORE WAS IT BECAUSE HE WAS ONE.
THE PERSON RACIAL NOT ADDRESS
THESE RECALLS IF. WHAT WE KNOW
WHAT WILL. YOUNG PEOPLE THRIVE
WHEN THEY HAVE SUPPORT IN THEIR
COMMUNITY AND PARTS SEPARATED
FROM THEIR FAMILIES SCHOOLS AND
LOCAL SUPPORT. A COMPREHENSIVE
RESEARCH REVIEW BY THE NATIONAL
RESEARCH COUNCIL TWENTY
THIRTEEN REPEAL THE COMMUNITY
BASED SERVICES PRODUCED MUCH
BETTER OUTCOMES FOR YOUTH.
REDUCE RECIDIVISM AND COSTS
LESS SIMPLY MOVING YOU FROM
LARGE SCALE STATE FACILITIES
FOR LOCAL EQUIVALENTS IS NOT
THE ANSWER. THIS APPROACH IS
BEING TAKEN UP FOR OVERLOOKING
COUNTY LEADERS IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY WE'VE SEEN NINE YOUR
FACILITIES OF CLOSE SINCE
TWENTY SEVENTEEN. AND MORE THAN
SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS SINCE
BEEN REDIRECTED TO PROGRAMS
OPERATED BY NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE
SUCCEEDING IN REDUCING YOUR FOR
US AS MUCH AS THIRTY PERCENT.
AND YOU THINK RESTORATION BY AS
MUCH AS 50% CITY AND COUNTY OF
SAN FRANCISCO WITH PLANNING TO
CLOSE ITS OLD JUVENILE HALL AND
REINVEST THOSE RESOURCES INTO
COMMUNITY ALTERNATIVES.
REALIGNMENT OFFERS OF THE
OFFERS US A CHANCE TO CHANGE
THE NARRATIVE AROUND WHAT IT
TAKES TO CREATE COMMUNITIES SAY.
THAT WE ACHIEVE IT NOT THROUGH
BARS WITH MEANINGFUL
INVESTMENTS AND DEVELOPMENT OF
YOUNG PEOPLE. WHO ARE MOST IN
NEED OF OUR SUPPORT. WHO ARE
STRUGGLING OF BEST SERVER
HEALTH SERVICES INFRASTRUCTURE
NOT THE JUSTICES. PEOPLE FROM
ALL WALKS OF LIFE ARE WITH US
ON THIS POINT I FEEL POLL
CONDUCTED MARCH FOUR YEARS AGO
INDICATED THAT MORE THAN TWO
THIRDS OF CALIFORNIANS BELIEVE.
THAT THE EDUCATION HEALTHCARE
SYSTEMS ARE BEST SUITED TO
SUPPORT YOUR CORE SYSTEM BALL.
SO WE MUST SEPARATE AND VISION
FOR NEW SYSTEM THAT SEES PEOPLE
FOR THEIR YOUNG PEOPLE FOR
THEIR POTENTIAL NOT THE WORST
MISTAKES THEY'VE EVER MADE.
WE'RE SERIOUS ABOUT CREATING
THE SERVICE CRITICAL NEED TO
FINANCIALLY SUPPORT COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS. WHO HAVE
LONG BEEN A PART OF RESOURCES
OR WE ALSO BRING ABOUT A NET
DECREASE IN THE TOTAL NUMBER OF
YOUNG PEOPLE ACROSS ALL SECURE
THE SUIT. THE BILL AND JUVENILE
STATE AND LOCAL. REENTRY WILL
HAVE LOCALLY IN OUR- OF THE
STATE STILL HAS A- CRITICAL TO
PLAY AN OVERSIZED FUNDING.
ISSUE STRONG ACCOUNTABILITY
OVERSIGHT. GIVEN BY AGENCY
OUTSIDE OF THE JUSTICE SYSTEM
WITH EXPERTISE THE NEW. AND
HEALTH AND WELLNESS. AGENCY
SHOULD HAVE SIGNIFICANT PARTY
INFORM SUBPOENA POWER IT'S
MANDATE SHOULD INCLUDE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR COUNTY DATA
COLLECTION. AND REPORTING TO
TRACK ME COOPER. HUNGARY HAD
SOME OF WELL BEING NOT SIMPLY
GREAT ABSENCE OF JUSTICE SYSTEM
INVOLVEMENT. AS TRACK NEARLY
BARS CITIZENS. SUPPORTING OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE IN OUR COMMUNITY
FOR ME REDUCING THE FOOTPRINT
OF THE JUSTICE SYSTEM THAT
TAKES THEM AWAY FROM THEIR
HOMES AND THEIR FAMILIES. COST
SAVINGS NICHOLS OF BJJ SHOULD
RECALL THE RESULT IMPECCABLE
FUNDING THAT COUNTIES ARE
REQUIRED TO SPEND ON UNITY
BASED ALTERNATIVE COURSE OF
ACTION AND THE REPURPOSING OF
EXISTING BUILDINGS FOR YOUR
DEVELOPMENT. APPLICANTS OR
EXPANSION OF SECURE SOLUTIONS
FOR DETENTION. DJJ YOUTH WITH
THE MOST SERIOUS CHARGES SHOULD
BE PROTECTED AGAINST FOR THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
THE BILL SOMEBODY'S THESE YOUNG
PEOPLE NEED ACCESS TO ENHANCE
TRAUMA INFORMED PROGRAMS THAT
CAN MEET THEIR LEADERSHIP
COGNITIVE VOCATIONAL SOCIAL AND
EMOTIONAL. OF THESE INVESTMENTS
WILL PAY OFF. SENIOR ARE
FOUNDATION OF THE SUPPORTER OF
REIMAGINING JUSTICE IN A THREE
FOR A NEW FOOTBALL JUSTICE AND
THE SERVICES THEY RECEIVE
MOVING FROM THE CRIMINALIZATION
AND PUNISHMENT FRAME ON FOR
HELP AND SUPPORTS AND BRING.
FIRST JAILS LAST GIVEN
OPPORTUNITY TO THRIVE THESE
YOUNG PEOPLE DEMONSTRATE
LEADERSHIP THAT OUR STATE ALSO
DESPERATELY NEEDS IN THIS
GENERATION I DO NOT HAVE CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FORMED
BY THE- SOUNDS. THANK YOU SO
MUCH DOCTOR ROTH OF NEXT MISS
GASKINS EVEY WITH CHILDREN'S
DEFENSE FUND FIVE MINUTES THANK
YOU. MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE IT'S
AN HONOR TO BE HERE MY NAME IS
TO MAKE A GASKINS I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CHILDREN'S DEFENSE FUND
CALIFORNIA A STATE OFFICE OF
THE NATIONAL TRIAL ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION FOUNDED BY MERION
RIGHT ELEMENT. WE CHAMPION
POLICIES AND PROGRAMS THAT
PROVIDE ALL CHILDREN WITH THE
RESOURCES AND OPPORTUNITIES
THEY DESERVE SUCCESSFULLY
TRANSITION INTO ADULTHOOD AND
BECOME DRIVING ENGAGE MEMBERS
OF THEIR COMMUNITIES. AS DR OZ
SAID THE POSSIBLE CLOSURE AT
DJJ PRESENT IN HISTORIC
CROSSROADS FOR CALIFORNIA. IF
DONE RIGHT THE STATE WILL BE
SET ON A PATH OF EVIDENCE BASED
BEST PRACTICES THAT BUILD ON
THE POTENTIAL OF OUR STATES YOU.
IF DONE WRONG THE STATE WIL
HAVE MISSED A CRUCIAL
OPPORTUNITY ONCE AGAIN AND THE
LIVES OF CHILDREN AND
COMMUNITIES WILL BE HARMED.
THIS CROSSROAD COMES AT A TIME
WHEN WE HAVE ALL BEEN FORCE TO
RECKON WITH THE UNCONSCIONABLE
RACIAL AND SOCIAL AND ECONOMIC
INEQUITIES CAUSED BY OUR
SYSTEMS. INCLUDING THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM. FOR FAR TOO
LONG WE HAVE RELIED ON
SURVEILLANCE CONTROL AND
PUNISHMENT TO RESPOND TO YOUR
BEHAVIOR AND THE RESULTS HAVE
BEEN DEVASTATING. JUSTICE
SYSTEMS TOO OFTEN CRIMINALIZED
NORMAL ADOLESCENT BEHAVIOR
FAILED TO ADDRESS THE ROOT
CAUSES OF UNHEALTHY BEHAVIOR
AND INCREASE THE CHANCES OF
FUTURE DELINQUENCY. AND LET US
BE PERFECTLY CLEAR ABOUT WHO IS
IMPACTED BY THESE FAILURES. ARE
BLACK BROWN AND INDIGENOUS YOU
BEAR THE BRUNT OF THE STATE'S
MOST HARMFUL JUSTICE SYSTEM
PRACTICES. AND LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BLACK YOUTH ARE TWENTY
TWO MORE TIMES LIKELY THAN WHAT
USED TO BE INCARCERATED PRE
TRIAL. LET NEXT YOU ARE THREE
POINT SEVEN TIMES MORE LIKELY
AND IN TWENTY NINETEEN A 100%
OF THE YOUTH TRANSFERRED TO THE
ADULT SYSTEM WHERE YOU THE
COLOR. WE CAN DO BETTER AND WE
MUST DO BETTER. WE DO BETTER BY
EMBRACING A HOLISTIC YOUTH
DEVELOPMENT APPROACH FOCUSED ON
PROVIDING OUR YOUTH WITH
OPPORTUNITIES TO LEARN. TO HEAL
TO DEVELOP THEIR SOCIAL SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL PHYSICAL AND
COGNITIVE COMPETENCIES WITH THE
SUPPORT OF CARING FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES. AND LOS ANGELES WE
HAVE BEGUN TO TRANSFORM OUR
YOUTH JUSTICE SYSTEM BY
BRINGING ALL SECTORS TOGETHER.
INCLUDING COMMUNITY AND SYSTEM
IMPACTING YOUNG PEOPLE TO ADOPT
A PUBLIC HEALTH FOCUSED
APPROACH WOULDN'T KNOWLEDGE
ABOUT ADOLESCENT DEVELOPMENT.
WHAT WE NEED NOW IS A
LEADERSHIP CONSTRUED THIS
HAPPENS ACROSS THE STATE.
CALIFORNIA MUST CREATE A STATE
LEVEL OVERSIGHT WITH EXPERTISE
AND YOU HEALTH AND WELL BEING.
NOT ADULT CORRECTION
PHILOSOPHIES. THIS NEW AGENCIES
TO HOLD A VARIETY OF
RESPONSIBILITIES INCLUDING
COLLECTING AND ANALYZING DATA.
DEVELOPING AND ENFORCING
REGULATIONS SERVING AS AN
OMBUDSMAN ADMINISTERING GRANTS
PROVIDING TECHNICAL SUPPORT AND
EDUCATING. AND TRAINING
STAKEHOLDERS AND BEST PRACTICES.
ONE OF HIS GREATEST TO BE TO
ENSURE WISE INVESTMENT AND
EFFECTIVE USE DEVELOPMENT BASED
OUTCOME DRIVEN PROGRAMS AND
ENSURE CONSISTENT DELIVERY OF
SUCH PROGRAMS ACROSS ALL
COUNTIES SHOULD AVOID JUSTICE
BY GEOGRAPHY. A GROWING BODY OF
RESEARCH INCLUDING THE TO YOUR
COMPREHENSIVE STUDY OF BY THE
NATIONAL RESEARCH COUNCIL THE
DOCTOR ROSS MENTIONED IT'S
CLEAR ON THE TYPES OF SERVICES
THAT EACH SUCCESSFUL THAT HE
SUCCESSFULLY THE OUTCOMES.
SERVICES SHOULD BE GROUNDED IN
YOUTH DEVELOPMENT PRINCIPLES
INDIVIDUALLY TAILORED ENGAGE
FAMILIES AND COMMUNITY
RESOURCES AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE
AND BE PROVIDED OUTSIDE OF
INSTITUTIONAL SETTINGS. THAT'S
THE STATE'S TO PRIORITIZE
INVESTMENT AND WHAT WORKS
HEALING CENTER AND CULTURALLY
RELEVANT EVIDENCE THE EVIDENCE
BASED ON COMMENTS HE PROGRAMS
LOCATED IN COMMUNITIES WHERE
YOU PLAN. IN THE EARLY STAGES
OF REALIGNMENT AND ADOPTION OF
A STATE WIDE NEEDS DEVELOPMENT
APPROACH. EXPERTS RECOGNIZE THE
NEED FOR SMALLER SECURE
FACILITIES FOR A LIMITED
POPULATION OF YOU. PARTICULARLY
TO AVOID AN INCREASE OF
TRANSFERS OF YOU TO THE ADULT
SYSTEM. IN LINE WITH RESEARCH
THESE FACILITIES SHOULD BE USED
SPARINGLY AND SHOULD HAVE NON
PRISON LIKE STRUCTURES AND
ENVIRONMENTS ARE PROGRAMMING
METRIC RECREATION AND LIVING
LIVING SPACES. AND WHENEVER
POSSIBLE COMMUNITY WOULD HAVE
PROVIDERS TO BE USED.
PARTICULARLY TO FACILITATE
CONTINUITY OF CARE SO THAT YOU
CAN MAINTAIN POSITIVE
CONSISTENT AND LASTING
CONNECTIONS WITH OTHER YOUTH
AND ADULTS IN THEIR COMMUNITIES
UPON RELEASE. THE RESEARCH IS
THERE WE KNOW HOW TO IMPROVE
THESE OUTCOMES OF PUBLIC
SAFETY. WE HAVE A COLLECTIVE
RESPONSIBILITY IS NOT FAIL OUR
YOUTH AND DEEP IN OUR CURRENT
EQUITIES IN OUR SYSTEM. DJJ
CLOSURE MUST BE IMPLEMENTED
WITH A BOTH ROBUST OVERSIGHT
AND POSITIVE YOUTH DEVELOPMENT
AS A CORNERSTONE THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY.
I PPRECIATE YOU MISTER GASKINS
OF FINALLY WILL HEAR FROM
FRANKIE GOOS MON DIRECTOR.
YOU'VE JUST INITIATIVE AT THE
NATIONAL CENTER FOR YOUTH LAW.
FIVE MINUTES MISTER GOODMAN. I
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I HAVE. I
AM THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME I AM
FRANKIE WAS MINE I'M AN
ATTORNEY AT THE NATIONAL CENTER
FOR YOUTH LAW A NONPROFIT LAW
FIRM IN OAKLAND THAT THAT HELPS
LOW INCOME CHILDREN ACHIEVE
THEIR POTENTIAL BY TRANSFORMING
THE PUBLIC AGENCIES THAT SERVE
THEM I WAS ALSO INCARCERATED AS
A USE. IN THE DIVISION OF
JUVENILE JUSTICE OR BACK THEN
THE CALIFORNIA SORRY WEST SPENT
SIX YEARS. LAST YEAR.
RECOGNIZING THE NEED TO SHIFT
TO A HEALTH BASED TRAUMA
INFORMED AND REHABILITATIVE
APPROACH TO THE STATE'S
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM.
GOVERNOR NEWSOM ANNOUNCED HIS
PROPOSAL TO SHIFT DJJ FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS. TO
THE HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY. WHAT THE LEGISLATURE'S
APPROVAL CALIFORNIA COMMITTED
TO MOVING TOWARD A PUBLIC A
PUBLIC BASED APPROACH TO
HELPING USE. RATHER THAN
INVESTING IN SYSTEMS OF SYSTEMS
OF CONTROL AND PUNISHMENT. NOW
THE GOVERNOR PROPOSES REVERSING
COURSE OFFERING A PLAN TO SHIFT
THE RESPONSIBILITY FOR HOUSTON
DJJ TO THE FIFTY EIGHT POUNDS.
GUARANTEEING MORE THAN TWO
HUNDRED MILLION ANNUALLY. AND
PRIMARILY TO A LOCAL PROBATION
DEPARTMENTS WITH LITTLE
OVERSIGHT GUIDANCE OR
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR HOW FUNDS
WILL BE USED. AND USE WILL BE
TREATED. WE'RE ALL AWARE OF THE
SOCIAL UNREST OVER RACIAL
INEQUALITY AND CALLS FOR
CHANGES TO OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM. REIGNITING THE ONGOING
SITE FOR JUSTICE FOR BLACK AND
BROWN COMMUNITIES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA AND THE NATION. IF
REALIGNMENT IS DONE THE RIGHT
WAY CALIFORNIA WILL BE ABLE TO
REDUCE ITS INEQUITIES THAT USED
IN THE JUSTICE SYSTEM FACE AND
GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITIES OF
COURSE THEY NEED TO THRIVE. THE
LEGISLATIVE PROPOSAL WILL
ACCOMPLISH STAND BY EMPHASIZING
INNOVATION AND COLLABORATION TO
IMPROVE USE OUTCOMES AND PUBLIC
SAFETY. CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF
ONLY A FEW STATES WITHOUT AN
INDEPENDENT OVERSIGHT AGENCY
WITH THE AUTHORITY TO ENFORCE.
LOCAL MINIMUM STANDARDS AND THE
EXPERTISE IN YOUTH JUSTICE TO
EFFECTIVELY SERVE USE WITH
COMPLEX NEEDS. IN A REALIGNED
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM. FOR
THIS REASON. THE LEGISLATURE
PROPOSES AN OFFICE OF YOUTH
JUSTICE WITH WITHIN THE HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY. WITH
THIS OFFICE THE STATE WOULD
CONCENTRATE ALL OF THE STATE'S
YOUTH. JUSTICE FUNCTIONS INTO
ONE YOU'VE SERVING AGENCY THAT
WILL BE RESPONSIBLE FOR
REGULATIONS DATA COLLECTION.
RESEARCH ON BEST PRACTICES AND
GRANT ADMINISTRATION. IF
LEADERSHIP IS CRITICAL BECAUSE
WE CAN THEN BEGIN TO BREAK DOWN
THE SILOS THAT EXIST. SUPPORT
LOCAL CLUB. MODERNIZE DATA
COLLECTION AND INNOVATIVE
PROGRAMS TO EFFECTIVELY SERVE
ALL USE LOCALLY. THE MULTIPLE
FUNDING PROGRAMS PROPOSED BY
THE LEGISLATURE HAVE DIFFERENT
PURPOSES BUT UNIVERSALLY HAVE.
THE SAME GOAL OF PROVIDING
COUNTIES WITH THE RESOURCES TO
DEVELOP A LOCAL CONTINUUM OF
CARE THAT RANGES FROM NON
RESIDENTIAL COMMUNITY BASED
SERVICES TO LOCAL OR REGIONAL
FACILITIES WITH ENHANCED
TREATMENTS FOR REALIGNED USE.
WITH THESE FUNDS IN SUPPORT
COUNTIES CAN BUILD OUR CAPACITY
TO RETAIN AND EFFECTIVELY SERVE
REALIGN USE WHAT EXPANDING
COMMUNITY BASED OPTIONS FOR USE
WAS LOWER NEEDS. THE REAL LINES
YOU FACILITIES GRANT ADDRESSES
THE OBVIOUS NEED TO INCREASE
LOCAL CAPACITY WITH FUNDING FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE RELATED NEEDS
AND IMPROVEMENTS. TO USE
EXISTING LOCAL FACILITIES AS
REGIONAL FACILITIES FOR
GEOGRAPHICALLY DIVERSE LONGER
TERM SECURE PLACEMENTS THE
FACILITIES WILL BE MADE
AVAILABLE TO OTHER COUNTIES
BASED ON CONTRACTUAL AGREEMENTS.
THERE IS ALSO A NEED TO PROVIDE
RESOURCES TO COUNTIES WERE
PROBABLY SERVICE USED IN A
RELAXED SYSTEM WITHIN SECURE
AND NON SECURE SETTINGS. THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE REALIGNMENT
BLOCK GRANT PROGRAM WILL AWARD
COUNTIES WITH FUNDS TO PROVIDE
COUNTY BASED CARE. CUSTODY AND
SUPERVISION OF ALL USED QUICKLY
REALIGNED YEARS. FINALLY THERE
IS A NEED TO PROVIDE TRAUMA
INFORMED CULTURALLY RESPONSIVE
AND EVIDENCE BASED SERVICES
INCLUDING SPECIALIZED TREATMENT
AND PROGRAMMING FOR HIGH NEED
YOUTH. IN THE AREAS OF MENTAL
HEALTH SUBSTANCE USE AND SEX
BEHAVIOR TREATMENT. THERE'S
ALSO A NEED TO DEVELOP MORE
DIVERSE LOCAL PARTNERSHIPS WITH
THE DIVERSITY OF EXPERTISE IN
YOUTH DEVELOPMENT. TO BETTER
SERVE YOU THAT INCLUDES
GOVERNMENTAL AND NON
GOVERNMENTAL STAKEHOLDERS TO
USE AND COMMITTEE RESTORATION
GRANT PROGRAM WILL DO THAT. OF
CRITICAL ARE THE STATUTORY
CHANGES TO PREVENT HARMFUL
TRANSFERS OF USED TO THE ADULT
SYSTEM. A DRACONIAN POLICY AND
PRACTICE THAT OVERWHELMINGLY
IMPACTS USE OF COLOR. ANY
AGREED UPON POLICY. NEEDS TO
AVOID THIS PRACTICE THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS FACT NEXT
JULY AS THE CLOTHES OF DJJ
INTAKE WITH FINAL CLOSURE OF
DJJ OCCURRING BY ATTRITION. BUT
IT OPENS THE DOOR FOR INCREASED
TRANSFERS TO THE ADULT SYSTEM
OF USE AND DOES NOT GIVE
COUNTIES ENOUGH TIME TO PREPARE
FOR YOU COMING BACK FROM DJJ.
AND AS WELL ASUSUAL WHO WILL
HAVE DJ ELIGIBLE OFFENSES ONCE
DJS CLOSED. AFTER DATE FOR
CLOSURE DJJ ENDING AND TAKEN
TWENTY TWENTY THREE AND A
COMPLETE COMPLETE CLOSURE DATE.
BACK TO DECEMBER OF TWENTY
TWENTY THREE PROVIDES TIME FOR
COUNTIES TO CREATE MEANINGFUL
AND APPROPRIATE ALTERNATIVES TO
DJJ IN THE ADULT SYSTEM. IT IS
TIME IT IS A TIME I SUPPORTED
BY LOCAL COUNTIES AND LOCAL. IN
CONCLUSION IT IS CRITICAL THAT
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR GET THIS RIGHT. IT'S
AN IN AN EQUITABLE MANNER THAT
DOES NOT SOLELY FOCUSED ON COST
SAVINGS OR UNINTENTIONALLY IN
DANGER USED IN THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM. FORTUNATELY THE
LEGISLATURE'S PLAN ACCOUNTS FOR
MANY OF THESE ISSUES CURRENTLY
IMPEDING THE STATE'S ABILITY TO
EFFECTIVELY SERVE USED. AND
IMPROVE PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY NAMELY THE LACK OF
VISION LEADERSHIP EXPERTISE
ACCOUNTABILITY. IN OUR IN OUR
FRACTURED JUVENILE JUSTICE
SYSTEM BY ESTABLISHING
OVERSIGHT ENTITY WHAT THE
RESEARCH DRIVEN HOW FOCUSED WE
CAN BETTER SUPPORT LOCAL
PROGRAMS ENSURE UNIFORM AN
APPROPRIATE RESPONSES TO USE.
AND MAKE BEST USE OF SCARCE
STATE FUNDS WHILE REDUCING
RACIAL DISPARITIES IN OUR
SYSTEM THANK YOU. MONTH THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION THANKS TO ALL OF
THE PANELISTS WHO ARE CARVED
OUT SOME TIME ON YOUR SATURDAY
MORNING TO JOIN THIS WILL. OPEN
IT TO MEMBERS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. CENTER MORE LOT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR HEY. SAID
ON CORRECTIONS PUBLIC SAFETY IN
JUDICIARY SUB FIVE WITH
SENATORS. SKINNER AND BELL AND
WE'VE DISCUSSED THIS SICK A
LITTLE BIT OVER THE OVER THE-
LAST YEAR TOO BUT- WHAT I WHAT
I WAS MISSING FROM THE
PRESENTATION SAYS WHAT. IS THE
SEED THAT IS DRIVING THIS IDEA
IT WAS- LITTLE HOOVER
COMMISSION REPORTER AT LA-
REPORTERS STATE AUDITOR'S
REPORT. ARE WE JUST LOOKING AT
MAYBE SUCCESSFUL MODELS FROM
OTHER STATES ALL RIGHT SO IT IS
YOUR QUESTION DIRECTED TO
FINANCE ABOUT WHAT WAS THE
IMPETUS FOR THE ADMINISTRATION
TO SUGGEST THE TRANSFER FROM
DJJ. IN THE FIRST PLACE JUST
REMIND ME I JUST COULDN'T WERE
INTERESTED IN HEARING FROM MANY
OF THE PRESENTATION OR FINANCE.
YES SO I THINK THE IMPETUS WERE
SORT OF MULTI FOLD I THINK. THE
PANDEMIC PRESENTED AN
OPPORTUNITY- THAT HAD BEEN
PREVIOUSLY I'M NOT CONSIDERED
POSSIBLE TO REALIGN THIS- SMALL
CONTINGENT OF POPULATION STILL
KEPT AT THE STATE LEVEL TO
COUNTIES- THE REASON FOR DOING
THAT IS THAT THE EVIDENCE HAS
SHOWN THAT THEY NEED TO BETTER
LOCALLY WHEN THEY'RE CLOSER TO
THEIR FAMILIES AND COMMUNITIES
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVEN THE STATE
TOOK ON- A SIMILAR REALIGNMENT
AFTER. BIRD WITH A DIFFERENT
POPULATION- REALIGNING THOSE
FROM DJJ AT THE TIME TO THE
COUNTIES- AND POPULATION AT
BOTH THE LOCAL LEVEL AND AT THE
STATE LEVEL HAS DECREASED
SIGNIFICANTLY SINCE THEN SO
WE'VE WE'VE SEEN WE'VE SEEN SB
A SUCCESSFUL MODEL- FOR THESE
YEARS AND SO I THINK IT'S A
CONTINUATION OF THAT EFFORT-
THAT IS KIND OF BROUGHT US TO
THIS POINT. THANK THANK YOU
MISTER COLOR MORE LIKE I WOULD
ADD AS I RECALL THE FIRST
ACTION- THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
TOOK OCCURRED BEFORE CALL OF
IT. IN TERMS OF BUDGET ACTION
AND ARE THERE ANY BEFORE I TURN
OVER THE CITY TO SKINNER WHO'D
LIKE TO ALL THE SERVICE COULD
YOU HAVE A QUESTION OR DO YOU
WANT TO RESPOND TO SEND MORE
OUT. BOTH OKAY- I WANTED TO
OPEN UP TO IF ANY OF OUR
PANELISTS WHO HAVE. YOU KNOW WE
HAVE A FUNDER WE HAVE NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS OF ANY. BODY ON
THE PANEL WOULD LIKE TO BRIEFLY
RESPOND TO SENATOR MORE LOCK.
IN TERMS OF- THEIR PERSPECTIVE
IN TERMS OF THE HISTORY. OF
THIS IDEA AND WHAT RESEARCH HAS
BEEN DONE ANYBODY ON THE PANEL.
YEAH MADAM CHAIR DOCTOR ROSS'S
AT YOU YES YES IT IS I THINK OF
IT THIS HAS BEEN BUILDING FOR
QUITE SOME TIME BUT I THINK THE
MOST RECENT- CATALYTIC MOMENT
WAS IN THE GOVERNOR SHORTLY
AFTER HIS INAUGURATION. WELL
DECLARED HIS INTENT TO
TRANSFORM THE JUVENILE JUSTICE
SYSTEM AS WE KNOW IT. WHICH WAS
ECHOING THE SENTIMENTS OF BOTH
FIGHTERS LIKE THE CHILDREN FUND
THEN WAS THE GROUP'S MONTH
ORGANIZATION FOR QUITE SOME
TIME SO THAT WAS A VERY
IMPORTANT- CATALYTIC GO A
MOMENT OF THE GOVERNOR MADE A
DECLARATION AND NOW WE'RE GOING
THIS IS LOOKING ON HOW WE MAKE
GOOD. ON THAT ON THAT. WHICH IS
FOLLOWED BY NUMBER OF COUNTIES
ACROSS THE STATE FINNEMORE LOCK
BACK TO YOU YEAH THANK YOU- MR
COLUMN- YOU KNOW JUST TRYING TO
RESEARCH BACK IN TWO THOUSAND
FIVE. SENATOR GLORIA ROMERO DID
WHAT WAS CALLED A G. R. P. A
GOVERNMENT REORGANIZATION PLAN
WHICH- WAS SORT OF DRIVEN BY
THE LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION
AND- THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE ALSO WEIGHED IN- AND SO
IT WAS A MAJOR REFORM DURING
THE SCHWARZENEGGER
ADMINISTRATION. AND I'M JUST
WONDERING WHY DON'T WE HAVE
THIS G. R. P. OR THIS THIS
GOVERNMENT REORGANIZATION PLAN.
WITH REGARDS TO. REALIGNMENT OF
DJJ. ADD THAT GOVERNOR
REORGANIZATION PLANS ARE
USUALLY- RELATED TO WHEN
DEPARTMENTS ARE COMBINED OR
TAKEN APART IT IS MY
UNDERSTANDING HERE VERSUS- SORT
OF SHIFTING RESPONSIBILITY-
BETWEEN THE STATE AND LOCALS-
WHICH HAS HAPPENED A VARIOUS
POINTS IN THE PAST AS I
DESCRIBE IN TWO THOUSAND SEVEN-
WHEN THE PRIOR- USE REALIGNMENT
TOOK PLACE- IN ADDITION- THE
PUBLIC SAFETY REALIGNMENT TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN I BELIEVE WAS
DONE WITHOUT A GOVERNOR RE
ORGANIZATION PLAN SO- I DON'T
THINK IT'S COMMON FOR THAT TO
BE THE VEHICLE FOR MAKING THIS
DECISION. SO THEN IT'S OKAY TO
DO SOMETHING OF THIS. MAGNITUDE
IN A BUDGET TRAILER BILL.
FINNEMORE LIKELY TO MOVE YOUR
MIKE LOCAL FOR PLEASE I'M SORRY
MEASURES ARE. BECAUSE I'M JUST
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND POLICIES
AND PROCEDURES. LEAST
HISTORICAL- METHODS OF HAVING
TO EITHER MERGE OR ORDERS MOVE
DEPARTMENT- IT LOOKS LIKE WE'RE
DOING IT THROUGH A PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT BUDGET TRAILER BILL
INSTEAD SO I'M JUST. TRYING TO
SEE DO WE HAVE A MODEL. FOR HOW
THIS IS DONE OR IS IT JUST. SO
THAT WE'RE NOT GETTING GET THE
KIND OF. WHAT I GUESS THE
DETAILS THAT THE PROJECTIONS
THE NARRATIVES OF WHY WE'RE
WE'RE DOING THIS- BECAUSE I
HAVEN'T SEEN ANY. REALLY
THOROUGH REPORTS AND I
APPRECIATE THAT YOU MADE A-
OPPORTUNITY FOR HEARING TODAY
SO WE CAN LEARN A LITTLE BIT
MORE BUT- RIGHT THAT THAT THE
THAT WAS JUST THE GIST OF MY
CONCERNS THANK YU MADAM CHAIR
THANK YOU AND MR KUSHER MORAL
FROM THE L. A. L. YOU WANTED TO
RESPOND AS WELL. YES I JUST
WANTED TO ADD ITEMS LITTLE BIT
MORE IN THE HISTORY OF THE
CONCEPT OF FULLY REALIGNED
DIVISION AND- THE DIVISION OF
JUVENILE JUSTICE. IT ACTUALLY
CAME UP. SEVERAL YEARS AGO AS
PART OF THAT TWENTY TWELVE.
TWENTY THIRTEEN BUDGET PROCESS-
FULLY ALIGNED ADDITION OF
JUVENILE JUSTICE IN. THIS
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL AT THAT
TIME. L. A. N. D. COME OUT AND-
OF THE CONCEPT OF REALIGNING
THE DIVISIONS YOU KNOW JUST
SAYS ALTHOUGH WE DID RESIDENTS
GOING TO. PROPOSAL HAPPENED
STRUCTURE- BENEFITS WE HAD DONE
FOR WHY. WOULD BE A GOOD
SOLUTION IS IT INCREASES
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR RESULTS
PROMOTES FLEXIBILITY INNOVATION
SEE AN INNOVATION. AND IMPROVE
OUTCOMES CONSIDERATION OF LOCAL
SERVICES- WE HAVE SHOWN THAT
REPORT FROM TWENTY TWELVE
TWENTY THIRTEEN WAS. THANK YOU
THINK THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
I'M JUST CURIOUS MEASURES MY
LAST QUESTION ARE WE DON'T HAVE
DJJ IS A REPRESENTATIVE ON THE
PANEL OR A SMALL RURAL COUNTY
AND IT. JUST CURIOUS OF. HOW
THEY'RE REACTING TO THIS
PROPOSAL. OF FINANCE. WITH
REGARD TO- OVER OR HOW ABOUT-
CHIEF HEITMANN WHO REPRESENTS-
CHIEF PROBATION OFFICER SHE
REPRESENTS. OF COUNTIES OF ALL
SIZES SHE FIVE MEN WOULD YOU.
CARE TO WEIGH IN ON HOW YOUR
YOUR SMALL COUNTY COUNTERPARTS
ARE WEIGHING IN. CERTAINLY
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY.
WE ARE WORKING CLOSELY WITH ALL
THE VARIETY OF- COUNTIES ACROSS
THE STATE- TO LOOK AT HOW WE
BEST. MOVE FORWARD AND WORK
WITH THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE ON THE
VARYING PROPOSALS. I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER THAT- WE
ARE. GOING TO CONTINUE TO
ELEVATE PRACTICES AND PROVIDE.
SOME LEVEL OF STANDARDIZATION
AND WE DO BELIEVE IN THESE- THE
NEED FOR STRONGER OUTCOMES AND
BETTER DATA BUT WE ALSO BELIEVE
THAT- WE NEED TO BE VERY
RESPONSIVE AND RESPECTFUL OF
THE FACT THAT. WE HAVE A
VARIETY OF SITUATIONS ACROSS
THE COUNTY IS AND HISTORICALLY
THE COUNTIES ARE BEST EQUIPPED
TO LEVERAGE- ASSISTANCE AND-
REGIONAL TYPE OF APPROACHES
WHEN THEY'RE ABLE TO DO THAT.
WITHIN THE CONTEXT OF THEIR-
THERE WERE- UNIQUE NEEDS AND
ABILITY TO. PARTNER AS
APPROPRIATE FOR THE TYPE OF USE
THAT THEIR COMMUNITY ARE SEEING
AND NEED TO SERVICE. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ANYMORE LAW I SEE. MY EX
RACE FROM SENATOR SKINNER LEYVA
AND BELL AND AROUSAL STARTED
LISTENING TO SKINNER THANK YOU
MADAMCHAIR TO- TO ADD A LITTLE
TO THE CONTEXT THAT SPEND
DISCUSSED SO YES THERE HAVE
BEEN FIVE PASSED CONTENT BY
DISCUSSIONS AROUND THE A
REALIGNMENT MODEL AS WAS
REFERENCE BY THE L. A. AND
OBVIOUSLY THIS ACTION MANY MANY
MANY YEARS AGO CURRENT. AD
WHICH I DON'T REALLY RECALL I'M
NOT AS FAMILIAR WITH TINY
ELEVEN THE. AND THE- MOSTRI.
ACTION BY THE LEGISLATURE BASED
ON THE GOVERNOR OF OWN PROPOSAL
WAS LAST YEAR WHEN THE GOVERNOR
AS DOCTOR ROSS REFERENCED YOU
REFERENCED RIGHT AFTER IS HIS
INAUGURATION BUT THEN. THE
GOVERNOR- MADE A CONCRETE
PROPOSAL LAST YEAR WHEN HE
PROPOSED TO IN HIS WORDS AND
THE JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM AS
WE KNOW IT. AND MOVE A DJJ INTO
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES. TO
FOLLOWING NEW MODEL THAT WOULD
ALLOW HEALTH OFFICIALS TO MOVE
TOWARDS ADDRESSING SUCH THINGS
AS EARLY CHILDHOOD TRAUMA. AND
THE LEGISLATURE ADOPTED THAT-
ACTION WE ENACTED IT TO MOVE TO
MAKE THAT MOVEMENT NOW IT WAS
SILENT ON THE CLOSURE OF THE
STATE FACILITIES NOW NONE OF US
I THINK IN THE DISCUSSIONS AND
WHILE IT WASN'T NECESSARILY
DEBATED ON THE FLOOR. IN THE
DISCUSSIONS IN THE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEES. THERE WAS
DISCUSSION ABOUT DID THE
ADMINISTRATION ANTICIPATE IN
THIS MOVE OVER TIME POTENTIALLY
CLOSING THOSE STATE FACILITIES
WHICH HAS BEEN. DISCUSSED FOR
MANY YEARS AND IN FACT WE HAVE
FAR FEWER WE HAVE QUITE A GOOD
RUN GREAT REDUCTION IN THE
NUMBER OF YOUTH THERE ARE
SERVED IN THE STATE FACILITIES
AND QUITE. A SMALLER NUMBER OF
THEM THAN WE HAVE IN PASSED AND
SO WHILE IT WAS AN EXPLICIT IN
THE ACTION THAT WE TOOK LAST
YEAR. I THINK THERE WAS SOME
ANTICIPATION THAT OVER TIME
WITH DJJ BEING UNDER HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES THERE WOULD BE A
CHANGE TO THE PRACTICE OF THE
STATE RUN DJJ FACILITIES THOUGH
AGAIN IT WAS NOT EXPLICIT IN
THE PROPOSAL. SO NOW THIS YEAR
WE ARE AS HAS BEEN DISCUSSED
AND DESCRIBED FACED WITH A
CHANGE WE'RE WOULD BE UNDER A
REALIGNMENT MODEL AND THE
REALIGNMENT MODEL BEING RATHER
THAN THE- STATE DJJ FACILITIES
THAT THEY WOULD BE EXPLICITLY
CLOSE THAT'S EXPLICITLY IN THE
PROPOSAL. AND ARE COUNTIES
WOULD HAVE THE RESPONSIBILITY
FOR THE ATTACK AND I THINK
THERE'S- ASISTIR ALREADY BEEN
HEARD YOU KNOW MUCH. MUCH TO BE
SAID FOR THE BENEFIT OF OUR
YOUTH BEING. HELD OR TREATED
CLOSER TO HOME CLOSER TO THEIR
SUPPORT SERVICES TO THEIR
ENVIRONMENT. I THINK ONE OF THE
KEY ISSUES BEFORE US IS. WE
WILL AND I WONDER AND I WANTED
TO PARTMINER FINANCE TO-
RESPOND TO THIS WHY DID THE
GOVERNOR MOVE AWAY FROM THE
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES MODEL
NUMBER FOR THE ANSWER I JUST
WANT TO POINT OUT. THE
CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF ONLY TEN
STATES. THAT HAS JUVENILE
JUSTICE UNDER CORRECTIONS AND
IF WE IN A FOR EXAMPLE WE MOVE
STRICT PROBATION AS MUCH AS
PROBATION HAS SOME VERY GOOD
SERVICES IN VARIOUS COUNTIES IT
IS A CORRECTIONS MODEL SO
THERE'S ONLY TEN STATES WITH
THAT. FORTY FORTY STATES HAVE
JUVENILE. UNDER EITHER HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES- CHILD
WELFARE SO I JUST WONDERED IF
DEPARTMENT FINANCE ONE COMMENT
WHY. THE GOVERNOR IN THE
REALIGNMENT PROPOSAL MOVED AWAY
FROM THE HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES MODEL. S. FIRST TIME
THAT THIS ADMINISTRATION HAS
FORMALLY PROPOSED- A
REALIGNMENT TO THE COUNTY AS
WELL AS IN THE MAYOR AND
UNDERLINE CIRCUMSTANCES AT THE
TIME WERE SORT OF WE WERE IN
THE PANDEMIC IN ONE TIME SIR
DEALING WITH THE FINANCIAL.
OUTCOMES OF THAT- AND IT AND IT
SORT OF JUST MADE US LOOK AT
OUR JUVENILE SYSTEM AND THINK
ABOUT IT ARE WE USING OUR
RESOURCES IN THE MOST EFFICIENT
WAY- THERE AROUND EIGHT EIGHT
HUNDRED USE CURRENTLY IN DJJ-
MANY THERE ARE MANY LOCAL
FACILITIES THAT ARE AVAILABLE
TODAY THAT AREN'T BEING
UTILIZED- AND- COUPLE THAT WITH
THE SUCCESS THAT. TOOK PLACE-
IN THE PAST UNDER SIMILAR
REALIGNMENTS. THEY CAME DOWN TO
A SORT OF YOU KNOW. OUR IS IT
BEST POSITIONED MOVING THIS
OVER TO HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICE AT THE STATE LEVEL OR
SHOULD WE SHOULD BE THINKING
ABOUT THIS AND A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT LANDS- LET'S BE
AFFECTED WITH YOU AND ARE
FINDING AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
ALLOWING THEM TO KEEP THEM
CLOSE TO THE FAMILIES.
COMMUNITIES ALLOW THAT SORT OF
LOCAL SORT OF- DID YOU KNOW.
DEVELOPMENT AND RANCH PLAN AN
OLD STUFF THAT TAKE THERE
THAT'S MORE DIFFICULT TO DO IT
OF STATE BUT STILL AND BE
BENEFICIAL- SO I THINK I SAID
THAT WAS THE OVER RIDING
DECISION. SORT OF AT THE TIME
INCLUDING THE NEIGHBORING SO IT
IS I MEAN AND I THINK THAT'S
WHY SAID THAT WE SORT OF THE
CREE. FACTOR THAT PUSHED TO DO
A RIGHT. RIGHT NOW. AND SO I IT
JUST HAD BEEN BUILT FIRST ALONG
TIME AS THE L. A. O. PLAN OUT
AND IT WAS WE ACTUALLY AT THE
END OF BROWN ADMINISTRATION WAS
PROPOSED IN TWELVE THIRTEEN SO
THIS IS- HI. IT'S ALWAYS BEEN
PART OF THE DISK BUT I THINK
THAT IMPETUS WAS SORT OF.
FISCAL AND DYNAMIC- ACTORS BUT
CERTAINLY CERTAINLY HAS A LOT
OF. GREAT POLICY ANGLES WHICH I
THINK MAKES SENSE WHY WE THINK
IT'S SUCH A GOOD PROPOSAL.
PERFECT ON THAT. I'M SO I
APPRECIATE YOUR EXPLANATION OF
THE MOVE TO. TO HAVING IT
MINISTERED ON WHY DON'T KNOW IF
IT MINISTERS RIGHT WAY BUT
BASICALLY THE YOUTH BEING.
HANDLED ON THE COUNTY LEVEL BUT-
COULDN'T THAT STILL BE ACHIEVED.
S. IS PROPOSED IN THIS OTHER
MODEL THROUGH HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES SO STILL HAVING
REALIGNMENT STILL GOING TO
COUNTIES BUT HAVING IT ERA THE
OVERSIGHT AND THE- GUIDANCE
AND- GUIDELINES FOR IT BEING
ADMINISTERED THROUGH A HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES SO THAT'S
REALLY QUESTION RESCUES WHY DID
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL MOVE
FROM THAT BECAUSE IT COULD
CONCEIVABLY AS IS PROPOSED IN
THIS ALTERNATIVE YOU COULD
STILL HAVE A REALIGNMENT AS THE
AS YOU JUST EXPLAINED. YOU CAN
STILL ACHIEVE THAT A CLOSURE OF
THE STATE FACILITIES AND
PROVISION OF THE YOUTH BEING
HANDLED ON THE COUNTY LEVEL BUT
STILL STILL THROUGH A HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES MODEL SO IF
YOU COULD ADDRESS THAT SPECIFIC
OF WHY THE- GOVERNOR MOVED AWAY
FROM THAT. WELL I THINK THERE'S
A COUPLE OF FACTORS HERE IS
THAT ONE I THINK THEY
DEMONSTRATED TRACK RECORD OF
TOWNIES- PERFORMANCE AS I'VE
ALREADY DESCRIBED AS SORT OF. A
LOUD MOST OF US TO FEEL
COMFORTABLE THAT THEY THAT THEY
HAVE THE ABILITY TO DO THIS-
WITH THIS POPULATION- TOO I
THINK THERE'S ARE. MANY AND THE
ADDITIONAL LEGISLATIVE
PROPOSALS THAT HAVE BEEN ADDED
ARE MUCH MORE BROAD BASED THIS
THAT. SORT OF TRANSFER
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THESE EIGHT
HUNDRED MAYBE THE HIGHEST NEED
YOUTH IN THE STATE IS GOING TO
BE A DIFFICULT ENDEAVOR A BY
ITSELF. AND SO SORT OF
EXPANDING ON MAKING ADDITIONAL
CHANGES TO OVERSIGHT AND OTHER
POLICY REFORMS IN ADDITION TO
THAT SEEMS TO MAYBE PUT THE
PROPOSAL ACTOR AT RISK- AND SO
OUR FOCUS HAS BEEN REALLY SORT
OF ON. WHAT IS NECESSARY TO
REALIGN THIS USED TO THE COUNTY
IS AND HAVE THEM BE SUCCESSFUL
THE POPULATION HAS A
DEMONSTRATED OVER. THE LAST TEN
OR FIFTEEN YEARS SO I THINK
THAT SIR THAT THE FOCUS HERE OF
TRYING TO KEEP OURSELVES FOCUS
ON THE REALIGNMENT CELLS- AND
TRYING NOT IN TRYING TO MAKE
SURE THAT SUCCESSFUL. VERSUS
MAKING FURTHER BROAD BASED
POLICY CHANGES AND YOU KNOW
WHAT MOVING OVERSIGHT ENTIRELY
DIFFERENT ENTITY OR SOMETHING
TO THAT AND. AND TO THAT EFFECT.
I'M THANK YOU. I AM RECIPIENTS
I THINK THAT THE THAT THE
OBJECTIVES THAT YOU DESCRIBED
CAN BE ACHIEVED IN TERMS OF
THAT FIVE. THE ROLE OF THE
COUNTIES STILL UNDER A UNDER AS
DOCTOR ROSS EXPRESSED WITH THE
WITH THE BENEFIT OF THE
EXPERTISE IN YOUTH HEALTH AND
WELLNESS SO I THINK THAT THE
LEGISLATURE'S ALTERNATIVE DOES
IT HAVE A GOOD JOB OF ACHIEVING.
YOU KNOW WE WERE WE WERE THROWN
AND I DON'T MEAN THROW THAT
OKAY WE WERE GIVEN SOMETHING AT
THE MAY REVISED TO SWITCH FROM
LAST YEAR AND IN THIS SHORT
TIME IN TRYING TO RESPECT A
DESIRE TO GO WITH THE
REALIGNMENT MODEL STILL TRYING
TO REACH. THAT PRINCIPLE THAT
WE AGREED WITH FROM THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL LAST YEAR
OF GOING THROUGH THE HEALTH AND
WELLNESS LENS SO I THINK THE
LEGISLATURE'S PROPOSAL HAS
GREAT BENEFIT FROM THAT
PERSPECTIVE THANK YOU SENATOR
LEYVA. THANK YOU MADAM BUDGET
SHARE- I JUST WANT TO THINK OF
DOCTOR ROSS AND MR USMAN- ONE
FOR THEIR PRESENTATIONS AND TO
FOR YOUR DEDICATION TO THIS
POPULATION. THESE ARE THE MOST
VULNERABLE PEOPLE IN SOCIETY
TODAY AND I THINK THAT MR
GOODMAN WHAT YOU SAID THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND THE LATE
LEGISLATURE NEEDS TO GET THIS
RIGHT. COULD NOT BE MORE TRUE
THESE PEOPLE NEED US AND THE L.
A. O. WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT THIS
PROPOSAL- CREATING MORE
ACCOUNTABILITY I THINK THAT'S
GREAT. BECAUSE WE CANNOT LET
THIS BE A GROUP OF INDIVIDUALS
THAT IS FOR GOTTEN THEY NEED
MORE RESOURCES THEY NEED MORE
ACCESS. I KNOW THE PART OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PLAN AND EVEN PART
OF THE LEGISLATURE'S PLAN. PUTS
THESE YOUNG PEOPLE CLOSER TO
THEIR FAMILIES BUT I THINK THAT
WE JUST CAN'T EVER FORGET THAT
SOMETIMES A FAMILY IS A
PROBLEM- WE ALL LEARN WHAT WE
LIVE FOR BETTER OR FOR WORSE
AND MANY TIMES THESE YOUNG
PEOPLE. ARE BROUGHT UP IN A
SITUATION THAT. MAKES THEM WHO
THEY ARE AND SOMETIMES PUTTING
THEM BACK IN THE FAMILY
SITUATION IS ONLY GOING TO MAKE
THE SITUATION WORSE. SO I
THINK- DOCTOR ROSS AND EXCUSE
ME AGAIN FOR YOUR DEDICATION
AND- WE DO HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO GET THIS
RIGHT BECAUSE THESE YOUNG
PEOPLE ARE COUNTING ON US THANK
YOU ADVENTURE. THANK YOU
SENATOR BILL. THANK YOU
EVERYBODY I WANTED TO SPEAK-
AFTER SIX YEARS OF BUDGET SUB
FIVE WORKING ON AUG JUVENILE
JUSTICE. ISSUES AND GIVE MY
PERSPECTIVE OF THE DIRECTION
THAT WE NEED TO GO AND ON THIS
ISSUE I'M JUST GOING TO ASK
THAT YOU BE BRIEF SENATOR BILL
WE'VE GOT A TIGHT TIME FRAME
THANK YOU. YEAH I WILL BE. THE
FIRST THING I THINK WE NEED TO
DO TO ADD TO THIS IS THE WE
HAVE TO HAVE THE ASUS- ADVERSE
CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCES-
SCREENING MANDATE THAT IS
RECOMMENDED BY. DR NADINE BURKE
HARRIS AND HER- WORK THAT SHE'S
DONE AND THE BABY HUNDRED
POINTS CLINICS. AND FINDING OUT
OF THE SUCCESS OF LOOKING AT-
CHILDREN'S HEALTH. FROM A
PERSPECTIVE OF- TRAUMA THAT
OCCURRED THE SECOND THING I
THINK WE NEED TO DO IS INCLUDE
WRAPAROUND- FULL SERVICE
PARTNERSHIPS. FOR ALL OUT REACH
OUT TO. AT RESCUES- WE ALSO ARE
HAVE A UNDERSTANDING OF THE
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION'S OR
THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS- SCHOOLS
FOR JUVENILE OFFENDERS- AND THE
SPECIAL EDUCATION PROGRAM NEEDS
OF THOSE STUDENTS I SUPPORT. OF
THE SMALL THERAPEUTIC-
FACILITIES- IS SPEND STARTED
ALL OVER THE COUNTRY THE
MISSOURI MODEL HAS BEEN- PROVEN
IN MANY STATES TO BE MORE
ACCEPTABLE THOSE FACILITIES ARE
SMALLER THERAPEUTIC FACILITIES
I THINK THE DIRECTION WE HAVE
NEEDS TO GO IN THAT DIECTION
IS THE HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICE
MODELS OF MENTAL HEALTH MODEL
YOU CAN TREAT DRUG ABUSE AND%
NOT TREATMENT. AND I JUST WANT
TO THANK EVERYBODY FOR MY
OPPORTUNITY TO SERVE ON- BUDGET
SUB COMMITTEE FOR THE LAST SIX
YEARS- AND I HOPE THAT THESE
ARE INCLUDED THIS PUT NEED
DOESN'T WERE IT SHOULD GOING
THE DIRECTION OF THE
LEGISLATIVE PROPOSAL WE NEED TO
WORK ON IT MORE AND FILL IN THE
GAPS ON EARLY INTERVENTION
TREATMENT THAT WILL BE FUNDED-
WHERE'S FEDERAL MATTER MEDICAID
FUNDS- PISD CHIEF FUNDS. THOSE
FUNDS ARE MATCH WHEN THEY'RE IN
IN FACILITIES WERE NOT ALLOWED
TO USE THOSE FUNDS SO OUR STATE
FACILITIES CHARGE- THE COST OF
THE STATE FACILITIES ARE THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
YEAR- THE AVERAGE COST OF THE
STATE COUNTY JUVENILE FACILITY
IS IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD OF A
HUNDRED SIXTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
PER YEAR- WE NEED WE NEED TO
GET A JOB THAT MONEY IS BETTER
AND MORE WISELY- I THINK THE
DIRECTION OF. THE LEGISLATIVE
PROPOSAL- NEEDS TO BE INSISTED
UPON AND I AGREE SENATOR
SCANNERS COMMENTS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR. BILL CENTER DORADO.
THANK MAN TO YOU. OF ALL DAY
PICKED THE PANELISTS AND ASK
THEM THIS QUESTION IF TO FIGHT
MEANT AND MS GASKINS. IF YOU
COULD SAY IN A VERY SHORT WAY.
OF WHICH OPTION YOU ARE
ADVOCATING FOR. AND GIVE ME ONE
OR TWO COMPELLING REASONS AS TO
WHY IT HAS TO BE THAT WHAT
NEEDS TO BE OR SHOULD BE THAT
OPTION. Q. FIVE WE WILL START
WITH YOU. THANK YOU- WELL I
REALLY DON'T FEEL LIKE WE'RE IN
A POSITION TO CHOOSE ONE OR THE
OTHER OPTION I THINK THAT WE
HAVE TO KEEP IN MIND THAT- THE
JUVENILE PROBATION DEPARTMENTS
ARE NOT SOLELY A CORRECTIONS
MODEL AWARENESS NOT SOLELY AND
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES MODEL
WE ARE VERY UNIQUE CAN WE
LEVERAGE OUR BOTH OF THOSE- AS
SIDES OF THE EXPERTISE. AND
PUTS US IN A UNIQUE POSITION
BUT- WE WILL NEED WITH THE
RESOURCES TO MAKE THIS A
SUCCESSFUL TRANSITION AND I
CAN'T REITERATE ENOUGH- THAT WE
AGREE THIS IS A SOMETHING THAT
WE HAVE TO GET RIGHT- THAT WE
HAVE TO LOOK AT IT FROM THE
LANDS OF WHAT IS BEST FOR THE
USE. AND ASKED THAT QUESTION
REPEATEDLY THAT A BUILDING ANY
ANY ADDITIONAL CHANGES THAT
IMPACT THE LARGER SYSTEMATIC
TIME WHEN WE'RE TRYING TO
REALIGN THIS COMPLEX OUR
POPULATION- COULD JEOPARDIZE
THE IMPORTANT WORK THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO HERE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ON IN SENATOR
ALTHOUGH I THINK THE CDF IS
MOST CONCERNED THAT THIS
PROCESS IS CENTERED AROUND THE
CURRENT AND LONG TERM WELL
BEING OF YOU AND WHAT WE'VE
LEARNED IS THAT IMPLEMENTATION
OF ANY CHANGES MUST INCLUDE
COMMUNITY INPUT AND OVERSIGHT
THAT'S FOCUSED ON HEALTH AND
THE WELL BEING OF USED TO BE
DONE SUCCESSFULLY AND SO I
THINK THAT IS THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING THAT WE WANT TO
SEE HAPPEN AND WE KNOW THAT WE
WILL CONTINUE. TO USE A GREAT
MINDS THAT ARE HERE TO GET THAT
DONE THANK YOU. DURAZO SENATOR
MINING. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I
WANT TO THANK ALL THE PANEL
MEMBERS SIN. ADMINISTRATION
CONTRIBUTIONS I DO WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE GOVERNOR'S
COMMITMENT TO THIS I THINK OUR
CHALLENGE IS GETTING IT RIGHT.
I THINK THE BROAD OBJECTIVE IS
DECRIMINALIZATION LOOKING TO
CAUSES TREATMENT AND
EMPOWERMENT OF YOUTH I HAD SOME
QUESTIONS BUT IN THE INTEREST
OF TIME I THINK I'LL JUST OFFER
A COUPLE OF MORE OBSERVATIONS-
I AGREE WITH SENATOR BELL'S
COMMENTS ALSO SENATOR LEYVA.
THAT FAMILIES OFTEN THE SOURCE
OF TRAUMA. AND NEEDS TO BE
EITHER INCLUDED OR IDENTIFIED
AS TO WHAT IS BEST FOR THAT AT
RISK YOUTH I THINK ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES I KNOW WE FACE IN
THE COMMUNITIES I REPRESENT. IS
INSUFFICIENT NUMBER OF TRAINED
PSYCHIATRISTS- CULTURALLY
SENSITIVE. PSYCHIATRISTS
PSYCHOLOGISTS THERAPISTS. AND I
THINK WE SHOULD PARTNER ON THIS
INITIATIVE WITH EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTIONS TO FURTHER
INCENTIVIZE YOUNG PEOPLE
PURSUING TRAINING. TO SUPPORT
THEIR COMMUNITIES AS
PROFESSIONALS WHO MIGHT BE BI
LINGUAL MULTI LINGUAL- OR
CULTURALLY SENSE IT ALONG WITH
THAT WOULD BE PEER SUPPORT- IN
THE THERAPY MODALTIES- I WOULD
NOT I'M ALSO GLAD TO SEE THAT
BOTH PROPOSALS. SUPPORT NOT
MAINTAINING THE PINE GROVE
YOUTH CONSERVATION CAMP. I
WOULD ALSO THINK WE MIGHT WANNA
LOOK AT PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION CORPS
AS WELL AS A POSSIBLE PATHWAY
FOR SOME USED TO WORK WITH
OTHER YOUNG PEOPLE UNDER
APPROPRIATE SUPERVISION- TO
DEVELOP SKILLS AND CAREER
PATHWAYS SO MORE A COMMENTARY
MADAM CHAIR THAN THAN A
QUESTION. BUT I DO THINK. THE
ISSUE OF RESOURCES IF WE ARE
GOING TO INVEST IN SOME OF THE
TRAUMA IDENTIFICATION AND
TREATMENT AS SENATOR BELL
IDENTIFIED THE ACES RESEARCH
AND WORK AND SUCCESSES. THE
FUNDING NEEDS TO ALSO BE
SUFFICIENT. TO INVOLVE THOSE
PROFESSIONALS WHO CAN PROVIDE
SUPPORT. TO THE AT RISK YOUTH
SO AGAIN THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH US IN AMMAN IN
APPRECIATED TWO QUICK QUESTIONS
FOR DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IF
YOU COULD TELL US I THINK I
HEARD SOMEONE EARLIER SAID THAT
THE CURRENT- POPULATION DJJ WAS
EIGHT HUNDRED BUT I WANTED TO
CONFIRM THAT AND SECOND WHAT'S
THE CURRENT OPERATING
EXPENDITURES FOR DJJ. AS OF
LAST WEEK AS THE POPULATION WAS
AT SEVEN HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE
AND THE TOTAL BUDGET IS A
LITTLE OVER TWO HUNDRED AND
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS. THANK
YOU I THINK THAT AGAIN THIS IS
WE WILL CONTINUE TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS AROUND OVERSIGHT
NOT A BET AND ACCOUNTABILITY
IT'S GOING TO BE IMPORTANT THAT
WE- ARE CLEAR ABOUT DATA
REPORTING OUTCOME METRICS
ASSOCIATED. WITH THE FUNDING IN
EACH PROPOSAL- AS WELL AS. OUR
BEST A GAS AND PER ARE PAUL OUT
XP. BOMB OF THE YOUNG PEOPLE-
WHO HAVE BEEN- A REFER TO
DEPARTMENT OF JUVENILE JUSTICE
WELL THIS IS THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE CAME TO A BUDGET
PROPOSAL WE ARE ASKING THE
FINANCE QUESTIONS BUT THAT
SHOULDN'T BE. INTERPRETED AS-
OUR DESIRE TO SAVE MONEY AT
THEIR EXPENSE THIRTY NIELSEN
YOU A QUESTION. YES I DO MADAM
CHAIR OBSERVATION. QUESTION THE
THERE'S A GIRL THERE WAS A WELL
TALENTED REORGANIZATION OF THE
AGENCIES OF GOVERNMENT. THIS
CALL BLOW UP THE BOXES. TO MY-
THE KNOWLEDGE THE ONLY BOX THAT
REALLY GOT BLOWN UP WAS A
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION. AT THE TIME
THAT AGENCY IT WAS TOP LIGHT
AND BOTTOM HEAVY MEANING THEY
DID NOT HAVE ENOUGH THE
MANAGERIAL. STAFF THE
GOVERNMENT CONTROLLED. INDIRECT
THIS THAT I THINK AROUND FIVE
BILLION DOLLAR. ORGANIZATION
THE PRODUCT OF THAT WAS THEN AN
ORGANIZATION THAT BECAME BOTH
TOP HEAVY AND BOTTOM HEAVY.
NOTHING MUCH CHANGE. NOW THIS
IS AN AREA WHERE THERE MAY WELL
BE SOME HOPE JUST YESTERDAY I
TALKED TO CHIEF PROBATION
OFFICER CEO OF SACRAMENTO
COUNTY. AND BASED ON PRIOR
EXPERIENCE I'VE BEEN WARY ABOUT
THIS. CHANGE PROPOSED THE
EGGMAN OF JUVENILE OFFENDERS
NOW BEING REMANDED TO THE
COUNTIES. THE HIS REMARKS DID
COMFORT ME SOME. BOB HI THE
HIGHEST IMPORTANCE IN THIS
SHOULD BE DIRECTED TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THE
REALIGNMENT. WILL ONLY WORK IF
RESOURCES FOLLOW. CALORIES DO
NOT AND WILL NOT IN THE
FORESEEABLE FUTURE HAVE MANY
RESOURCES IN FACT THEY'RE IN
DIRE STRAITS RIGHT NOW. THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WILL
THERE BE IS THERE A PLAN FOR
SOME LONG TIME A LONG LONG TERM
SUSTAINING OF FUNDING TO HELP
THIS TRANSITION OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUVENILE JUSTICE
TO THE AUTHORITY OF COUNTY
PROBATION. YES PROPOSAL
INCLUDES- TWO HUNDRED TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS HER USE-
PER YEAR AND SO WE GET TO FULL
IMPLEMENTATION INCLUDES A TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLAR
MINIMUM. FOR COUNTIES AND IN
TOTAL UPON FULL IMPLEMENTATION
WEEKS THOSE TO BE. TO BE OVER
TWO HUNDRED AND TWELVE MILLION
DOLLARS- AND IN TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY FIVE. ALLOWS FOR SOME
GROSS TO THAT FUNDING- AND JUST
FOR NOTED THAT HE HAD A
SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER THAN OUR
ORIGINAL NAY REVISION PROPOSAL-
WHICH IS CONTEMPLATED ON SORT
OF. BEING ABLE TO ADD PEOPLE ON
THE MARGINS MAYBE YOU KNOW LESS
COSTLY BUT AFTER HAVING
DISCUSSION WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS AND HAS BEEN
DISCUSSED TODAY- IT'S A HIGH
NEED POPULATION WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT. COUNTY IS OUR
RESOURCE PROPERLY TO BE ABLE TO
TAKE THEM ON SO- I REVISED
PROPOSAL REFLECTS THAT- AND WE
DO THINK. IT'S SHOULD BE
SUFFICIENT. I'M GLAD THAT ON
YOUR AND WILL BE FOR OUR BUDGET
COMMITTEE BE VERY CLOSELY
SCRUTINIZING THIS TRANSITION.
NOW YESTERDAY I HAD A NICE
CONVERSATION WITH THE- CHIEF
PROBATION OFFICER SERIAL. AND
AGAIN AS I SAY HE COMFORTED ME
SOME ABOUT THEIR PLANS FOR THIS
TRANSITION. I DID NOT ASK THIS
QUESTION KNOWN MAYBE THIS WOULD
BE FOR CHIEF HEIGHTENED. WHAT
WAS LEFT THEN IN THE JUVENILE
FACILITIES OF THE STATE WORDS
OF THE MORE DIFFICULT. WARDS
THE ONES WHO WERE BEHAVIORAL
PROBLEMS. IN CUSTODY IN OUT OF
CUSTODY. THIS IS A MORE
DIFFICULT POPULATION HOW ARE
YOU ARE YOU ANTICIPATING
DIFFERENT STRATEGIES TO DEAL
WITH THIS MORE OR LESS AMENABLE.
POPULATION AS A NOW COME INTO
YOUR AUTHORITIES IN THE
COUNTIES. THANK YOU SENATOR FOR
THAT QUESTION- YES YOU ARE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT THESE ARE THE
HIGHEST NEED- A USE WITHIN OUR
SYSTEM WITH SOME VERY COMPLEX
NEEDS AND WE'VE ALREADY BEGUN
DISCUSSIONS- MONTHS- THE
DIVERSE COUNTIES WITH OUR
COLLABORATIVE PARTNERS I'VE
BEEN SPEAKING WITH OUR- COUNTY
EDGED EDUCATE OUR COUNTY
DIRECTOR OF EDUCATION ARE-
MIDDLE HEALTH DIRECTOR WHO SETS
ON OUR JUVENILE JUSTICE
DISCORDANT IN COUNCIL- AS WELL
AS ALL OF THE OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS IN THE COMMUNITY
THAT PARTICIPATE. AND HAVE A
VOICE IN OUR LOCAL SYSTEM AND
I'M SURE THAT'S GOING TO BE
TRUE FOR EACH- CHIEF PROBATION
OFFICER THAT THEY WILL NEED TO
WORK WITH A WIDE VARIETY OF
STAKEHOLDERS COMMUNITY PARTNERS
GOVERNMENT PARTNERS HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES I HAVE TO PUT
TOGETHER THE ALL OF THE
RESEARCH ALL OF THE DATA. THAT
WE HAVE AVAILABLE TO US
ARTISTIC DEMONSTRATES HOW WE
CAN BEST SERVE THESE
INDIVIDUALS AND WE KNOW THAT
SOME OF THEM HAVE A VERY HIGH
MEDICAL NEEDS AND WE HAVE SOME
WITH US SEXUAL. BEHAVIORS THAT
ARE GOING TO HAVE TO BE
ADDRESSED SO WE MAY NEED TO
USE- SOME. ALL CONTRACTING
MONTHS WITH VARIOUS. FOR
BERRIES. NEEDS WHERE'S OTHER
USE WILL BE ABLE TO SPEAK
SERVED- IN THEIR THEIR LOOK
LOCAL A COMMUNITY WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE TO LOOK AT. WHAT IS
AVAILABLE IN EACH COMMUNITY
WHAT THEY'VE SHOWN TO BE HAVE
THEIR STRENGTHS WITHIN AND WHAT
COMMUNITY RESOURCES AND
PARTNERSHIPS THAT THEY CAN
LEVERAGE BUT THIS IS NOT A NEW-
SITUATION FOR US THIS IS. THE
TYPE OF A COLLABORATION THAT
HAS SERVED US WELL IN THE PAST
AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO I
REALLY HAVE TO LEAN ON AND
LEVERAGE ALL OF THOSE
PARTNERSHIPS. THANK YOU FOR
THAT THE LITTLE WHILE AGO MY
COLLEAGUE FROM BERKELEY.
OBSERVE SOMETHING THAT REALLY
TUGS AT MY HEARTSTRINGS. I
FOUND THAT THE COMMONALITY AND
MOST CRIMINAL OFFENDERS. IS
PLUGS ALCOHOL. BUT ALSO A
TOUGHER ONE TO DEAL WITH WHAT I
CALL THE BROKEN HEART. THIS IS
PARTICULARLY SO FOR OUR
YOUTHFUL OFFENDERS. IT WAS A
FAMILY THAT DIDN'T WORK THEY
DIDN'T GET NURTURED THEY DID
NOT GET LOVED SUPPORTED. THIS
TIME THIS BROKEN HEART BEGINS
IN THE WOMB. TEN YEARS AGO ASK
COULD BAND DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT. TO RECITE SOME OF
THE REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS
WHICH- HE PROCEEDED TO DO. I
THEN INQUIRED WILL WHAT DO YOU
HAVE. TO HELP WITH THE BROKEN
HEART. IT WAS VERY DISTURBING
BECAUSE THE BLACK LOOK THAT
I'VE BEEN RECEIVED TOLD ME ALL
I NEEDED NO THEY WEREN'T REALLY
LOOKING AT THE BROKEN HEART. IS
THAT AN AREA THAT YOU FEEL HAVE.
HE FIRED SOMEONE THAT YOU CAN.
BEEF UP OR DO ADDITIONAL WORK
WITH THAT BROKEN HEART AND THAT
USE THAT NEVER EVEN HAD A
CHANCE. ABSOLUTELY AND I
APPRECIATE YOU MENTIONING SHE
CO I HAVE GREAT RESPECT FOR THE
WORK THAT HE DOES- WITHIN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND- FEEL
THAT HE IS A LEADER IN THIS
AREA AND I KNOW HE TOO IS
LOOKING AT THE AREA- TRAUMA
INFORMED CARE AND WE- HAVE.
GROWN BY LEAPS AND BOUNDS- IN
OUR UNDERSTANDING OF THE
SIGNIFICANCE OF EMBEDDING ON
TRAUMA INFORMED CARE THROUGHOUT
OUR OUR WORK WHETHER IT'S
DIVERSION AND PREVENTION AS
WELL AS THOSE USE THAT ARE IN
DETENTION- I AM VERY PASSIONATE
ABOUT. THE WORK THAT WE'RE
DOING WITH THE USE LOCALLY AND
I KNOW OTHER CHIEFS FEEL THE
SAME. THE EFFORTS THAT WE'RE
MAKING TO ESTABLISH MEANINGFUL
RELATIONSHIPS WHICH EACH WITH
EACH OF THE YEARS AND HELPED
THEM- REALLY COME INTO
THEMSELVES AND HAVE A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF THEIR
STRENGTHS AND WHO THEY ARE AS
AN INDIVIDUAL AND BE ABLE TO
BUILD WITH EDUCATIONAL
RESOURCES AS WELL AS AS- MENTAL
HEALTH AND COUNSELING
RESOURCES. TO HELP THEM BE THE
BEST PERSON AND THEY CAN BE- WE
CAN ONLY DO THAT WELL WITH
PROPER RESOURCES AND BY
LEVERAGING JEAN ALL OF THE
DIFFERENT- SCIENCE AND RESEARCH
THAT HAS BEEN ESTABLISHED. AND
I DEFINITELY BELIEVE THAT THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT WE HAVE TO DO
WE NEED TO DO IT FOR EACH YEAR.
AND WE NEED TO LEAVE LOOK AT
EACH USER INDIVIDUALLY AND
CREATE AN INDIVIDUALIZED PLAN
FOR THEM. VERY GOOD. OF WOULD
THAT BE LIKE AN I EP IS THAT
WHAT YOU'RE CONTEMPLATING FOR
OR MAYBE YOU ALREADY HAVE THAT.
APPLICABLE FOR. I'M SORRY
RENDERED EDUCATION PLAN OR
INDIVIDUAL REVILLA KATIE PLANS
IS THE U. DRAFT THOSE FOR EACH
WARD. ABSOLUTELY AND FOR THOSE
USE THAT HAVE NOT YET
COMPLETED- THEIR HIGH SCHOOL
EDUCATION WE WORK VERY CLOSELY
WITH OUR COUNTY EDUCATION
DEPARTMENT- AND ADDS A
TREMENDOUS SPECIAL ED RESOURCES
WITHIN OUR FACILITY- BUT
INTENTIONALLY FOR THE
POPULATION THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT AND MANY OF THEM ON OUR
ON THE OLDER END OF THE
POPULATION THAT WE WORK WITH.
SO WE WILL NEED TO GO BEYOND
THAT EDUCATIONAL PLAN FOR THEIR
HIGH SCHOOL BUT WE WOULD WE
WOULD BE LOOKING TOO LITTLE-
WHAT SECONDARY- OPTIONS ARE
THERE ARE THEY SOMEONE THAT- WE
CAN GET INVOLVED AND- PURSUING-
EDUCATION THROUGH A LOCAL
COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND A
UNIVERSITY OF OCCASIONAL-
PROGRAM AND THAT PART OF THE
WORK REALLY TAPS INTO GETTING
TO KNOW THAT USE UNDERSTANDING
WHAT THEIR- THEIR STRENGTHS ARE
WHAT BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY WHAT
THEIR AREA OF. INTEREST ARE AND
WHERE WE CAN TAP INTO THEIR
PASSION AND CONNECT THEM TO THE
RESOURCES THAT ALLOWS THEM- TO
SEE A BETTER FUTURE FOR
THEMSELVES RIGHT NOW WE HAVE
USED OUR FACILITY THAT ARE
WORKING ONLINE I'M TOWARDS
THEIR COLLEGE EDUCATIONS BUT WE
ALSO HAVE YOU THAT ARE
EXPLORING- THEY'RE STILL IN
THAT EXPLORATION PHASE THAT ARE
I'M TRYING OUT A VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT THINGS- TO. ESTABLISH
THEIR PATH FORWARD AND THE
INDIVIDUALIZED PLAN NEEDS TO
BEING NOT ONLY FOR THEIR
EDUCATION- BUT A TOTAL
INDIVIDUALIZED PLAN FOR THEIR
FOR THEIR TREATMENT- FOR WHAT
THEIR PLANS ARE- AS WE MOVE
TOWARDS- FREE ENTRY INTO THE
COMMUNITY- WHERE THEY'RE GOING
TO RESIDE MANY OF THEM WILL BE-
PERHAPS- MOVING INTO MORE
INDEPENDENT LIVING- RATHER THAN
RETURNING TO THEIR HOME
ENVIRONMENTS SO THERE ARE MANY
SKILLS. AND OPERA TRINITY'S TO
REALLY AND THERE UNDER. OF WHAT
THE ACHIEVE. DURING THAT WITH
THEIR WITH US AND TO WORK WITH
OUR COMMUNITY PARTNERS ON
MENTORING AND GETTING OTHER OF
POSITIVES ARE WALL MODELS
INVOLVED IN THEIR LIVES. ALL
WHILE THEY'RE WITH US THANK YOU
IN THAT IT ENABLES AND WE NEED
TO WRAP IT UP BECAUSE I GOT TO
GET THE PUBLIC COMMENT SEARCHED
LET'S WRAP IT UP FOR THAT THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
APPRECIATED DR PANDA HERE MIKE
UP. YES ADJUSTED VERY BRIEFLY
I'VE JUST ALL I WANT THANK-
CENTER SKINNER AND- SUB FIVE
FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS ISSUE OF
SHARES SUB THREE LOOKING
FORWARD TO THE OVERSIZE IT AS
THE- DJJ WE MOVE IT OVER TO- TO
HELP EVEN SERVICES AND
CERTAINLY VERY POOR WE DO THIS
RIGHT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR ALSO THANK YOU JUST
QUICKLY- LESS THAN A YEAR AGO I
HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO VISIT
THE- JUVENILE JUSTICE. OF
FACILITY AND- DEFINITELY ONE OF
THE MOST HEARTBREAKING TIMES OF
MY LIFE TO TALK TO YOUNG WOMEN
AND YOUNG MEN WHO. DID NOT FEEL
THAT THEY WERE GETTING. THE
OPPORTUNITY AND THE AND A
PATHWAY TO GET WHERE THEY
WANTED TO BE AS AS HUMAN
BEINGS. I JUST WANNA SAY THE
LEGISLATIVE PROPOSAL UP. SEEMS
TO ABSORB A LOT OF HISTORY AND
EXPERIENCE AND- INVOLVEMENT BY
COMMUNITY AND ADVOCATES SUCH AS
THE ONES ON THE PANEL TODAY.
AND I THINK THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL FALLS VERY VERY SHORT
OF THE THOUGHTFULNESS THAT.
THESE YOUNG MEN AND WOMEN
DESERVE TO HAVE AS FAR AS THEIR
OPPORTUNITIES. IN LIFE THANK
YOU. I HAVE. THAT AND WITH THE
COLOR ARE GOING TO IT UP POP
COM. REMEMBER IN ALL THE WE
HAVE A HARD STOP AT TWELVE
THIRTY SO WE CAN BREAK FOR THE
CHAMBERS TO BE A CLEAN TO FOR
US TO RECONVENE AT ONE THIRTY.
LET ME FIND MY PLACE ON THE
SCRIPT. SO WITH ALL THE
SCHEDULING DEBATE HAVING ENDED
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO ANYONE
WANTING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT ON EITHER ISSUE HEARD
THIS MORNING EITHER CALL THAT
NINETEEN RELATED SPENDING OR
THE CULTURE OF DJJ. DUE TO
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS IN CLEANING
PROTOCOLS COMMITTEE CHAIRS MAKE
INTO TO THE LIMIT ON TESTIMONY.
TODAY I'M GOING TO ASK EACH
MEMBER THE PUBLIC COMMENT. TO
LIMIT THEIR COMMENTS TWO ONE
MINUTE PLEASE LET'S BEGIN WITH
ANY WITNESSES HERE IN THE
GALLERY. I SEE NONE OF THE ANY
WITNESSES IN HEARING ROOM ONE
TWELVE. THE HEARING ROOM
APPEARS TO BE EMPTY WITH THAT
ARE WILL MOVE TO WITH THIS IS
WAITING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT VIA THE TELECONFERENCE
RAIDER. IF YOU PLEASE PROP THE
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT FOR COVERT
NINETEEN SPENDING OR DJJ WILL
BEGIN. MODERATOR. YES HEAR YOU
NOW OKAY LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU HAVE A COMMENT PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR TOUCH TONE
PHONE. AN INDICATION THAT
YOU'VE BEEN PLACED INTO THE
QUEUE AND MAY REMOVE YOURSELF
FROM THE QUEUE BY REPEATING THE
ONE THEN ZERO COMMAND. IF
YOU'RE USING A SPEAKER PHONE
PLEASE PICK UP YOUR HANDSET
MAKE CERTAIN YOUR PHONE IS ON
MUTE IT BEFORE PRESSING ANY
BUTTONS FIRST WE'LL GO TO LINE
SIXTY TWO GO AHEAD. ONE SIXTY
TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN GO AHEAD
PLEASE. ACTUALLY GOOD AFTERNOON
EVERYONE CAN MIGUEL FROM THE
YOUTH JUSTICE COALITION AND-
I'M HONORED TO BE HERE TODAY WE
URGE YOU TO CLOSE DJJ THE RIGHT
WAY INCLUDING SUPPORTING THE
PROPOSAL PUT FORTH BY THE STATE
LEGISLATURE WE MUST THINK
OUTSIDE THE CAGE. AND RECOGNIZE
THE VISION FOR A YOUTH JUSTICE
OFFICE WITHIN HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES BUT THE TAX OVERSIGHT
AND ACCOUNTABILITY. WE NEED TO
FOCUS ON DATA COLLECTION
TRANSPARENCY DIVERSION BE
CONSTRUCTION AND ADVANCEMENT
FROM CORRECTIONS TO YOUTH
DEVELOPMENT CALIFORNIA HAS
LEGISLATIVE CAGE FREE CHICKENS
IT'S TIME WE REQUIRE CAGE FREE
CHILDREN YOU. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS MODERATOR.
THIRTY SEVEN. IN THIS MARKET-
I'M LUCKY TECHNICAL I'M
SUPPORTING THE LEGISLATURE-
REALIGNMENT PROPOSAL BECAUSE IT
WILL- PROVIDE A GREATER
OPPORUNITIES FOR COMMUNITY
INPUT AND INVOLVEMENT
INCLUDING- OPPORTUNITIES FOR
SOCIAL SERVICE AGENCIES AND
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
TO RECEIVE FUNDING- INTERVIEW
FOR COMMUNITIES- I THINK THAT-
IN IN ORDER FOR US TO CENTER ON
YOU- HEALTH AND WELLNESS- HE
NEEDS TO. GET THAT HAVE POWER
UTILIZE THREE AND PREVENT
HARMFUL TRANSFER OF USED TO
PUNITIVE DISPENSED THAT- WILL
ONLY FURTHER ENTRENCHED AND
BASIS AND CANNOT PROMOTE YOUTH
DEVELOPMENT. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. NINE FIFTY FIVE. THE
CENTERS ON BEHALF OF THE IDEAL
CALIFORNIA RELYING THAT THE
PRESIDENT PROGRAM THE COUNTY
MUST COME WITH STRINGENT
OVERSIGHT AND ADEQUATE
RESOURCES TO ENSURE THE
PROGRAMS ARE WORKING AND WE
ENVISION AND PREVENT ANY
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES COUNTY
MARKLEEVILLE PROPER AND THE
GOOD IMPORTANT AND EFFECTIVE
WORK CURRENTLY BEING DONE WITH
JUVENILE BY COUNTIES SHOULD BE
THE CORNERSTONE OF THE PROPOSAL
THERE'S A REAL OPPORTUNITY TO
EXPAND ON THE WORK WE'RE
CURRENTLY GOING TO- EXPAND VIA
WRAPAROUND SERVICES BY COUNTY
WORKERS INCLUDING PROBATION
SOCIAL WORKER PUBLIC HEALTH
NURSES. MENTAL AND BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONAL. FOR THE
WORK WEEK DO PARTNER WITH.
THING HOW BASED. WE ARE. THAT
CAN OF THE- WITH A FOCUS ONLY
ON NON RATHER THAN. IN PART
WITH NOT FOR. MAY HAVE ON. AND
POTENTIALLY DELETERIOUS
CONSEQUENCES WITH A- EIGHT
EIGHT EIGHT FIVE ENGAGEMENT AND
INVOLVEMENT OF THE PROPOSAL
HOWEVER WE DO NOT BELIEVE IT
WILL BE EFFECTIVE TO CREATE A
NEW AND STOP WITH THE
PARCHMENT. FINALLY WE WANT TO
ENSURE A GOOD OUTCOME FOR THE
YOUTH WE SERVE BUT ALSO TO
ENSURE THE PROTECTION OF
WORKERS PROVIDING THE SERVICES.
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. LINE SIXTY EIGHT GO
AHEAD. HI GOOD MORNING- THERE
ARE JAPANESE MANAGER THANK YOU
SO MUCH MY ME GO RIGHT YEAH I'M
A POLICY COORDINATOR WITH THE
ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION. WHAT
THE LEGISLATIVE BOCANEGRA
PROPOSAL BECAUSE THE DJJ THE
RIGHT WAY I BELIEVE THAT-
HANDLING AND ALL. BEING USED
SHOULD BE VIEWED THROUGH A-
SERVICE PLAN AND TO ANSWER THE
QUESTION OF THE OTHER SENATOR-
OF THE FORMER USE- MY HEART WAS
CHANGED- WHEN. I WOULD BUY ON
BREAK USE MINE CAME INSIDE AND
TOLD US THAT WE COULD BE AN
ATTORNEY- AND I INTEND- HAVE
PURSUED- THAT PASSION I AM ET
RECITAL NIGHT- AND I AM OPPOSED
TO DOING THAT. RECEIVE HELP
FROM. BASED OR WHAT WHILE I
PROBATE OFFICER. EITHER%
MISTREATED MY FAMILY OR
PROVIDED LITTLE OR NO
OPPORTUNITY FOR ME. AGAIN I
BELIEVE THAT COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS. SENSIBLE HOW WE
NEED YOU AND AFTER BEING- THAT
COMMUNITIES. DENTURE SUPPORT
LEGISLATOR PROPOSAL THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NEXT WITNESS ONE
MINUTE BT. MODERATOR NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. LINE SEVENTY
TWO. I MY NAME MANY MANY OUR
CORE WHICH THANK YOU JESSICA
AND I'M SUPPORT OF THE NATION'S
AGE. I'M I'M IN SUPPORT OF THE
LATE SHARE PROPOSAL ANY SPEAKS-
ME PERSONALLY BECAUSE MY DAD-
STARTED OUT AS THE USED GOING
IN AND OUT OF JAIL AND BECAUSE
WE DON'T HAVE THE SEPARATE
STRUCTURES IN PLACE BEFORE TO
REALLY INVEST IN TAKE CARE OF
YOU MY DAD ENDED UP. HE NEEDS
SIX YEARS IN. HI THE PROPOSALS
ARE YOU THE MAIN MY DAD KICKED
IN. BY THE WAY MOSTLY YOUNG
PEOPLE OF COLOR DARK AND COULD
HAVE BEEN SAVED AND ARE
SUPPORTED. AND THEN HE WOULDN'T
HAVE HAD TO GO TO PRISON FOR
SIXTEEN YEARS- SO THAT IS WHY
DISPOSAL IS VERY IMPORTANT TO
ME THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MODERATOR NEXT WITNESS. MY
SIXTY GO AHEAD. GOOD MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MADAM CHAIR THIS
IS SUPER RALPH FROM THE PACIFIC
JUVENILE DEFENDER CENTER WE
SUPPORT THE ALTERNATIVE BUDGET
TRAILER BILL AND IN PARTICULAR
AS WE MOVE FROM HAVING LUNCH
STATE FACILITY SYSTEM TO HAVING
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTY SYSTEMS IT'S
ESSENTIAL TO HAVE A DEDICATED
STATE LEVEL OVERSIGHT AGENCIES
TO PROVIDE LEADERSHIP SUPPORT
AND ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THE CARE
OF YOUNG PEOPLE. IN RESPONSE TO
SENATOR MORLOCKS QUESTION THE
FUTURE THIS WAS PLANTED LONG
AGO IN THE TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
LITTLE HOOVER REPORT THANK YOU
BILL JUSTICE REFORM THE NUMBER.
ONE RECOMMENDATION BUT IT
SHOULD BE A STATE OF THE STATE
IS JUSTICE AGENCY OUTSIDE THE
CORRECTIONAL SYSTEM THE STATE
AUDITOR HAS REPEATEDLY
EXPRESSED CONCERN ABOUT THE
PERFORMANCE AT THE FCC IN
PROVIDING LEADERSHIP AND
OVERSIGHT OVER STATE GRANT
PROGRAMS AS THE PRIMARY FOCUS
OF THAT AGENCY IS ON ADULT.
CORRECTIONAL ISSUES WHAT THE
CONCEPT OF THE OFFICE IF YOU
JUSTICE AND FINALLY WERE ALSO
CAN THAT THE PROJECT AND- IN
THE L. TRAILER BILL TO PUT AN
INCREASE IN TRANSFERRED TO
ADULT COURT HE PUT FORWARD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS. LANE.
SIXTY SEVEN. NINE SIXTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN GO AHEAD
PLEASE. NEXT WITNESS MODERATOR.
LINE TWENTY SIX. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME IS
MATTHEW EASILY SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
CORRECTIONAL PEACE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION WERE IN OPPOSITION
TO THE DJ REALIGNMENT PROPOSAL
THEN THE CLOSURE OF THE STATE
FACILITIES WEEKLY COUNTY
ASSEMBLY UNPREPARED TO HANDLE
THE FIVE YOU ENTERED CURRENTLY
HOUSED WITHIN THE DJJ
FACILITIES AND WITHIN THE LAST
FIVE TO TEN YEARS DJ MAKE GREAT
STRIDES IN IMPROVEMENT AND THE
RESOLUTION OF THE- FEDERAL
LAWSUIT. THERE ARE A LEVEL OF
SERVICE AND PROGRAMMING THAT
ARE UNMATCHED IN QUALITY AND
DEPTH THROUGHOUT THE DJJ.
CURRENTLY THEY OFFER FULLY
ACCREDITED JUNIOR HIGH AND HIGH
SCHOOL EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS
EXTREMELY SUCCESSFUL SPEC
BEHAVIOR TREATMENT PROGRAM.
RUSSIAN AND POSTED THE VIEWS
PROGRAMS THAT SIGNIFICANT
MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT
PROGRAMMING ALSO OFFER
VOCATIONAL TRAINING FOR THE
WARDS INCLUDING CARPENTRY
ROOFING LANDSCAPING ELECTRICAL
AND PLUMBING. THERE ARE
NUMEROUS OTHER PROGRAMS THAT
IMPLEMENT YOU CAN'T GET
EVIDENCE BASED RESEARCH THAT
ARE PROVEN TO REDUCE RECIDIVISM
GIVE GGG YOU. UNTIL THAT THE
SEAT OUT THE WORLD ON
COMPLETION. OF THEIR TIME DJJ.
YOU IF EFFECTIVE PROGRAMMING
EVENTUALLY. IMPLEMENTED IT'S
VERY LIKELY BOTH EXPENSIVE AND
INCUMBENT THAT WE DELIVER
ACROSS IT COUNTY. WITH GREAT
CONCERN BUT WILL BE DESPERATE
CARE AND TREATMENT OFFERED TO
JUVENILE DEPENDING ON WHAT
COUNTY THEY HAPPEN TO HAVE
COMMITTED THEIR CRIME AND- FOR
THESE REASONS. WE'RE ABOUT THE
REALIGNMENT PROPOSAL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MODERATOR NEXT
WITNESS. NINE SEVENTY FIVE.
THIS IS JOSH DUGGAR
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
AND ON BEHALF OF COLLEAGUES
WITH URBAN COUNTY THE
CALIFORNIA AND RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
COUNTIES ARE LYING ON THE
OBJECTIVES RELATED TO A DJJ
REALIGNMENT BENEFIT TO KEEPING
YOU HOME IN MAINTAINING
COMMUNITY TIME TO PRODUCE
IMPROVED OUTCOMES AND DESIGNING
A SYSTEM THAT DOES NOT RESULT
IN MORE YOU STAYING. UP IN
ADULT COURT SYSTEM. AFTER THE
OF THE NEIGHBORHOOD. COUNTY
SPENT CAN TIME IN PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION ABOUT HOW TO
DEFINE THAT THAT CAN ACHIEVE
THE GOAL. THIS INCLUDES A
STRUCTURE THAT OFFERS RESOURCES
PROTECTION AND FLEXIBILITY THAT
WILL BE NEEDED TO DEVELOP
PROGRAMS. THAT WILL BE NEEDED
TO MEET THE COMPLEX NEEDS OF
THE YOUTH POPULATION WE LOOK
FORWARD TO FURTHER WORKING WITH
THE LEGISLATURE TO BUILD ON
THIS STRUCTURE THANK YOU THANK
YOU MODERATOR NEXT WITNESS. BY
TWENTY FIVE. YES MY NAME IS
CLEARING A BIRD ONE OF THE
TEACHER CALIFORNIA STATE PRISON
CORCORAN I'M ALSO ARE YOU ONE
THOUSAND SIX REPRESENTATIVE. IS
THAT YOU CAN CONCERNS NOT. SO
THAT MEANS A COUPLE PROGRAMS
AND STAFF WAS FACILITY WILL BE
OVERLOOKED. AN IMPORTANCE IN
PROVIDING. THIS VALUABLE
POPULATION WILL BE LOCKED.
ORDER CONCERNS IT'S IN THE
FUTURE WILL BE ON ITS OWN
PROVIDE YOU SERVICE SOMEONE
DOLLARS THAT COULD BE SPENT.
THAT WOULD BE SPENT BY FANS
THEIR OWN INFRASTRUCTURE THE
PROGRAMS THAT ARE OUT. NO WAIT
BECAUSE ALL THAT ARE YEAH. THE
PROFESSIONAL STAFF MEMBERS
TRUCKER PROGRAM ARE IN PLACE
THERE'S NO NEED TO RAISE THE
WHEEL AND WHEN RESOURCES. IT'S
BEEN A POINT HIGHLY TRAINED
EXPERIENCED PROFESSIONAL STAFF
WE ARE NOT IN YOUR BACK ON THE
CITY'S DEDICATED PROFESSIONAL.
CURRENTLY IN THE PIPELINE FOR
YOU. THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS ONE MINUTE PLEASE. LINE
SEVENTY EIGHT. AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS EMILY OWE IT TO YOU
JUST COALITION I SUPPORT THE
LEGISLATURE BJJ REALIGNMENT
PROPOSAL WE NEED TO END THE
CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION VIRUS
IN ADOPTED CARE NOT CAGES
PLANNED FOR OUR YOUNG PEOPLE
ACROSS THE STATE MY COUSIN IS
CURRENTLY SERVING TWELVE YEARS
IN STATE PRISON AND I TRULY
BELIEVE THAT IF HE HAD ACCESS
MENTAL HEALTH AND COMMUNITY
SUPPORT IT WOULD STILL BE HOME
AND DRIVING. AND TODAY. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU
MONTEREY. NEXT WITNESS. LINE
FORTY SEVEN. BY FORTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WAIT A LINE
pHI GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
CALVIN SPELLED AND I AM WITH
THE- DEPARTMENT JUNGLE JUSTICE
INTERVIEWS CORRECTIONAL
FACILITY. CURRENTLY IT'S J. J.
HAS NAY INCREDIBLE STRIDES AND
IMPROVEMENTS IN ALL AREAS
INCLUDING. A CURSORY SHOWING
THE REDUCTION OF VIOLENCE. LOS
RECORDING YOU OFFER FROM. BEING
INSTRUCTIONS WILL YEAH. IF
YOU'RE REBUILDING A NEW HOUSE
WE ARE THE MODEL THAT YOU'RE
LOOKING AT WE ARE THE MISSOURI
MODEL WE FOLLOW THE MISSOURI
MODEL WE'VE DONE EVERYTHING WE
CAN. YOU DON'T GET. TO ENSURE
THE SAFETY OF THE U. WE CHANGE
THE WAY WE APPROACH TO YOU. P.
EIGHTY EIGHT TREATMENT
MODALITIES WE SIT DOWN WE
REDUCED OUR LEVEL OF USE OF
FORCE WE ARE IN THE FOREFRONT
IN THE NATION. THE REDUCTION OF
VIOLENCE. AND REDUCTION OF
COURSE WE CHANGED. AT LEAST
CLASSROOMS WE WANT YOU ALL YEAH.
VERY QUICK TO TAKE THESE KIDS
TEN SECONDS. SHE GAVE IT YEARS
AND YEARS. OF CHANGE U. S.
FORCES CHANGES TO THE CONSENT
DECREE WE DIDN'T AND YOUNGER.
AT THIS LEVEL HE SAID IT WAS
ALL ABOUT MAYBE. CALVET IF YOU
USED. AND NOW WE CAN ONLY
WITNESS I NEED YOU TO WRAP UP
YOUR AT A MINUTE AND FORTY
SECONDS CAN YOU WRAP UP PLEASE
YEAH YEAH YEAH BUT INSTEAD OF
THE CULPRIT BEING YOUR- YOUR
REASON. BUSINESS AND MONEY
MAKING IN THIS COUNTY LITERALLY.
I REQUEST A LITTLE FIVE HELLO
SUPPOSED AGAIN AND USE IN SPAIN
WOULD BE J. J. AND MAY YOUR
GUTS. THE MODEL THAT YOU'RE A
WITNESS THANK YOU YOUR OVER TO
MINUTES THANK YOU THANK YOU
MODERATOR NEXT WITNESS I. BUT
LINE SEVENTY. ONE MINUTE ARE.
ONLY MY NAME IS ISRAEL VIA- CON
AT THE INDIVIDUAL COMMUNITY
MEMBERS FOLLOWING A CAR
STRAIGHT OUT OF THESE
ORIGINALLY OUT OF MISDEMEANORS.
I'M CALLING STRONG OF THE LEAD.
PLAN DJJ ARRIVED IN MY
EXPERIENCE. I'LL SAY IT IS OUT
OF THAT A LOT OF STUDENTS WILL
BE GIVEN JUNE BECAUSE RICHARD%
WAS BUILT A GRADUATION GIFT
ITEMS AND I GOT A LOT OF
PROBATION OFFICERS AND I NEVER
HAD A PROBATION OFFICER HELP ME
OR MY FAMILY IN ANY WAY SHAPE
OR FORM I NEVER ADEQUATELY
LOCATION OFFICER TO GET A JOB
APPLICATION DATA TRINITY CHURCH
SO. I WILL. I'M CONCERNED THAT.
THE DIRECTION THAT THE- JUST TO
PULL BAY BECAUSE COULD NOT THEY
DON'T HELP US. THE REASON BE
DEPORTED. ARE THAT WE DESTROY
OVERSIGHT THANK YOU. MY NEXT
WITNESS PLEA. LONDON SEVENTY.
HI THIS IS A DERELICTION TEST.
WE HAVE THE LOS ANGELES POLICE
PROTECTIVE LEAGUE. TO SCHOOL
POLICE OFFICERS ASSOCIATION AND
OTHERS AROUND LAW ENFORCEMENT
WHO ARE A BIT CONCERNED WITH
HIS COACH TO BOTH. AND THE
GOVERNOR'S APPROACH- WOULD LIKE
TO LINE OURSELVES WITH.
HEALEY'S COMMENTS AND- I THINK
ENCOURAGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
REALLY THINK ABOUT- THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF COUNTIES IN
THE WAY AND THEN THE ABILITY TO
PAY HAD. TO AFFECT CHANGE TO
SOME OF THE OTHER PROGRAMMING
CORRECTIONAL AND A PUBLIC
SAFETY PROGRAM IS DONE ONLINE
TO THEM THEY DON'T HAVE THE
BEST TRACK RECORD. I WOULD URGE
YOU TO RECONSIDER- WHAT THE
STATE'S ROLE SHOULD BE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT WITH THIS
PLEASE MODERATOR. BLIND. TWENTY
THREE. BY TWENTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MOVADO LINE
NINETEEN. YES MY NAME IS
RICHARD EVANS I'M A TEACHER AT
DJJ AND I OPPOSED THE CLOSURE
OF DJJ NOT JUST BECAUSE I'M
THERE BUT I HAVE SEEN OVER THE
LAST THIRTY YEARS A LOT OF
CHANGES BEING MADE AND I
BELIEVE THAT. CLOSING DJJ IT
WOULD TAKE US BACK. AND A LOT
OF THE IMPROVEMENTS WOULD NOT
BE ENCOURAGED WHERE IT'S GOING
TO THE BEACH COUNTIES. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. ONE THIRTY FIVE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS TRACY
WHITE I AM A NEW JJ
PROFESSIONAL INSTRUCTOR AND
MYSELF AS WELL AS MY FELLOW
TEACHERS AND YOU CAN. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. BUT IN SIXTY SIX.
GOOD AFTERNOON DOMINIQUE KNOWN
AS DIRECTOR OF THE POLICY OF
THE CHILDREN'S DEFENSE FUND
CALIFORNIA ARE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR SHE COULD ASK
INTENSIFIED EARLIER WE WANT TO
MAKE IT COMPLETELY CLEAR THAT
CHILDREN'S DEFENSE FUND
CALIFORNIA STRONGLY SUPPORTS
THE LEGISLATIVE ALTERNATE
PROPOSAL BECAUSE IT ENSURE THAT
DJ CLOSURE WILL BE DONE THE
RIGHT WAY PARTICULARLY THROUGH
THE CREATION OF A NEW YOUTH
DEVELOPMENT FOCUSED OVERSIGHT
THESE WILL BE WITHIN THE HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY. TO
ALLOW OUR YOUNG TO REPEAT
RESOURCES OPPORTUNITIES THEY
DESERVE ASSEMBLY INTO ADULTHOOD
THANK YOU THANK. YOU MODERATOR
NEXT WITNESS. NINE FOUR ONE.
LINE FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. FIVE ELEVEN YEAR OLD IN
THE THEATER COALITION I SUPPORT
THE LEGISLATIVE PROPOSAL TO
CLOSE THE DAY DATA RIGHT WHERE
SOMEBODY IMPACTED BY PROBATION
WHAT THE NEW AND ADULTS ON
PROBATION NEVER TO HELP ME LIKE
ISRAEL HAS STATED EARLIER BUT-
I THOUGHT WE NEED TO INVEST IN
THE LOCAL COMMUNITY SUPPORT AND
NOT GIVE MONEY TO PROBATION ONE
CALL THE NINETY DAY DANCE AND
REALIGNING- AND I LAKE COUNTY
ALONE. WIRED ID DETAILS ABOUT
THAT- SEVEN HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE
YOU DID BECAUSE YOU KNOW TWO
HUNDRED THIRTY MILLION DOLLAR
BUDGET CURRENTLY COUNTY WE HAVE
ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED YOU MAY BE
LOWER CRITICAL OF IT BUT A ONE
BILLION OLLAR BUDGET AND WE
HAD A FIGHT FOR YEARS TO GET
OVERSIGHT LOCAL OVERSIGHT. OF
PROBATION OVERSIGHT COMMISSION
I ALMOST GOT ON THE PHONE
CANCEL BECAUSE THE COLD GETTING
HOW TO FIGHT MAKE SURE THAT HE
GETS THAT THEY THAT THEY
ACTUALLY- CREATED AND IT'S
STILL NOT CREATED AND SOLD FOR
OTHER LOCAL KIND OF THIS IS WHY
WE NEED OFFICE OF YOU JUST THAT
THE DAY LEVEL TO MONITOR-
WHAT'S HAPPENING TO YOUNG
PEOPLE AT THE LOCAL LEVEL TO
MONITOR BUT BASS AND I MAKE
SURE THAT THEY'RE GETTING
COMMUNITY BASED SUPPORTS ABOUT
THE WORK. THANK YOU THANK YOU
ONE MINUTE ON THE NOSE THANK
YOU. MODERATOR NEXT WITNESS.
ONE THIRTY. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS A AT THE AND
COORDINATOR FOR THE CAL LAW FOR
YOU CAN COMMITTEE JUST BECAUSE
THEY JUST A COLLECTIVE THAT
THEY ADDITIONAL GOING TO SEE
THAT AS OPPOSED TO HELP THE
PROCESS THE YPG'S COMBO OF OVER
INDUSTRIES IN OVER FIFTEEN
COUNTIES ELECTED JACOB OF THE
NETWORK AND SAYS NOBODY HAS
SOME. SO AND USE ALTERNATIVE
PROPOSAL TO CLOSE THE DAY J. AB
LIGHTWEIGHT IN A WAY THAT
CENTERS OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY THANK YOU THANK
YOU MODERATOR CAN YOU TELL ME
HOW MANY ADDITIONAL CALL IF YOU
HAVE ON THE LINE WITH THE. HOUR
OF TWELVE THIRTY HAVING ARRIVED.
IT DOES LIKE WE HAVE SO.
WAITING TO SEE. IF THE
SEVENTEEN WITNESSES CAN SIMPLY
SAY THEIR NAME ORGANIZATION AND
WHICH PROPOSAL THEY SUPPORT WE
COULD PROBABLY GET THROUGH THEM
IN ABOUT TEN MINUTES IF CAN
PEOPLE CONTINUE TO GO ALONG
I'LL JUST HAVE TO SHUT IT DOWN
SO YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION AND
WHICH PROPOSAL YOU SUPPORT.
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN. NINE
FIFTY ONE. BUT ISRAEL APART OF
SILICON VALLEY DE BUG SO THEY
CALIFORNIA WHERE PART OF THE
CALIFORNIA USED TO BE HERE.
THANK YOU TO YOU CHANEY JR YES.
WHAT ALTERNATIVE PROPOSAL AND
URGE LEGISLATIVE IS BASED ON
AMENDMENTS TO PRIORITIZE NEED
BASED ALTERNATIVES YOU CAN FIND
AT AND YOU CANCERS RESULT OKAY
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. MY.
EIGHTY GARCIA POLICY AND
ADVOCACY MANAGER WITH YOU ALIVE
WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THE LEGISLATURE
BECAUSE OF THE SHUTDOWN DJJ
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. LINE
SEVENTY NINE. A FORMER
PROBATION AND ASK. WE DON'T
BELIEVE WE'RE GOING TO I HAVE I
BECAUSE I. NEVER HELP ME OKAY
YOU. NEXT WITNESS THANK NEXT
WHAT. NOW ORGANIZATION PROPOSAL
SUPPORT PLEASE ONLY. BARCELONA
THE WESTERN CENTER ON NON AND
OF THE LEGISLATUREPROPOSAL
THAT DJ THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
NINE EIGHTY SIX. GOOD AFTERNOON
JIM WOOD BURKE ON THE HAPPENED
FRENCH COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
THAT CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF
LEGISLATURES ALTERNATIVE
PROPOSAL THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. LIVE EIGHTY NINE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
MICHAEL KESSLER FROM LEGAL
SERVICES FOR PRISONERS WITH
CHILDREN WE SUPPORT THE
LEGISLATURE'S DJJ REALIGNMENT
PROPOSAL THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. CLIENTS. ONE
SIXTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NEXT
WITNESS BLIND NINETY. GOOD
AFTERNOON ELIZABETH CALVIN WITH
HUMAN RIGHTS WATCH WE SUPPORT
THE LEGISLATURE ADULTERATED
PROPOSAL AND FULL
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE OFFICE OF
YOUR CHANCES THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. BLYDE EIGHTY EIGHT.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MY NAME IS MARGARET OKAY
AND I'M THE DIRECTOR OF POLICY
WITH THE W. HE WOULD FOR
INSTANCE IF YOU'RE CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF THE MONTH
LEGISLATORS ALTERNATIVE TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE THAT WILL CLOSE
BJJ THE RIGHT WAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. THE
LIGHT NINETY ONE. AND WEBER.
LATER AND NOW WE ARE A STRONG
SUPPORTER LEGISLATIVE
LEGISLATION B. YOU GAVE ME A
LINE OF PROPOSAL ALSO BEING
FORMALLY GARDEN BE. IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. LINE
SEVENTY SIX. UGH GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS ERICA COMMUTE JUST A
COLLISION AND WE SUPPORT THE
LEGISLATORS DJJ REALIGNMENT
BOTH OF THEM THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. NINE FORTY.
HELLO AND THAT IS FROM
COMMUNITY EITHER THE STORE IN
THE. DJJ REALIGNMENT FROM
BECAUSE BJJ THREE BILLION NEXT
WITNESS. LINE SIXTY NINE. HI MY
NAME IS DEBORAH LEON WAS A
COLLEGE ATHLETE DJJ FOR THE
PAST TWENTY YEARS AND I'M
OPPOSED TO THE CLOSURE DJJ
WHICH PROVIDES INTENSIVE SEX
OFFENDER IN PSYCHIATRIC BEDS
LONG TERM THERAPY FOR KILLING
TYRONE MUCH COMMENT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH POSTED. THE CLOSER
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. THERE
ARE LOWER THINK YOU AT THIS
TIME. WONDERFUL THANK YOU TO
ALL THE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WHO PARTICIPATED IN PROVIDING
THEIR COMMENTS ON TODAY'S
AGENDA TOPICS CALL THAT
NINETEEN AS WELL AS THE
DIVISION OF JUVENILE JUSTICE
REALIGNMENT PROPOSAL WE WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION. AS A REMINDER
COLLEAGUES- SHORTLY WILL BEGIN
OUR AFTERNOON HEARING WOULD
TAKE THE JOINT HEARING THE
SENATE BANKING- WITH THE OUR OF.
TWELVE FORTY HAVE BEEN ARRIVED
I WOULD SUGGEST THAT WE
RECONVENE AT. ONE FIFTEEN. ONE
FIFTEEN AGAIN THANK YOU FOR
EVERYONE FOR YOUR PATIENCE THE
COOPERATION WE'VE CONCLUDED
THIS MORNING'S AGENDA THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND
FISCAL REVIEW IS ADJOURNED AND
WE WILL RECONVENE AS A JOINT
HEARING WITH SENATE BANKING-
REGARDING THE DEPART OF
BUSINESS OVERSIGHT AT ONE
FIFTEEN THANK YOU THANK YOU TO
ALL OF OUR PANELISTS WHO
PARTICIPATED IN THIS MORNING'S
HEARING. WE APPRECIA